Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Alexis Frédéric.
Alexis, est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Alexis Poulin. Je suis condateur du
monde moderne, éditorialiste
et ça fait quelques années que je suis
dans le secteur des médias.
Fred
Frédéric Bascuniana. Je suis
actuellement consultant en stratégie. On
appelle ça analyste stratégique. Ça va
être important pour la suite de ce qu'on
dira. J'ai aussi fondé un mouvement
citoyen dont on parlera plus tard.
Si je vous pose des questions. Bien
entendu.
Précaution aratoire. Frédéric, tu es un
ami. Euh, tu as tendu la main à la
chaîne il y a une dizaine d'années,
il y a 13 ans.
Il y a 13 ans. Et je suis très heureux
euh de te recevoir euh parce que c'est
un juste retour des choses et et ne tape
pas sur ton micro, l'ingénieur du son va
monter au plafond. Euh nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour parler
censure, pour parler peut-être Epstein,
pour parler déploiement de stratégie
gouvernementale, d'encadrement de la
population, d'astroturfing, de contrôle
des populations. Frédéric est une pointe
de diamant dans le secteur depuis un
certain nombre d'années. Alexis est en
première ligne pour comprendre les
mouvements sociaux, pour prendre la
température sur internet avec son prisme
de lecture. Euh, on commence par qui ?
Fred. Avec plaisir.
Avec plaisir. C'est quoi l'astrurfing ?
Alors l'astrurfing, ça existe depuis des
décennies he c'est pas forcément lié à
au monde internet. C'est un gouverneur
d'un état américain qui à un moment
donné reçoit des des centaines de
lettres de gens très en colère. Et puis
en regardant le le texte dans les
lettres, il se dit "Mais c'est la même
personne qui les a écrites ?" Et à ce
moment-là, il lance le terme
astroturfing. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'aux
États-Unis, il existe une marque de
gazon artificiel de la marque Astroturf.
Et il emploie cette expression. Pourquoi
? Parce qu'aux États-Unis, quand un
mouvement populaire part d'en bas, on
dit grass route. Ce qui donc signifie
par la racine des herbes par en bas. Et
donc il dit non non dans une interview,
il dit non non c'est pas grass route,
c'est Astroturf. Donc c'est devenu une
blague et un même avec le temps. Et dans
le monde numérique c'est quoi ? C'est
l'art et la manière de fabriquer euh des
une opinion publique,
une opinion publique avec de fausses
foules alors souvent en colère,
diffamante et cetera, de telle sorte que
les gens se disent "H il y a pas de
fumée sans feu ?"
Alexis, on peut se tutoyer ?
Oui. Euh est-ce que tu as déjà vu ça de
ton expérience sur internet ? Euh tu as
un gros compte internet, tu fais
beaucoup de trafic. Est-ce que tu as
déjà vu des mouvements instrumentalisés,
créés de toutes pièces ? Comment tu as
fait pour les expertiser ? Est-ce que tu
es remonté ? sur quelques profils pour
savoir qui était connecté avec qui, qui
fait quoi, comment, à quelle heure ça
arrive, les heures de bureau, pas les
heures de bureau. Est-ce que c'est un
mouvement qui est maintenant automatisé
? Parce que Frédéric, je te ferai parler
après sur le côté automatique des
choses. Alexis,
ouais, on peut dire que c'est énormément
de trafic en réalité organisé par alors
maintenant on appelle ça les fermes de
troll mais on a des campagnes qui sont
organisées. Alors ça peut être souvent
par des partis politiques hein où on aou
des puissances étrangères
ou des puissances étrangères. On va
parler de ça aussi évidemment ou la
France, le gouvernement qui va utiliser
ça évidemment pour des campagnes de
santé publique. Là là par exemple, il y
a il y a il y a un cas d'école en ce
moment, c'est euh French Response qui
est le compte du gouvernement français
qui répond de manière un peu troll pour
s'adapter à l'époque pour faire la
promotion de la diplomatie française. Et
on voit bien qu'il y a tout un
écosystème autour de ce compte pour le
pousser sur les algorithmes notamment
sur X pour que il soit un peu visible
qu' a du monde que ça monte parce qu'ils
commencent et ils sont un peu petits
dans le game face à des comptes
américains de de millions d'abonnés qui
vont qui vont faire le jeu. Donc ça
existe. C'est c'est un outil d'abord un
outil marketing mais c'est un outil
politique aujourd'hui clairement et ça
peut servir aussi à faire du caractère
assassination, c'està-dire à tuer des
réputations pour dire "N'y allez pas, là
c'est un une zone de l'internet qui est
interdite."
Ce que je vois moi depuis depuis une
dizaine d'années, c'est le en fait il y
a une lutte entre l'internet privé, donc
les on va dire les les entreprises
privées et les États pour savoir qui va
avoir la main pour contrôler un peu le
temps de cerveau disponible. Et
clairement aujourd'hui les États ont
décidé de prendre la main, ce qui était
pas le cas il y a de ça quelques années
hein, même si on remonte à l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron, il y a eu de la
struturfing énorme de la part des
oligarques puisque sa tête était sur
tous les magazines en disant "Voter pour
Macron, il est super." Et puis après, il
y a eu des campagnes en ligne et cetera
et notamment les Macronistes, he vous
rappelez tous ces bottes macronistes qui
ont disparu très rapidement une fois
Macron élu. Euh et donc on se retrouve
avec aujourd'hui cette lutte extrêmement
violente euh avec des lois de censure
qui se mettent en place soit-disant pour
protéger la jeunesse. J'imagine qu'on en
parlera euh parce que les États ont
décidé de reprendre la main en disant
"OK, Elon Musk c'est peut-être l'homme
le plus riche du monde mais c'est pas
lui qui fait la loi." C'est d'ailleurs
ce que disait Thierry Breton qui est
maintenant interdit de territoire
américain quand il était commissaire
européen et qu'il a mis en place le DSA.
L'idée c'est de réguler, de dire que ces
espaces ne sont pas des Far West
numériques. Ce ne sont pas des Far West
numériques, hein. Il y a déjà des outils
pour euh censurer des comptes,
interdire, flaguer, dire qu'il y a des
choses interdites qui sont là. Mais il
faut aller plus loin. Typiquement, on
utilise la loi. Alors, particulièrement
en France he d'ailleurs Pavel Durof qui
est le fondateur de télégramité
comme un criminel l'an dernier, explique
que en France, c'est particulier parce
que c'est le seul pays qui criminalise
qui va aller poursuivre les réseaux
sociaux. Dans les autres pays, on les
interdit. On fait en sorte que ce soit
interdit. Euh basta. En France, on
utilise la justice parce qu'on a une
démocratie. Et donc, vous avez un député
Macronist qui fait un signalement sur la
plateforme X pour des contenus criminels
qui est repris par une juge du parquet
qui a été nommée évidemment par un
gouvernement Macronis qui reprend la
balle et qui lance une enquête et cetera
avec perquisition pour que ça a dans ce
sensl.
Je peux te couper ?
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
C'est obligatoire.
Toujours penser contre soi-même et avec
bienveillance.
Sur les réseaux, on voit des pédophiles,
des images à caractère pornographique,
on voit des contenu aux, antisémite,
raciste,
boosté avec des gens qui se
radicalisent, je sais pas. Et et le
parquet saisit, la juge saisit le
parquet ou inversement
aussi pour protéger notre jeunesse.
Alors, elle fait son travail et elle
applique la loi française. Absolument.
Et la loi française est assez
restrictive en matière de liberté
d'expression. Et on a affaire à des
Américains de l'autre côté hein qui sont
propriétaires de ces plateformes qui ont
aucune limite et qui disent "Nous, on a
des néonazies, des antisémites. Alors
les pédocriminels, c'est peut-être la
limite et encore hein." Euh donc c'est
pas du tout la même vision.
Il y a pas de et encore hein. Oui oui le
le Kstein est assez est assez parlant.
Et donc côté français, on applique la
loi et en plus on est aidé par une
équipe extraationale, la Commission
européenne, qui a mis en place le DSA
qui permet d'aller encore plus loin dans
des lois de censure qui seraient pas
autorisé.
C'est quoi le DSA ?
Le DSA, c'est le Digital Single Act qui
est en fait la mise en place des outils
pour contrôler les réseaux sociaux,
notamment en période électorale, pour
protéger les utilisateurs de ces réseaux
sociaux. Là, je reprends la la la les
les termes européens notamment en
matière de vie privée euh et qui est en
fait la première loi importante de
l'Union européenne pour aller à
l'encontre de ces gafames, de ces
plateformes qui faisaient la loi. Alors
déjà, il y a eu beaucoup d'amendes qui
ont été faites, hein. Facebook a payé
des millions de de d'euros, Google
aussi. X maintenant a une amende de 125
millions d'euros. Euh l'idée c'est de
les faire payer, mais maintenant l'idée
c'est aussi de les faire fermer euh ou
du moins de les contrôler au point
queils vont perdre l'audience qu'ils ont
parce que cette audience est devenue
catastrophique hein pour les médias
traditionnels. Euh moi ce que je vois
aujourd'hui au-delà de la loi française
euh c'est qu'on a des milliardaires
nationaux hein, euh Bernard Arnaud,
Boloré, Niel et cetera, qui investissent
des millions
sont philanthropes
qui sont philanthropes parce qu'en fait
prenons le parisien, le le journal
quotidien de Bernard Arnaud, c'est un
journal qui perd 30 millions d'euros par
an. Euh donc Bernard Arnaud met 150
millions d'euros au pot tous les 3 ans
environ pour que ce qu'à un cas ce média
faillitaire continue. Et donc euh si les
milliardaires euh nationaux mettent
autant d'argent dans des médias
nationaux, c'est pour grignoter du
cerveau de français et dire là c'est
c'est c'est mon troupeau de mouton,
laisse-moi faire ce que je veux avec.
C'est ton interprétation.
Oui, mais c'est mais vous allez voir, on
va y arriver. arrivent les milliardaires
globaux euh Musk, Bezos et cetera qui
ont compris que bon finalement les
médias traditionnels c'était un peu
asbine. Jeff Bezos vient de virer 1/3 de
la rédaction du du Washington Post hein
euh comme ça parce que ça coûte trop
cher et que maintenant faut passer à
autre chose hein. Des intelligences
artificielles font le meilleur boulot
que des journalistes aux yeux de Bos.
Euh et puis Elon Musk surtout surtout
lui euh a compris d'ailleurs il paye
plus de 40 milliards de dollars la
plateforme X qui qui enfin Twitter à
l'époque hein qui ne les vaut pas parce
qu'il sait que avec ça en fait il va
toucher, il va aller faire chier dans
dans les pardon pour le terme dans tous
les précarrés euh arriver en disant e il
est sympa ton troupeau de mouton, je
vais voir avec quoi tiens on va jouer
euh les migrants c'est votre problème.
Et donc on a vu, il joue avec la FD, il
joue avec Tommy Robinson en
Grande-Bretagne, on va voir ce qu'il va
faire pour 2027, mais évidemment
aujourd'hui l'ébullition qu'on a en
France, c'est parce que l'an prochain,
on a on a une et donc les milliardaires
nationaux disent "Non, c'est pas
possible. Faites en sorte que ces mecs-l
viennent pas tout flinguer alors qu'on a
mis des années, qu'on a investi quand
même des millions pour choisir qui va
être n champion à la prochaine élection
de course à la saucisse qu'on appelle la
présidentielle. Donc il faut absolument
éviter ça et c'est ce qu'on voit en ce
moment. Frédéric, je me fais l'avocat du
diable. Je me dis la France, l'Europe a
vécu des campagnes d'astroturfing de
puissance étrangère. Les Russes avaient
d'une fermatrol à hauteur de 4000 m².
Ils sont passés à 14000 m². On avait
posé la question au ministère de
l'intérieur russe pour savoir ce qu'ils
en pensaient du fait que ça pourrissait
la relation franco-russe. Ils nous ont
dit que c'était une société privée qui
pouvait rien faire. Bling bling cœur
avec les doigts. Euh Frédéric, de ton
expérience,
quand on a euh des campagnes
d'astroturfing pour modifier une
politique, modifier une opinion
publique, est-ce que c'est légitime la
réaction européenne ? Est-ce que c'est
légitime la réaction française ou est-ce
que ils en profitent aussi pour
s'arranger de leur côté ? Alors, bien
sûr, c'est toujours euh présenté comme
une repost, hein, euh structurante,
hein. On on fait l'objet d'une attaque
euh notamment par euh des officines
étrangères et il faut qu'on s'équipe.
Alors, dans mon écosystème, on sait
qu'il y a des gens comme moi et j'en ai
fait partie qui sont directement ou
indirectement consultés euh pour créer
des euh ce qu'on appelle des personnat
management software. Et alors je traduis
pour l'audience, ce sont des logiciels
spécialisés dans l'animation de profil
et qui vont selon moi provoquer une
véritable, pardon pour les termes
excessifs, mais je l'assume, apocalypse
cognitive à l'échelle de la population
quand ils vont être euh
motorisés par des intelligences
artificielles de plus en plus
fonctionnelles, ergonomique pour les
utilisateurs. On n'y est pas tout à
fait. C'est en train d'arriver. J'en
veux pour preuve le fait que lorsque
notre cher président publie des des
choses par exemple sur X, on a encore
des robots assez rudimentaire qui
viennent dire dans plusieurs langues en
allemand, en portugais et cetera euh
quel président visionnaire et cetera. Et
souvent je fais des des saisis d'écran
et on s'amuse, on regarde. Bon,
évidemment ça fait pas trop peur. On se
dit ils sont au ils sont encore au
début. Bon là, on a deux niveaux de
réalité. On a un premier niveau de
réalité qui est l'aliby structurant de
la Post. Très bien. Honnêtement, ça se
comprend.
Légime.
Légitime. Et c'est comme ça qu'on nous
le présente. Second évidemment, il y en
a probablement d'autres d'ailleurs
niveau de réalité qui est que c'est
l'alibie idéale pour faire de la
cybernétique. Alors peut-être que si tu
veux, on peut parler cybernétique
maintenant. C'est le moment ou jamais.
Alors, il faut toujours faire un petit
peu de pédagogie sur ce que c'est que la
cybernétique. Imaginez que vous soyez,
je sais pas moi, euh un navigateur
athénien qui prend son bateau et qui va
d'Athène à l'île de Crête par exemple.
Euh d'ailleurs, l'occasion de dire que
la cybernétique vient étymologiquement
de la notion de pilotage, hein, ça vient
du mot kybernetis.
Et la cybernétique, c'est pas donc au
doigt mouillé dire "Le vent va dans
telle ou telle direction, je vais
essayer de naviguer au mieux."
Euh c'est l'art et la manière de
comprendre les interactions entre les
vagues et le bateau et d'ajuster le
gouvernail. Maintenant, si je le pour
c'est pour faire comprendre l'idée,
hein. Donc c'est la raison aussi pour
laquelle d'ailleurs avec cette
discipline on forge des concepts tels
que la boucle de rétroaction. D'accord ?
ce que tout le monde peut comprendre
dans sa douche le matin. Tu sais quand
on quand on met l'eau trop chaude et
qu'on est brûlé, après on on met du
temps à ajuster et on arrive à avoir le
thermostat au bon niveau. Et ben, la
cybernétique
lorsque l'on on l'applique à l'échelle
d'une population, c'est un thermostat
géant qui permet de fabriquer des
interactions homme machine, c'est-à-dire
la biologie rencontre la machine de la
manière suivante. Alors, l'équivalent du
gouvernail, c'est quoi ? C'est toutes
les annonces qu'on fait sur un peuple.
d'accord à l'attention d'un peuple et on
prend d'abord la mesure donc ce qui est
fondamental pour bien comprendre la
puissance de la cybernétique donc de ces
modes de pilotage hein d'ailleurs même
étymologie que le terme gouvernance la
gouvernance a la même étymologie que le
mot cybernétitique ou je sais c'est
surprenant mais voilà donc les nouveaux
modes de gouvernance puisque c'est la
manière bonchi chic bon genre de le dire
euh consiste à savoir jusqu'où on peut
aller trop loin avant que ça ne chauffe
et qu'on ait à nouveau les gens dans la
rue par exemple donc c'est c'est une
procédure foncièrement cybernétique.
jusqu'à ce que ça passe. Comme le disait
Pierre Édouard Philippe à un moment
donné, pour moi c'est l'interview
l'interview la plus intéressante euh de
la décennie parce que c'est l'aveu
ultime, hein. C'est lorsque lors d'une
conférence dans une grande école à Les
secces, il dit "C'est très intéressant
pour nous de constater empiriquement que
lorsqu'on va au-delà d'une certaine
limite, tiens, il se passe rien." Donc
ça nous donne envie d'aller toujours
plus loin. Donc la cybernétique, c'est
ce cet énorme thermostat appliqué à une
population et qui maintenant est
motorisé par les intelligences
artificielles qui ont besoin évidemment
donc les si je dis thermostat, il y a
prise de température. Prise de
température, c'est la data. Donc
l'analyse de la data n'a jamais été
aussi puissante et la montée en
puissance des des calculateurs est
exponentielle. Donc voilà pourquoi je
parle d'apocalypse cognitive parce que
dans un autre niveau de réalité, comment
imaginer qu'il ne sucombe pas à la
tentation d'exploiter ces technologies
pour prévoir nos comportements ?
Tu vois le mal, tu vois le mal trop.
Pourquoi ils auraient besoin d'exploiter
nos comportements ? La situation
économique va bien. Tout le monde arrive
à chauffer. Nos étudiants sont font des
repas gargantues que trois fois par
jour. Nos taxis ont un business
florissant. Ils roulent tous en en en
limousine et et euh et madame Michu n'a
jamais été aussi heureuse.
Voilà. Alors, l'occasion de dire que euh
la voix d'exacceptabilité, si tu veux,
de cette façon de monitorer les foules
euh passe par des termes euh qui ont été
forgés par des des prix Nobel qui ont
eux-mêmes enrichi la connaissance alors
de ce qu'on appelle pompeusement hein
théorie cognitive fondamentale
appliquée. Je dis ça parce que c'est une
formation que j'ai suivie. Donc c'est
une manière de dire on va comprendre
hein, c'est la c'est cette capacité qui
est unique dans le règne animal. L'être
humain, c'est le seul animal qui
réfléchit à la manière dont il
réfléchit.
Bon donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs, ça porte un nom, on appelle
ça la métacognition. Tout est basé
là-dessus. C'est c'est ça commence par
une obsession qui est tout à fait saine
de la part de chercheur de renom pour
devenir après donc les rudiments de ce
qu'on appelle l'économie
comportementale. Donc là on a des
fondateurs de tout ça. Ça a commencé il
y a plus de 15 20 ans. D'accord. Le
grand nom à la matière, c'est Daniel
Cannman qui a écrit un bouquin sur les
deux vitesses de fonctionnement du
cerveau et lui forge littéralement tout
ce que les gens trouve dans le monde
bisouours de LinkedIn au quotidien,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui parlent en
mode bon chic bon genre euh de des
derniers billets cognitifs qu'ils ont
identifié chez les consommateurs. Donc
ça commence comme ça et c'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça l'économie
comportementale. Ensuite arrive Richard
Taller qui lui aussi bénéficie d'un prix
Nobel et fait un hommage dès la première
page de son bouquin à Daniel Camman en
disant "Sans lui, je n'aurais jamais pu
développer la thèse du nudge qui est la
sienne."
Ça arrive, ça arrive même au meilleur.
C'est pas ça, c'est maman. Bah
alors là prioritaire
maman, je te rappelle.
Donc là-dessus arrivent si tu veux tous
les théoriciens de l'économie
comportementale qui vont franchir un
autre rubicon qui est celui de
l'ergonomie de l'information. Ils se
qualifient eux-mêmes de choice architect
les architectes du choix. Donc je répète
premier jalon, on commence à comprendre
nos réactions
épidermiques reptilienne. Donc j'y
reviendrai peut-être après pour refaire
la pédagogie parce que c'est là que le
docteur Spock rencontre Homer Simpson.
Je t'expliquerai après pourquoi on a
tous les fait
je fais simple
là on se retrouve avec des technologies
pour
influencer encadr diriger
vers
un sens ou résister à un autre sens
censé avoir des politiques et un
gouvernement et des fonctionnaires qui
bossent pour nous protéger nous aider
sauver la France sauver la balance
commerciale le PIB et tout ce qui va
avec ils sont sous pression de facteurs
externes et exotiques comme la guerre
économique, des puissances béliqueuses,
des des des sécessionnistes religieux ou
économiques, on en pass meilleurs.
Ils ont la technologie pour Je je te
coupe la parole, tu reviendras tout de
suite ou si tu veux terminer
euh alors peut-être juste préciser
justement pour les gens qui ne seraient
pas très familiers de ces concepts-là,
ça vaut la peine d'aller faire leur
recherche et de s'intéresser donc à
l'architecture de l'information. On
appelle ça aussi les ergonomes de
l'information. On parle aussi d'une
science qui a émergé avec les gars
femmes qui est la captologie. D'accord ?
Donc c'est l'art et la manière de gérer
cette économie psychique he l'expression
commence à émerger. Donc l'économie de
la tension à partir du moment où on
maîtrise, on comprend l'or noir de
l'attention, on ne peut pas évidemment
imaginer que ceux qui nous gouvernent
n'en fassent pas une variable en quelque
sorte enfin une méthode pour paramétrer,
hein comme autant de leviers cognitifs
euh
et calibrer leur propre communication.
D'accord ? Et donc il faut vraiment que
les gens qui ne sont pas familiers de
tout ça fassent leur recherche pour
comprendre que dans un contexte où on
est capable de stocker d'énormes volumes
de données, on comprend mieux le
comportement humain et on peut en faire
usage.
On peut l'extrapoler.
Ah mais bien sûr qu'on peut les
l'extrapoler. C'est exactement ce qui se
passe en ce moment. C'est-à-dire que là
en fait les apprentis sorciers du nudge
de l'économie comportementale se disent
et là je pense que l'expression est
adaptée. Il y a parfois des bugs encore
dans la matrice. Cette chaîne est encore
un bug dans la matrice.
Pour l'instant soutenez-nous sur Tip. On
a vraiment besoin de vous. sans vous, on
va périquiter et et euh il faut vraiment
que vous nous souteniez, nous financer,
c'est notre indépendance. Alexis, quand
tu vois Frédéric queon connaît depuis
bientôt deux décennies, qui nous connaît
dans d'autres vies, qui est un réel
professionnel de ce qui ce qui est
l'économie cognitive ou la guerre
informationnelle, toi quand tu l'entends
parler et quand tu vois d'autres auteurs
agités la guerre cognitive, la guerre
informationnelle et qui font des
bouquins à partir de fich Wikipédia,
est-ce que tu les croises ? Est-ce que
tu te fais attaquer par eux ? Est-ce
qu'ils ont déjà essayé de te corneriser
à tort ou à raison ? Qu'est-ce que tu
peux voir ? Qu'est-ce que tu analyses
dans ce que Frédéric voit ? Et est-ce
que tu peux ou est-ce que tu l'as vu
retranscrit sur internet ?
Bah, c'est ce qu'on disait. Oui, sur le
le le Twitter par exemple, X est
vraiment le l'exemple flagrant de de ça
avec cette idée de la la polarisation,
de la montée aux extrêmes ou un contenu
qui va être émotionnel, qui va provoquer
davantage de réaction alors que un
contenu qui va être beaucoup plus
factuel bah sera moins sera moins
repris. Donc c'est vraiment une guerre
de l'attention mais par le biais des
émotions, hein. Ça le le le l'aspect
émotionnel est extrêmement important
aujourd'hui. D'ailleurs, la hier, il y
avait l'interview de de Zelinski par Léa
Salamé où il a il a ressorti son plus
beau jeu d'acteur pour montrer son
émotion parce qu'il voilà, il a compris,
il faut remettre de l'émotion dans cette
guerre. Et on est vraiment dans ce
moment-là où effectivement il y a des
auteurs, enfin il y a ceux qui
travaillent à la truelle et puis il y a
ceux qui travaillent avec un pinceau
façon peintre de la Renaissance. Euh et
c'est euh c'est vraiment pour moi le euh
l'outil qui va effectivement arriver à à
destination avec Lia parce que euh on
avait euh avant des petites boutiques,
on bricolait euh avec l'IA, c'est des
c'est plus des fermatrols, ça va être
des pays entiers qui vont pas exister
mais qu'on peut faire exister. Euh
d'ailleurs Lulu veut inventer un état
fictif hein qui va être un paradis
fiscal, mais ça peut aussi jouer en
disant et si on créait aussi un
numérisation de gens qui n'existent pas
euh avec l'idée de numériser l'ensemble
de la planète. Ça c'est aussi euh une
envie euh très très forte portée par les
gars femmes. Euh d'où le EUID he le fait
que tout la vie réelle va être une vie
numérique avant tout hein.
T'explique EU. Alors, EUID, c'est le
passeport numérique européen qui sera le
passeport unique au-dessus du passeport
national papier, hein, qui vous
permettra de de voyager, d'avoir accès à
l'euronuméric aussi, d'avoir accès à
votre portefeuille d'euronumérique,
peut-être de de de vous connecter sur X
et valider votre identité une fois que
on aura atteint tous les échelons de la
du contrôle d'identité.
Et c'est un c'est un c'est c'est public
hein, c'est de loite qui gère ça avec
d'autres cabinets de conseil. Vous avez
un calendrier hein en 2026 euh en
novembre 2026, nous on sera un peu un
peu avant, les États européens membres
de l'Union européenne devront déjà
mettre une première brique hein de de
cette EUID, de cet identifiant numérique
et et puis ça ira très loin avec cette
idée d'avoir une plateforme unique un
peu à la WeChat en Chine qui fait à la
fois système de pénement, euh Facebook,
Twitter, enfin tout est là. L'idée de
l'Europe, c'est ça. D'ailleurs, au au
sommet de Davos cette année au World
Economic Forum euh a été lancé par les
les globalistes, hein, le W social, le
réseau social qui doit remplacer à terme
les réseaux américains pour ce qui est
de notre de notre petit pays. et sur le
l'IA et le fait qu'on va jouer sur les
cerveaux, ça s'accélère vraiment en ce
moment et je dirais qu'il y a une
entreprise qui qui est précurseur et qui
est en train de de de de gagner tout et
pas lentir qui a été fondé par Peter
Till et qui a des contrats mais à
hauteur de milliards avec le
gouvernement britannique évidemment la
DARPA, le gouvernement américain mais
aussi les Français hein, le
renseignement français qui travaille
avec Palentir. Et cette entreprise
évidemment gère le big data et c'est
vraiment pour moi ceux qui aujourd'hui
gouvernent enfin d'une certaine façon
ont les moyens d'aller encore plus loin
dans cette dans ce mapping numérique
dans cette cartographie numérique des
populations pour dire "Ah bah là ça va
sans doute péter là attention il y a un
truc qui se passe appuyons sur un bouton
et et tout est comme ça et d'ailleurs
premier réflexe qu'on les mola en Iran
avec les dernières révoltes coupez tout
coup tout y compris Starlink et celle où
c'est très fort, c'est-à-dire qu'ils
utilisent une technologie pour arriver à
même couper les signaux satellites.
Alors, pas tous, mais globalement l'idée
est de faire un blackout total des
réseaux parce que ça se joue là aussi, y
compris dans des révoltes. On l'a vu à
l'époque des des printemps arabes où
Facebook avait un rôle prépondérant et
là vu surtout des caps sous-marins qui
étaient coupés juste avant. Je j'ouvre
une parenthèse, je rebondis une seconde
après sur Frédéric. Tu parles de
Zelinski, Zelinski, il est sous les
bombes. Ils ont plus de chauffage, ils
ont plus d'eau chaude, c'est l'hiver,
ils ont les radiateurs qui pètent. Le
mec passe à la télé en Occident,
bah il décrit que quand même ça devient
chaud.
Bah bien sûr. Oui,
il a le droit de faire ça.
Ah mais j'ai j'ai pas dit le contraire.
C'est pour ça que je te dis qu'il a eu
raison de reprendre son rôle et de
mettre de l'émotion parce que ce que
vivent les Ukrainiens en ce moment,
c'est insupportable. Et le but est
d'arrêter au plus vite le massacre avec
la question évidemment des territoires
qui est loin d'être réglé. Mais euh la
question c'est que quel jeu va jouer euh
Emmanuel Macron et sa coalition des
volontaires euh avec quel moyen enfin
tout ça reste encore des vux pieux.
Enfin si si on veut parler de ce
dossier-là, il est fou parce qu'on est
vraiment dans un dossier du de d'un flou
total euh où on a des promesses,
beaucoup de promesses. Alors sans
rafale, des militaires de l'OTAN qui
vont aller en voilà, mais on ne sait pas
quel moyen logistique, quand, à hauteur
de combien et tout et tout est comme ça.
Donc on se dit "Mais où est-ce qu'ils
vont quoi ? C'est c'est quoi le le but
final ? Si c'est sur pour peser sur des
négociations, on apprend que Macron est
prêt maintenant à reprendre Vladimir
Poutine au téléphone. Très bien. Pour
une discussion sérieuse. Bon, mais pour
dire quoi ? parce que jusqu'à présent,
c'est les Américains et les Russes qui
discutent avec les Ukrainiens qui sont
invités de temps en temps. Et on voit
bien que les Européens à part dire "Ben,
on a une coalition quand même, on est
l'OTAN quand même, on a on a des trucs,
il se passe pas grand-chose." Donc oui,
ce qui se passe en Ukraine
particulièrement là en hiver est
tragique.
Je rebondis sur Freds,
tu réponds pardon. Euh le passeport
numérique, le crédit numérique,
l'authentification numérique euh en
terme de sécurité des données, c'est
safe ou pas safe ?
OK. Est-ce qu'on peut débrancher
quelqu'un du jour au lendemain parce
qu'il a critiqué une boîte, on lui
supprime son compte bancaire, sa
capacité à voter, son utilité civique ?
Oui ou non ? On attend.
On attend record.
Je reviens sur ce que disait Alexis, le
prédictif. Alors c'est ça tombe bien,
j'ai un pote qui est derrière, tu es pas
obligé de parler. On a bossé avec une
boîte qui fait du prédictif à à
l'échelle française et qui fait quelques
petites choses. Euh Alexis dit "Voilà,
ils ont de la data, ils ont accumulé de
la data, maintenant ils ont des
capacités de calcul, ils font du
prédictif, ils anticipent." Bon bah je
je me fais l'avocat du diable. Bah ils
anticipent que dalle. Ils ont pas vu la
guerre arriver, ils ont pas vu la crise
financière arriver, ils ont pas vu la
révolution arabe arriver, ils ont pas vu
les gilets jaunes arrivver. Euh, ils
étaient en panique avec les mouvements
sociaux, avec les gamins les gamins qui
se synchronisaient pour aller piller des
supermarchés, choper des lessives, parce
que on refusait de voir que la France
entièrement disait que quand tu vois des
gamins sortir avec de la crème
hydratante et de la lessive en disant :
"Ça coûte tellement cher que maintenant
j'offre ça à l'anniversaire,
tu as pas l'impression que on se on fait
un peu de la passez-moi l'expression, de
la branlette intellectuelle sur le
prédictif." Alors parce que soit on est
un petit peu retardé attardé en France,
on n'est pas capable d'anticiper
proprement.
D'où ça vient le fait qu' on il soit
complètement largué ? C'est la
technologie qui est pas là. Il y a
personne, il y a pas de l'humain pour
analyser correctement les choses. Tu
vois la chose comment ?
Alors il y a plusieurs niveaux de
réponse. D'abord j'évacue rapidement la
notion d'évolution technologique
exponentielle qui fait que c'est en
train de changer.
Deuxème élément de réponse et là on va
on risque d'être surpris. Deuxème
élément de réponse, la base de toute
ingerie sociale n'est que très rarement
basée sur une parfaite prédictibilité.
Elle est généralement fondée sur la
capacité des ingénieurs sociaux à
amplifier nos passions tristes.
C'est-à-dire que l'anticipation, c'est
pas forcément ce qui les intéresse le
plus. Ce qui les intéresse, c'est de
savoir ce qu'ils vont faire avec la la
tectonique des plaques quand ils
observent. Pour le moment, ils sont, si
tu veux, sur une fenêtre glissante qui
est relativement courtmiste. Ce qui
devient inquiétant, c'est que il il
s'améliore là-dessus. Bon, mais je
voudrais maintenant en profiter pour
insister sur ce qui se produit vraiment.
on est confronté à un processus de
déshumanisation absolu.
Je m'explique.
À partir du moment où la fameuse ce que
les Chinois appelleraient les
transformations silencieuses que
observent et tent de calculer à sur des
échelles de temps de 20 ou 50 ans,
d'accord, en dehors de ces
transformations silencieuses qui se
produisent,
le les modes de gouvernance actuel nous
considèrent véritablement comme de la
biomasse humaine, comme un cheptel.
D'accord ? Et donc occasion de rebondir
sur ce qui a été dit sur les émotions.
Euh en effet, il joue sur nos émotions.
Mais il faut bien dire au public que
quand nous en parlons, nous sommes
nous-mêmes en quelque sorte malgré nous
des agents de cette manipulation
mentale. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on nous
fait aussi craindre nos propres
émotions. Nos émotions sont
consubstantielles de notre intelligence.
Étymologiquement, les émotions, c'est ce
qui nous fait bouger. Euh, on en est
arrivé à un stade où les gens vivent une
psychose au sens cela aussi
étymologique, la peur de l'âme. Ils ont
peur d'avoir des réactions colériques
qui sont un peu le stigmat du petit
peuple, tu vois, qui dès qu'il a des dès
qu'il dérape, on le voit bien au
Royaume-Uni, ça donne quoi ? Des flics
qui viennent taper à la porte et qui
ditent "Vous avez dérapé". D'accord ?
Donc on entretient cette espèce de
d'angoisse d'anxiété autour des
émotions.
Je peux t'arrêter tout de suite par que
c'est
c'est les lois qui font ça.
Attends euh je t'arrête tout de suite.
Bien sûr.
Tu tu as déjà été en Angleterre. Ouais,
bien sûr. J'ai
tu con tu tu connais un peu le coin. Je
me mets à la place du gouvernement
anglais avec tous ces défauts qu'il peut
avoir. Il se retrouve avec une
population qui est segmentée, fragmentée
et il a peut-être peur aussi d'une
guerre civile. Quand tu vois le scandale
des Grooming Gangs qui a été caché par X
magist magistrat, quand tu vois euh une
police qui débarque pour dire
"Maintenant, tu as dit des bêtises parce
que tu as énervé les autres et puis euh
on peut pas laisser monter ça."
Peut-être qu'il joue aussi sur le fait
de mettre le calme, il privilégie le
calme au détriment d'autres opinions.
Alors, c'est là que je vais peut-être à
mon tour être stigmatisable comme
fournisseur de fausses opinions, hein.
Je cite le pouvoir puis qu'il y a un
autre niveau de réalité sur lequel je
voulais arriver, c'est qu'on ne peut pas
être totalement certain actuellement et
nous on est obligé de faire un effort de
on va dire de dialectique entre deux
notions. Soit ils accompagnent le
mouvement et ils essayent avec le
thermostat cybernétique en quelque sorte
par l'observation des foules de le
contrôler. Soit ils jouent aux apprentis
sorciers et ils essayent de voir
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller trop loin
pour d'autant mieux contrôler le peuple
en faisant exactement ce que j'étais en
train de d'expliquer. C'est-à-dire créer
cette psychose. Très important de
comprendre étymologiquement le terme.
C'est pas juste pour faire bien que je
le dis hein. Cette psychose c'est-à-dire
que les gens deviennent de plus en plus
anxieux à l'idée de ressentir ce qu'ils
ressentent et de voir le réel qu'il voi
pour devenir ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs
dans la science de l'ingénierie sociale
des individus agentiques. Je vais
expliquer après ce que c'est parce que
ça veut dire en fait que l'on modélise
et on affine en quelque sorte si tu veux
le sentiment des foules en créant cette
psychose. Maintenant, pourquoi je tenais
aussi à en parler ? Parce que euh sur
d'autres plans, on fait très souvent la
confusion entre émotion et émotivité. Il
y a des émotions saines que l'on peut
accueillir et qui sont structurantes
voir salvatrices. Il y a des colères qui
sont des actions correctrices
nécessaires face à un excès notamment de
persécution, des colères saines. Ça ne
surprend personne. Donc on a un seul mot
pour parler aussi bien de colère
chaotique et potentiellement violente et
de colère saine qui qui procède
notamment de ce qu'on appelle
l'indignation. Nous sommes ici des
indignés potentiels, je crois, sur
beaucoup de sujets. Bon, donc c'est
important de comprendre ce couple parce
que ce que je vois autour de moi, c'est
des gens qui vont jusqu'à quitter les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'ils estiment
qu'ils sont sur une vaste plaque de
vergla
eux. Et c'est là en fait qu'on échoue,
c'est là qu'on se déshumanise. C'est là
qu'en fait on a inoculé en nous
parraction psychique cette espèce de
poison de l'autocensure.
Et c'est là qu'on devient justement et
là c'est très important ce que j'appelle
des individus agentiques, c'est-à-dire
des agents au sens de Stanle Milgram.
Comme je te l'ai dit, moi je fais de
l'analyse
alors expérience très importante que
tout le monde connaît et cite mais ce
que les gens oublient c'est que les gens
qui comme moi d'ailleurs, je travaille
beaucoup sur la conduite du changement
et la
été critiqué d'ailleurs son expérience 5
ans après.
Oui mais en fait je voudrais y revenir
pour oublier l'expérience et parler en
fait du vrai sujet qui est l'essence de
ces travaux. L'essence de ces travaux
c'est dans quelle mesure un agent humain
donc hein d'accord s'efface derrière la
technique pour rentrer dans le processus
qu'on lui a inculqué. H
donc c'est comme ça qu'il finit par
mettre une blouse blanche et tuer des
gens parce qu'on lui a donné un ordre.
Mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui dans un
univers hyper cybernétique et dans un
monde d'industrialisation de
l'automatisation si j'ose dire nous
devenons de plus en plus des justement
des individus dit agentiques au sens de
1000 g à savoir que nous effaçons notre
conscience morale derrière le processus
technologique si tu vois ce que je veux
dire. Et c'est très important d'avoir ça
à l'esprit parce que ça et donc je
reviens à ta première question sur la
prédictibilité, ça oui, on est capable
de le mesurer, de le prédire, de
l'amplifier, de le consolider.
Alexis, tu voulais rebondir ? Oui, je
voulais rebondir sur le le le principe
de l'autocensure en fait qui est au cœur
de de ce qui se passe actuellement avec
ces lois sur les discours de haine.
On voit que on est censé être dans des
démocraties libérales où la parole est
libre encadrée par la loi évidemment. Il
y a des choses qui sont interdites par
la loi. Euh or moi quand je croise des
gens les gens passent leur temps à me
dire merci euh merci de dire les choses,
merci de parler. Comme si déjà plupart
de nos concitoyens avait intégré que la
parole libre était quelque chose qui
n'était pas donné qui était dangereuse
hein. On ne prend pas la parole en
public, on peut perdre son emploi, on
peut être blacklisté de plein de choses.
Donc on on perd son compte en banque, on
ferme sa gueule. On ferme bien sa
gueule. Ça c'est intégré alors qu'on est
dans une démocratie libérale où la
parole normalement est censée nourrir le
débat démocratique. Or, on voit bien que
le débat démocratique se réduit, se
rétrécit, devient une caricature, une
sorte de théâtre et l'autocensure est
devenue la norme avec l'idée de dire
"Bon ben, je vais passer à autre chose,
euh il faut surtout pas que je me mette
dans la sauce, euh restons restons
courtois ou ne disons rien ou faisons
bah ce que font la plupart des Français,
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut gérer la fin du
mois. Euh il y a un prêt à remboursé
pour les plus chanceux. Euh et puis euh
faut il y a les gamins, il y a les
études et donc euh ben ça c'est c'est
pas pour moi la politique, c'est pas
pour moi euh la cybernétique, c'est pas
pour moi tous ces trucs. Donc tant pis,
peu importe. Et ça, on retrouve ça dans
dans toutes les dictatures, hein.
C'est-à-dire, on ne parle pas de
politique, on fait sa vie et et puis ça
intéresse quelques quelques fous, hein,
qui veulent aller au combat ou qui
profitent du système. On est en train de
rentrer là-dedans, hein, clairement.
Moi, moi ce qui me choque actuellement,
c'est de voir le la déconnexion de la
représentation nationale qui passe son
temps dans des débats pris crocolins sur
le budget. Alors, les socialistes vont
faire alliance avec les verts mais qui
vont refaire alliance derrière. Enfin,
tout le monde s'en fout. Là, les
Français, ils ont lâché l'affaire. ces
gens, il y a un monde à part des gens
qui sont élus, qui sont censés être
représentatifs, qui vivent une vie mais
qui est une vie parallèle, hein, dans un
monde fantasmé avec euh des idées sur le
chômage, le machin, le travail. On a
gagné pour 300000 français la retraite,
hein, si on parle de l'État de la
France, le problème c'est le problème
démographique. Euh là, personne veut
veut le prendre de face. Et donc, on a
ce ce monde là où ils ont droit à la
parole, mais ils ne l'utilisent pas.
parce que quand il devraient prendre la
parole pour dénoncer les choses, alors
quelques-uns le font hein. Par exemple
sur l'affaire Epchine, tu as la France
insoumise qui balance, hein, qui
commence à dire "Mais faut qu'on en
parle, faut qu'on fasse un truc". Bon,
ils feront une commission d'enquête
parlementaire, c'est ce qui permet de
d'occuper un peu ces gens-là pour
travailler. Mais il y aura pas de suivi
judiciaire ou quoi que ce soit.
Tuen sais rien.
Généralement,
la commission est pas là. Je vais
prendre la défense de la Franceoumise.
Ils ont vu les victimes. Ils ont vu
Mais c'est les seuls à prendre la parole
pour les victimes. C'est les seuls. Les
autres sont en train de défendre les
coupables. Enfin les les potes d'stein
mais il défendent j'ai plus personne
défendre les potes d'Emstein.
Bah je sais pas Jack Lang a eu droit à
une campagne de de relation publique sur
tous les médias public et privé BFM RTL
France info pour expliquer que écoutez
j' pas vu les images. J'ai vu j'ai vu
Marco Olivier Fogier lui poser question
RTL il a fait BFM également et il a fait
France info parce que les Français
veulent peut-être ses déclarations.
Ah bah ouais mais qu'il les fasse un
juge peut-être.
Non mais voilà, les Français veulent ces
déclarations mais dans un cadre où la
justice plus Ouais, on peut on peut mais
juste pour dire qu'il y a ce monde là et
puis le le monde des Français qui se
taisent, baisse la tête et ont peur pour
le futur clairement parce que ce climat
de peur c'est vraiment ce qui a été
imposé ces dernières années. Emmanuel
Macron, on peut dire qu'il a
chirurgicalement enlevé la joie de vivre
en France. On a eu la coupe du monde, on
l'a gagné.
Euh, il y a pas eu de célébration comme
en 98, ça a été juste une baston sur les
Champs-Élysées. Triste. Dès qu'il y a
une fête sur les Champsélysé, c'est
pareil, ça arrive, c'est lacrimau. Tu as
les pauv qui sont mobilisés matin, midi
et soir, tous les weekends. Il y a pas
un jour où ils sont pas là en Robocop à
dire "Ah, c'est fini, la fête est finie.
La fête est finie." Mais parce que la
fête est finie, façon on est en période
prévolutionnaire. C'està-dire que là,
ils le savent très bien et c'est ça fait
partie de de ce prédictif. Euh tout ce
qui est aujourd'hui de l'ordre de de
l'État, c'est d'organiser le moment où
comme tu dis, ça va finir dans les rues
euh avec des bâtons, avec les uns contre
les autres ou si ça devient politique,
des mecs qui vont reprendre les fourches
à l'ancienne et qui vont aller sur les
lieux de pouvoir.
Oui, ça va être compliqué avec euh des
gros camions qui ont des gros lanceurs
et qui sont d'ailleurs ce qui m'a les
sentors. Ce qui m'a ce qui m'a un petit
peu je me fais le candide, ce qui m'a
surpris en fait, c'est la mitraillette,
la mitrailleuse qui est audessus.
Ouais. Et alors c'est c'était quand même
interpellant. Quand je vous écoute tous
les deux, ça me fait penser au clip des
Pink Floyd, tu sais où il y a les le
cerveau un peu à trafiquer, les gamins
qui se mettent tous alignés,
une autre brique dans le mur
avec le spectre de la guerre qui
revient, ce matin, j'en parlais ce
matin.
Je disais en fait que justement le mur
est en train de se construire. Je dis
comme dans le clim comme dans comme dans
la chanson de Pink Floyd et et plus les
briques vont être hautes, plus ce sera
difficile d'abattre ce mur. Et donc
aujourd'hui, il y a cette prise de
conscience qui doit être faite mais
rapidement et dans le monde occidental
puisqu'on est censé être ce monde de la
démocratie libérale. Euh et dire vous
savez les deux combats du siècle du 21e
siècle pour moi c'est les combats le
combat pour la liberté et pour l'humain,
c'est-à-dire ne pas déshumaniser
l'humain. Or toutes les lois qui
arrivent sont en train de faire en sorte
que l'humain est bon de la matière comme
une autre he de la matière humaine. on
va arriver au minerais humain et et plus
les lois de censure qui sont en train de
réduire nos libertés. Et si on prend pas
conscience de l'importance de ce combat,
parce que ça veut dire que chaque siècle
va apporter sa nouveauté, le 21e siècle
sera la fin de de cette idée de
démocratie libérale portée par le 18e
19e siècle. C'est pour ça qu'il faut
bien prendre conscience que cette
accumulation de choc psychique, cette
stratégie du choc, cette exploitation
des peurs, surexploitation des peurs, de
l'anxiété,
le fait aussi de créer dans la psyché
collective une forme de double
contrainte qui est un terme technique de
de l'ingénierie sociale. C'est-à-dire
alors pour le dire, pardon, je vais être
un petit peu vulgaire, mais il y a une
phrase que j'aime bien de volud n de
coucou Jack Nicholson qui dit "C'est
quand tu sais plus si tu chies du poivre
ou si tu pisses du vinaigre, la
dissonance cognitive." Donc c'est les
gens qui
Jean-Claude Vâ a ajouté le fait d'être
conscient de tout ça peut-être aware.
Non non mais blague à part je reviens
donc sur le terrain d'expérimentation
dont nous sommes qui avait raison
d'ailleurs
qui est donc notre cerveau. Donc c'est
la guerre de 5e génération que les gens
fassent leur recherche là-dessus parce
que ça a été théorisé. D'accord. Et ce
que je voulais surtout amener là dans la
discussion, c'est que il y a en effet
une intentionnalité derrière tout ça qui
est mesurable scientifiquement, qui a
été étudié, qui est la perte d'immunité
collective. C'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où tous ces chocs se diffusent
dans la population, les gens ont des
sujets de clivage qui rendent impossible
l'intelligence collective. Ils
n'arrivent plus en fait à coaliser. Ils
sont sur des luttes horizontales. Ils se
ils se crêpent le chignon les uns les
autres. il n'arrivent plus à coaliser de
manière verticale. Et ça, ça a été non
seulement observé mais théorisé, voilà,
étudié par de nombreux spécialistes en
euh en psychosociologie hein, bien sûr.
Donc là, on est vraiment dans les je
dirais l'armement enfin l'arsenal même
euh basique des ingénieurs sociaux,
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui issue de la
cybernétique nous amène à des techniques
de manipulation mentale de plus en plus
élaborées. Je t'ai pas dit notamment que
les gens qui ont par exemple créé
l'école de Palo Alto il y a longtemps de
de ça au siècle dernier grosso modo au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
donc il y a au premier rang desquels un
des cfondateurs, on va dire de la
cybernétique Grégory Baiton dont le
meilleur ami s'appelait Milton Ericson
qui est celui qui a formalisé les
techniques de d'hypnose. D'accord. Ces
gens-là étaient euh de gentils
bisounours à en leur temps. On disait
ils sont ils ont créé l'école de Palo
une école de psychologie cognitive
alternative qui sort du monde freudien
pour en fait reprogrammer les gens qui
ont notamment des traumas psychiques.
D'accord.
C'est vous qui avez fait l'expérience
avec les souris là ?
Alors avec les souris, avec ils ont
aussi créé des expériences avec les
souris, la société des souris.
Alors ça dépend laquelle parce que là
là où il y a tous les rats qui se
bouffent à la fin où il se laissent
mourir. Ouais. Ou tuas la dénatalité, il
se laisse mourir.
Ouais.
Exactement.
Parce qu'il y avait trop en fait. la
société de l'abondance. Tu veux que
j'explique ? Euh bah en fait, il donne
tout ce qu' tout ce qu'il faut au rat
pour que ce soit le paradis des rats,
quoi. Et comme il y a plus rien, il y a
plus de combat et voilà, les rats se
laissent mourir. Enfin, ils font ils
font plus de de petits rats. Donc c'est
un peu le mais un un laboratoire de la
société occidentale quoi. Et ils
arrivent à se laisser mourir tout
simplement.
Alors justement ce qui est important
maintenant, pourquoi je vous dis tout ça
? Parce que la véritable révélation que
tout le monde oublie de de faire, c'est
que dans les années 80, les profils de
ces deux personnages ont été
déclassifiés. C'était pas des PSIS,
c'était des employés de de l'OSS euh et
des employés c'estàd pas des freelance.
Pas des freelance avec une prestat de
temps en temps. Des employés mais
employé de la CIA.
Voilà
hein. Voilà l'OSS étant l'ancêtre de la
CIA. Bon et on s'est aperçu notamment
que Gregory Baideson dans les années 30
avait fait des expériences qu'on appelle
de chismogenèse, c'est-à-dire générer un
chisme àelle à l'échelle d'une
population. Il a fait au Japon, auxil
Fidji, il a fait en Birmanie, il a fait
dans plein de pays. Et qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait principalement ? il finançait
des médias, il les animait, il détermine
la ligne éditoriale. C'est ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui. Donc dites-vous bien
que si ça se faisait dans les années 30,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est probablement
passé mettre dans l'art d'orchestrer
la pression médiatique. D'accord. Donc
quand quand je voulais revenir au
troisème niveau de réalité qui est quand
tu parlais de prédictibilité,
peut-être qu'on se trompe, peut-être
qu'ils sont en train d'induire dans la
population des choses qu'ils ont
réellement voulu. Je sais que je vais
passer pour un complotisme mais si ça se
trouve dans 6 mois me donnera raison.
Euh d'ailleurs quand on creuse le le
conflit ukrainien, on s'aperçoit que
tout avait commencé en 2014 et pour ceux
qui
même 2009 mais 2014 on a eu les premiers
événements. On a aussi des traces euh de
nombreux reportages où on a des des
processions de diplomates qui vont euh
se réunir en Ukraine et cetera. Voilà
avec avec des voilà des petits fours et
cetera. Voilà. Donc, je voulais vraiment
insister sur le fait aussi que euh les
études qui ont été menées notamment au
sein de l'école de Paloalto et puis
après l'Institut Tavistock et tant
d'autres ont amené notamment des
techniques d'induction de la
schizophrénie. H
Milton Ericson est l'inventeur de la
voilà bon notamment la théorie de la
sollicitation 12 de la sollicitation
paradoxale notamment parce qu'au départ
le prétexte là aussi extrêmement
vertueux consiste à dire il y a dans
dans des environnements hospitaliers
beaucoup de patients notamment en phase
terminale qui ne veulent pas se laisser
soigner. Donc tous ces travaux étaient
basés sur la façon d'amener des gens à
comment dire déclencher des réflexes de
survie. D'accord. Faire du renforcement
vital et cetera. Bon, mais pourquoi
c'est intéressant d'en parler ? Parce
que ce faisant, en travaillant sur ces
sujets-là, il a établi une méthode que
d'ailleurs dans le jargon, on appelle la
méthode d'ide d'Alice au pays des
merveilles. C'est comment est-ce qu'on
peut littéralement induire la
schizophrénie chez un sujet sain. Ça a
donné lieu aux déclassification MK
Ultra.
Ouais.
Et ça a donné lieu notamment aussi à la
création de techniques d'interrogatoire
du nom de Cubark avec un cas au début,
un cas à la fin. Les gens peuvent
rechercher. Vous allez sur Amazon, vous
allez trouver des centaines de bouquins
en vente aux États-Unis. pas forcément
traduit en français, il y en a très peu,
sur cette technique d'interrogatoire qui
consiste justement à créer des
mécanismes, si tu veux de de réponse de
survie chez chez des sujets humains,
d'accord ? Mais après avoir mis en place
toutes les techniques d'isolation
sensorielle qui sont très proches de ce
qu'on a appliqué au niveau collectif
dans des phases de psychose comme celle
induite par le Covid notamment. Tu
parles, tu parles l'espèce de petites
cagettes, pas cagette, l'espèce de bain
en apesanteur, sans bruit, tout ça.
Ça c'est la version intensifiée, ça
c'est la version torture. Mais en fait,
on savait depuis Milton Erikson qui, je
répète a inventé les techniques
d'hypnose les plus, on va dire, les plus
vendues au monde en ce moment. En tout
cas, elles ont un certain leadership.
Euh non non, on est capable justement de
pousser un être humain à rechercher
comme ligne de fuite la possibilité la
moins extrême qui lui est offerte qui
est une sorte de médiane de de survie si
tu veux. Exactement comme émerge
d'ailleurs dans le discours public euh
le camp de la raison par rapport aux
extrêmes. C'est un petit peu la même
chose. On t'isole au milieu des
extrêmes, on crée cette psychose que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui est que tu
ne sais plus si tes émotions sont
saines, salvatrices ou si si c'est de
l'émotivité qui va te trahir et t'amener
à ton autodestruction. Donc dans cette
espèce de réflexe d'anxiété, tu t'en
remets généralement à la médiane. Et en
fait, il faut bien comprendre que les
ingénieurs sociaux, ça c'est le truc
qu'ils ont bien formalisé, bien
algorithmé. Et c'est la raison pour
laquelle tous ceux qui me disent "Non,
non mais la Macronie c'est mort" et
cetera. Je dis "Attendez, moi je
préférerais que que Macron reste pas
trop loin parce que je connais mon
ennemi. Le prochain va bénéficier de la
courbe d'apprentissage euh du précédent
et donc de toutes les erreurs qu'il a
faites. Donc il sera beaucoup plus
séduisant
et de toutes les lois qui ont été
laissées.
Le prochain est déjà là et surtout je la
la magie de la macronie pour ceux qui
connaissent Harry Potter, le vol de mort
qui est le sorcier noir ultra puissant a
brisé son âme dans des recru dans des
objets pour ne pas être tué. Donc il y a
cet objet où il y a son âme. La
Macronie, c'est la même chose.
C'est-à-dire que en marche s'est brisé
dans plein de de parties pour ne jamais
être tué. Et donc on aura de toute façon
la suite qui est ce parti européiste qui
est déjà là. Alors Bernard Casneuve
utilise le terme du baricentre. Alors ça
ça va monter. Vous avez vous avez
entendre parler du baricentre. Qui est
le mieux placé pour être au barentre de
ce centre là qui est la voix de la
raison et que qui dit voilà suivez-nous.
C'est le joueur de flû hein du village
quiemmène les enfants dans dans l'eau.
Mais c'est pas grave c'est lui qui a la
flû. C'était des enfants ou des petits
Liamings ?
C'était des enfants.
C'était des enfants malheureusement. Euh
pour se venger d'ailleurs et
c'est la fameuse ligne de fuite.
Voilà. Et cette ligne de fuite, c'est
c'est clairement aujourd'hui elle elle
est identifiée.
Elle est propulsée par les médias aussi
he qui vont systématiquement essayer de
de faire monter les extrêmes dans un
premier temps, hein. C'est une campagne
électorale, c'est toujours ça. On fait
monter les extrêmes, arrive le second
tour, oh là là, non, surtout pas les
extrêmes, mon dieu, rendez-vous compte,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? C'est
l'assurance de gagner, hein. C'est
l'assurance de gagner. Donc, on a besoin
euh de Jean-Luc Mélenchon, on a besoin
de Marine Le Pen, on a besoin peut-être
encore de plus radical dans le futur euh
pour avoir cette ligne qui qui se qui se
survit, qui se qui s'entretient et qui
rassure parce que derrière les gens sont
rassurés, se disent "On a échappé au
pire". Alors que l'extrême centre, c'est
une réalité et elle est particulièrement
présente dans les lois de censure. On
voit que ça accélère parce que ils sont
pas sûr de gagner à la prochaine et
surtout ce qu'il contribue à faire dans
la continuité de ce que dit mon cher
Alexis, c'est que il crée une espèce de
bulle spéculative que dans le langage
technique des ingénieurs sociaux, on
appelle une paracosmie paracosmos, un
monde parallèle euh dans lequel et
pardon, je vais encore employer un un un
un gros mot un peu cuistre, mais j'aime
bien pousser les gens à faire leur
recherche.
un monde dans lequel les gens vont être
ce qu'on appelle stockisés. Ça veut dire
scotomiser pardon. Ça veut dire en fait
que de en langage psychologique
et en langage manipulatoire
malheureusement parce que maintenant on
connaît bien ces ces mécanismes. C'est
lorsqu'un individu est prêt à tout pour
ne surtout pas quitter le monde
confortable à part à cosmie dans
laquelle il vit qui est motorisé par son
déni. Ça s'appelle la bourgeoisie ça.
Alors ça peut s'appeler la bourgeoisie
mais ça s'appelle j'ai l'impression plus
de 60 ou 80 % des Français qui ont
beaucoup de un gros problème avec la
réalité. Certains se croient totalement
affranchis et capable de la décrire
telle qu'elle est mais sont malgré tout
coincés à l'intérieur de ce je que je
crois ressemblait à un piège à hein.
D'accord. espèce de bulle à l'intérieur
de laquelle ils n'ont pas la vision
systémique. Ils se disent par exemple
tel sauveur providentiel va venir, c'est
la ligne de fuite peut-être qui qui
commence à en terme de curseur aller un
peu à gauche ou à droite selon les les
prismes idéologiques hein. Là on s'en
fiche dans le cadre de notre propos mais
il reste à l'intérieur du même système.
Maintenant, la vraie réflexion, c'est
sommes-nous collectivement capables de
nous affranchir de cette espèce de bulle
spéculative qui, comme disait d'ailleurs
Ginsbourg en parlant du snobisme,
Ginsbourg disait c'est une c'est comme
une bulle de champagne qui hésite entre
l'euro et le paix hein. Quand ça va
éclater, ça va puer. Bon et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe en ce moment.
On vit dans une dans une espèce de de
cosmos parallèle. D'accord. Bon et donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils font en utilisant cette
technique ?
Ilsent, ils pulvérisent littéralement
nos capacités immunitaires. C'est ça le
but, c'est nous sommes trop occupés déjà
en terme de dépense de glucose
intellectuelle
à nous enliser comme nous le faisons
même là d'ailleurs de bonne intention et
nous avons raison. Je veux dire, je suis
pas
tout seul. Moi non, je comprendre. Ce
que j'essaie de dire, c'est que nous
sommes en quelque sorte des
confirmateurs systémiques comme le dit
beaucoup un ami, c'est-à-dire des agents
d'autorégulation sans même nous en
rendre compte. Pourquoi ?
parce que c'est une première étape, on a
besoin du diagnostic, je dis pas le
contraire simplement comme nous avons du
mal à nous élever à une vision
systémique, d'accord, les autres font de
la cybernétique, ils ont en quelque
sorte un avantage sur nous parce qu'ils
voient tout en système parce
que ton prisme de lecture, il y a un
côté bornue mais je vais
Non non, tu vas voir, tu vas voir où je
vais en venir, c'est que mais je parle
évidemment dans les grandes masses,
hein, je parle globalement donc
globalement nous sommes rassurés
lorsqu'on écoute tel ou tel
éditorialiste nous dire voilà avec moi
vous allez un peu vous encaniller voir
le monde tel qu'il est. D'accord ? Non
mais avec plaisir.
Tu as lu Gustave Lebon ?
Oui bien sûr. Psychologie des foules
qui continue.
Oui oui bien sûr. Alors depuis Gustave
Lebont, qu'est-ce qu'on a compris ?
Qu'il y a une part de rebelle attitude
si j'ose dire à l'intérieur du peuple.
Donc on va faire, moi je te conseille de
lire d'ailleurs euh un certain Howard
Bloom euh qui est puissant mais qui a
écrit un un bouquin en plus en deux
tomes euh qui s'appelle le principe de
Lucifer dans lequel il explique que
cette fameuse bulle spéculative, cette
paracosmie, d'accord, se nourrit
maintenant de sa capacité à recycler les
revendications. Donc ça commence
basiquement parce que tout le monde peut
comprendre le walisme, les minorités et
cetera. Mais même ce que l'on croit
parfois être nous-même, hein, euh
extrêmement pur, c'est-à-dire notre
capacité à relever la tête au travers de
gens qui portent bien notre aspiration
quoi, à l'émancipation, en fait, nous
nous enlisons dans les sables mouvants,
hein, de ce que nous pensons être notre
survie. Mais en fait, c'est le
diagnostic, le diagnostic. Et pourquoi
je dis ça ? Juste, je termine là-dessus.
Nous n'avons pas de plan. Nous n'avons
pas de plan. Nous sommes devenus
incapables d'intelligence collective
parce que nous dépensons trop d'énergie
à essayer déjà de déchiffrer le monde.
Et d'ailleurs, j'ai toujours des gens
qui me disent "Ah, tu passes ce soir à
tel endroit et cetera, mais j'ai trop de
vidéos à suivre." C'est amusant. Les
gens qui tentent de se mettre à niveau
disent eux-mêmes "Je suis submergé
d'information".
En une phrase, quand tu as essayé de
penser contre toi-même, ça a donné quoi
?
Alors, quand j'ai Très bonne question
parce que je
Non, non, mais je le fais. Non non mais
est-ce que tu as cru que tu étais venu
pour pousser un cad mon je dis pas ça
parce qu'on se connaît parce qu'en fait
je crois vraiment que tout le monde doit
apprendre à réfléchir comme ça. C'est la
base d'ailleurs de du développement des
Qu'est-ce que je t'ai dit ? Qu'est-ce
que je t'ai dit quand je t'ai je t'ai
accordé le privilège de venir ce soir ?
Je t'ai dit que j'allais te
Je peux le dire ou pas ?
Ouais vas-y. On va te défoncer. J'ai dit
OK je
je reconnais donc Bertrand qui est donc
qui ne m'invite pas parce qu'on se
connaît hein. Bon et ça m'a rassuré. Je
suis au moins
au moins les gens pourront pas croire
que on est en collusion. même si on
s'entend bien. Donc pour réfléchir
contre soi-même, tu sais euh à quel à
quel moment on est forcément tenté de
c'est le moment on est tenté que tu t'es
dit quand tu t'
c'est le moment où on est tenté de
décrocher. On se dit
je vais essayer de me lever 2 secondes
dans cette bulle confortable, d'accord ?
Je vais me moto scotomiser. D'accord.
Donc je vais en fait finalement me
libérer de toute cette souffrance en
restant moi-même dans le déni parce
qu'après tout peut-être qu'il voudrait
quelque part peut-être pas vraiment mon
bien mais suffisamment mon bien pour que
je puisse surnager comme ça. Et donc
parfois j'essaie de me dire comme tu
l'as très bien fait en début d'interview
c'est est-ce qu'il y a pas quelque chose
de légitime à tout ça ? C'est ça penser
contre soi-même actuellement. On n pas
le choix. On est obligé de se demander
par leur prisme idéologique est-ce
qu'après tout ils font pas ce qu'ils
peuvent ? Et quand tu creuses vraiment
le sujet, évidemment qu' il y a des gens
comme moi qui vont t'expliquer non, la
tentation prométéenne est trop
puissante. Là, les techniques de la
cibernétique ont atteint un niveau tel
qu'en effet, je suis désolé de le dire,
mauvaise nouvelle, je serai la cassante
de service avec ma fausse opinion de
complotiste. Mais bien sûr qu'ils sont
tentés, sinon je n'aurais pas été moi
indirectement consulté via un consultant
par quelqu'un qui travaille pour les
services secrets qui a dit "Tu sais, on
travaille sur le cahier des charges d'un
personnat management software en
utilisant les IAS. s'il te plaît. Est-ce
que tu t'y connais ? On a besoin d'aide.
Non, ils sont en train de travailler sur
les outils pour pouvoir justement
provoquer. En
quelle année c'est ça qu'ils ont essayé
de te tamponner ?
L'année dernière
c'était des Français.
Des Français bien sûr.
Ils sont présentés avec une vraie carte
?
Non, pas du tout. C'est pour ça que je
t'ai j'ai bien pris soin de dire
indirectement par un consultant.
Alexis, tu voulais rebondir et une fois
que tu auras rebondi, moi j'aimerais
rebondir sur vos deux traigns.
Ouais. Euh bah en fait, a il y a ce côté
systémique effectivement qui fait qu'on
est enfermé dans la matrice ou dans la
cage de de rat de petit labyrinthe
et où on est très conscient d'avoir une
place qui nous est allouée et comme en
plus on joue avec les les plateformes,
les réseaux sociaux, c'est encore pire
parce que il y a un jeu algorithmique
qui fait que un coup on est vu, un coup
on est pas vu, un coup on est amplifié,
un coup on n'est pas amplifié et puis on
est dans des dans des parcs hein, dans
des dans des tout petits enclos où on
dit bah lui il a le droit à peu près à
cette jauge pour éviter l'anomalie
justement. Euh mais l'anomalie c'est le
c'est Brésil, l'anomalie c'est
Spartacus. L'anomalie elle arrive de
toute façon qu'on le veuille ou non
malgré tous les modèles prédictifs.
Après ce qui se passe dans notre société
Bril
le film Bril absolument ils ne font que
reculer l'échéance.
Oui. Ce qui se passe dans notre société
est nouveau et je pense n'a pas été vu
par les auteurs de dystopie euh c'est la
la démotivation. C'estàd que je pense
pas qu'on va avoir ou j'espère me
tromper mais un mouvement d'émancipation
populaire porté par une figure
extrêmement forte. On a eu les gilets
jaunes. Je pense que ça a été le dernier
moment un peu comme on peut dire que ça
a été le dernier groupe de rock. Bah les
gilets jaunes ont peut-être ce dernier
mouvement là et on a vu comment ça s'est
passé. Il y en a qui sont pas d'accord.
C'est
il est d'accord.
C'est c'est pour dire finalement
regardez ce qui s'est passé. On vous a
massacré. Vous avez pas eu les leaders
les peu de leaders que vous avez eu, ils
ont été traités comme des criminels
éborniés, mutilés mais à la romaine
genre révolte d'esclave. Voilà, envoyz
envoyz les les centurions et et depuis
je pense qu'il y a eu cette
démotivation, la peur évidemment
physique de perdre quelque chose dans
une manifestation, la violence aussi de
la répression qui est montée d'un
niveau. Tout ça de manière républicaine
et démocratique he nous dit-on. Je me
pose des questions quand même et
derrière pas de reprise parce que il y a
eu en plus la période Covid qui a été un
labo à à ciel ouvert de voir comment on
pouvait traiter les gens comme des
souris. Ça a fonctionné de manière
merveilleuse avec quand même un bémol.
Beaucoup de gens ont compris qu'on les
prenait pour des cons mais un peu trop.
Donc ça ça a pas forcément fonctionné.
Et d'ailleurs je reviens sur Davos et le
World Economic Forum. cette année, ils
voulaient rener le dialogue. Ils ont
compris que la confiance était un peu
rompue avec les élites et donc il faut
quand même trouver un truc pour vous
embobiner encore un peu plus euh parce
que on dit il il euh ce il revient
toujours. Qui sont il ? Euh ce sont les
gens qui aujourd'hui profitent de
système et qui ont les manettes du
système ou du moins la vision ass
ainsi que leurs idiots utiles
et puis ceux bah ceux qui profitent je
dis ceux qui ceux qui profitent on va
dire voilà les éléments qui profitent.
Nous dans ce système, on joue le jeu
peut-être de soupape d'une certaine
façon. Euh moi la revue de presse que je
fais tous les matins, je pousse des
coups de gueule. Les gens disent "Merci,
au moins, c'est une colère qui fait
plaisir. Tu as dit des mots que je
disais pas." Euh mais bon, c'est c'est
rassurant. Voilà, il y a le côté doudou,
c'est rassurant et ça permet de se dire
"Je suis pas tout seul." Mais ça c'est
super important hein, déjà de lutter
contre le l'individualisation, le fait
de d'isoler ce que tu parlais de
d'isolement sensoriel. On est en plein
là-dedans. Donc moi, j'essaie de
regrouper de dire on est on est on est
nombreux, beaucoup plus nombreux que ce
que vous pensez. Maintenant,
l'émancipation politique, la sortie du
système, elle passe par une réflexion
longue. Effectivement, ça va pas se
passer avec le les règles du jeu telles
qu'elles sont écrites aujourd'hui, hein.
Clairement, d'ailleurs Macron disait
"Don't follow the rules, hein, quand il
était face à des étudiants américains,
ne suivez pas les règles." Et si on suit
les règles, clairement on a perdu. Donc
il faut trouver une nouvelle grammaire
sans être hors la loi, hein, mais
simplement dire comment on peut essayer
de hacker ce système d'une façon ou
d'une autre en disant euh on va jouer le
jeu mais on va pas forcément jouer le
jeu. On va essayer de passer bah sur un
autre côté, vous fermez la fenêtre,
c'est pas grave, on parle à travers la
fenêtre, on va faire des on langage des
signes. Voilà. Donc travaellement
et c'est ce qu'on fait actuellement,
sachant que il y a toujours le risque de
la démotivation, hein, de dire que bon,
des gens vont s'agréger, peut-être
venir, on va avoir de plus en plus
d'audience ou pas avec le Shadow Ban.
Mais à un moment, des gens vont dire
"Bon, j'ai autre chose à faire." C'était
bien mais bon voilà, il faut passer
quand même à des choses sérieuses. Euh
et puis et puis a enfin là, on va on va
vivre une année 2026, c'est une année de
combat hein pour ce qui est
dire formidable.
Formidable. Oui.
Tu parles latin ? Euh pas temps non,
vas-y
parce que nous on a tu as chologie de de
formidable. Ouais,
vas-y.
Euh je me rappelle plus.
Ah
formidable je sens que c'est pertinent.
Formida de terrifiant.
Terrifiant. Voilà. Ben on est bien
d'accord.
Tu parles pas grec non plus hein.
Ah mais non mais ni ni Grec
mais voilà ça va être une année de
combat terrifiante qui prépare 2027 qui
va être une année alors là de de blague.
La présidentielle je ne pense pas que ce
sera une élection honnête hein,
disons-le.
Pourquoi ? des ingérences extérieures
américaines, des inérences intérieures.
Non non non, tout simplement parce que
Emmanuel Lacron l'a dit hein, il va nous
protéger des ingérences étrangères pour
être bien sûr que de toute façon le
baricentre va gagner. le prétexte idéal.
Le prétexte idéal, le fait que sans
doute cette année il va y avoir des
mouvements sociaux encore, on va trouver
encore plein de choses. Je ne sais pas
en fait en fait aujourd'hui et Trump
d'ailleurs est le symptôme de de ça,
c'est-à-dire la on sent la frénésie ou
du moins l'excitation du malade en face
terminale qui passe sa dernière journée
où tout va bien.
Tu as déjà vu un malade en face
terminale
? Euh j'ai vu mon grand-père. Ouais.
Ouais.
Et et il y a souvent une journée où ah
ça va bien et puis bah le lendemain il
est mort. Euh j'ai un peu l'impression
avec euh avec ce qui se passe
actuellement qu'on est dans cette
journée euh de la veille de la mort.
Fred je te laisse encore 2 minutes parce
que j'aimerais bien rebondir un peu
parce que moi c'est mon petit plaisir
aujourd'hui.
Tu veux rebondir un coup ?
Oui. Euh ce à quoi il fait référence euh
à savoir le combat terrifiant qui arrive
de deux choses unes he trois trois
possibilités. Soit on l'assume
frontalement et bon ben on retombe
encore dans le phénomène de la Jacquerie
et puis la manipulation médiatique, les
infiltrés, l'éclivage interne au
mouvement qui n'arrive pas à s'entendre,
le spontanéisme, le purisme qui fait
rêver parce qu'on se dit "Regardez,
c'est beau, on se retrouve autour d'un
rond-point ou dans une rue, c'est
magnifique mais c'est un peu
déstructuré. Ça veut pas dire que c'est
mal. Je veux dire, c'est la sous-pape.
Bon euh deuxème possibilité de de
réaction euh celle qui fait selon moi
l'objet d'une manipulation collective,
d'une ingénierie sociale pour ressortir
les gros mots, à savoir que on on nous
pousse à la démission, au désengagement,
à la dépression
parce qu'un individu politiquement
désengagé sert totalement le propos de
la caste, hein, de la fameuse oligarchie
élective. Hm.
Au pouvoir.
H
donc dites-vous bien et ça je le dis
pour l'audience en mode un peu provoque
et dans l'espoir qu'on ait des débats
ultérieurs hein, pas forcément
maintenant.
J'aime pas quand tu commences tes
phrases par dites-vous bien.
Bah alors
parce que tu tu es en train de tomber
dans le ce que tu critiques c'est-à-dire
c'est-à-dire que tu côé
tu donnes du prémâché.
Euh justement c'est peut-être pour ça
que je l'ai contrebalancé en disant il y
aura des bas hein. Tu vois j'avais suivi
j'avais suivi ce que je disais. Je
sentais que ça allait pas te plaire te
connaissant. Non non, justement, il y
aura débat derrière. Donc je suis dans
l'assertivité, j'assume totalement mon
propos en sachant qu'il est propice au
débat. Très bien. Mais une chose est
certaine, selon moi, c'est qu'à partir
du moment où l'on se désengage, on leur
rend service et que c'est probablement
le but recherché. C'est-à-dire que le
bombardement psychique, on appelle ça le
carpet bombing, voilà,
de nos consciences, chaque semaine, il y
a une, je pense que tout le monde l'a
ressenti. On se dit cette semaine, on a
encore quelque chose de pire que la
semaine précédente et ça nous surprend
toujours. Ça fait l'objet des
discussions de bistro. On se dit c'est
pas possible. Je pensais pas qu'ils
iraient toujours aussi loin. Donc ça
crée une sorte d'épuisement psychique.
C'est une sorte d'asséchement de notre
capacité mentale à si tu veux à
affronter tous ces termes. Tous ces
toute cette violence en fait si tu veux
qui est qui est qui est sousjacente.
Catatonie émotionnelle continue.
Ouais exactement. Exactement. Et
certains deviennent littéralement
neurovégétatifs quoi, hein. C'est-à-dire
il encéphalogramme zéro en disant je
laisse passer, c'est bon, je mets en
mode automatique, hein. Euh Aristote
l'avait d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière formalisé avant tout le monde et
ils le savent hein. Aristote disait pour
que le en substance, j'ai pas la
citation exacte, le le tyran qui a
besoin de se maintenir au pouvoir doit
doit s'assurer que les gens ont à peine
la tête hors de l'eau et que leur survie
économique prend l'essentiel de leur
énergie. Sinon, ils vont se mettre à
réfléchir en meut et à fonder des
mouvements. Bon, donc la troisème
posture, c'est celle qu'il a évoqué,
c'est celle plus constructive et qui
généralement il
s'appelle Alexis,
hein.
Il s'appelle Alexis.
Bah ouais, mon cher Alexis. Oui,
pourquoi ? J'ai pas oublié. Donc la
troisième posture qui est la plus
rarissime hein, c'est celle à laquelle
fait référence Margarette Med
l'anthropologue quand elle dit bon un
petit groupe de personnes peut changer
les choses. On sait aussi d'après
l'historiographie et cetera que à
l'échelle de notre civilisation ce sont
toujours les les minorités he qui font
basculer des régimes. qu'il est possible
qu'une minorité éclairée euh ne cherche
pas simplement à briller sous les
projecteurs, mais à être éclairante pour
les autres et dire "On a peut-être un
processus structurant à vous proposer
dans lequel on peut reconstruire de
l'intelligence collective en partant du
principe que nous sommes fragmentés,
voir atomisés, tous transformés en
petites monades urbaines égocentriques
dans une société que Christopher Lage
d'ailleurs avait hyper bien décrite
parce que je l'ai relu récemment sur le
narcissisme généralisé, tu vois, où
chacun est dans son compte à soi." Non,
qu'à un moment donné certains euh osent
formuler un plan et c'est ce qu'on a
pas. On n pas de plan. On a que des
gens. Moi franchement je je suis comme
vous hein, je regarde les médias. On a
trop d'éditau et trop de diagnostics à
ce stade. C'est de l'ordre de la
confirmation systémique, je le pense. Ce
que les gens n'osent pas faire, c'est
penser en dehors comme on dit dans la
silicone vallée, en dehors de la boîte,
c'est-à-dire s'élever au-dessus du
système, voir tout ça du point de vue de
Sirius et dire comment est-ce qu'on peut
s'extraire de cette paracosmie.
OK. Ça fait beaucoup de BW pour moi là
d'un coup.
Ouais, mais ils sont ils sont importants
parce qu'ils sont vrais.
Bon,
précis.
On a déjà étudié votre secteur
d'activité. On est des des vieux de
l'internet.
Ce que tu décris Fred pour nous c'est
les choses. Euh je suis désolé de te le
dire mais nous on est sur des trucs
beaucoup plus basiques comme la
soutenabilité des sociétés
thermoindustrielles. Quels sont les
principes mêmes de la soutenabilité de
ces sociétés ? la consommation euh
calorifique exponentielle, les métaux,
les cailloux, les géologues, les
pétroliers, des tuyaux dans le sol et ce
qui vous permet en fait d'avoir un peu
votre glucose dans le cerveau pour
pouvoir se faire un petit peu,
permettez-moi l'expression, de la
branlette intellectuelle pour nous, on
est basique, c'est-à-dire les phénomènes
de manipulation de de de foule, on est
peut-être un peu plus doué que les
autres, donc on a assimilé ça très
rapidement. On a creusé tous les
bouquins, tous les auteurs que tu as pu
lire. Tu sais, tu comprends parce que ça
fait suffisamment d'années que tu me
connais. Je vous pose la question. Je me
fais l'avocat du diable. Euh déjà, je
vais défendre la population qui s'est
mis en catatonie émotionnelle, qui
essaie d'élever ses gosses
tranquillement, qui essaie de survivre,
de payer ses impôts, de survivre à la
violence du quotidien. Il faut pas le
renvouloir à
Je l'ai pas stigmatisé, hein, je la
comprends.
D'accord. J'accepte. Merci d'avoir la
cette précision. Moi, je suis en train
de te chauffer parce que je vais bientôt
te tomber dessus à raccourci.
Tu m'avais prévenu donc
et donc le sois pas gentil avec moi
parce que ça va être dur plus dur.
Donc euh la question que je vous pose
c'est avoir étudié tout ça, vous avez
peut-être autre chose comme motivation.
Vous avez peut-être trouvé une autre
motivation pour ce que tu as mis entre
guillemets il, c'est-à-dire
la stabilité de la de la population
mondiale, éviter que ça parte en guerre
civile de partout, éviter que ça parte
en guerre de partout.
Et quel était le le dénominateur commun
de tout ça ? Nous, on bosse sur
l'énergie, c'est notre clé de voûte,
notre clé de voûte de prisme de lecture.
On bosse, on a infiltré suffisamment de
boîtes qui travaillent dans l'énergie
pour comprendre leurs paranos, leurs
angoisses et ainsi de suite. Et donc, on
voit que l'énergie se rarifie,
que l'énergie bon marché se rarifie
et on se dit la liberté
c'est plus tu as de liberté, plus tu as
d'énergie bon marché. Plus tu as
d'énergie bon marcher, plus tu as de
liberté.
Hm. moins ta d'énergie vont marcher,
moins tu as de liberté et ils sont
obligés de gérer ça.
Mais il y a deux choses. Alors sur
l'énergie, c'est évidemment c'est le
nerf de la guerre et on est des sociétés
extrêmement énergivores, de plus en plus
d'énergiv.
C'est peut-être le nerf de la guerre,
mais c'est peut-être surtout le nerf de
la liberté.
Alors c'est le nerf de la liberté, c'est
bien pour ça qu'elle est ultra contrôlée
et qu'on veut passer au tout électrique.
Euh parce que sans doute qu'avec
l'électricité, c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'avoir le de la data encore une
fois de consommation, d'être sûr qu'on
sait exactement qui fait quoi et
comment. Je parle là pour les maisons
individuelles, hein. Euh vous savez que
le le l'UE est en train de réfléchir à
interdire les les cheminées ouvertes,
hein, puisque c'est très dangereux pour
le climat. Et puis bah, se chauffer au
bois, c'est ancestral, hein, mais c'est
c'est mauvais pour la santé, mauvais
pour le climat. Désolé de vous la
prendre. Euh et donc il y a une guerre
comme ça à bab bruit aussi pour dire
relions tout, faisons le tout
électrique. Or, l'électricité, bah c'est
pas produit par de l'électricité, il
faut derrière des centrales atomiques,
des usines à charbon, des centrales
thermiques et cetera. et et puis la
question du renouvelable he qui est qui
est effectivement la grosse question, on
se rend compte que même les Allemands
sont obligés de dire "Bon, c'est c'est
c'est foireux, il va falloir revenir
peut-être au nucléaire." Et l'Europe, on
est très mal très mal placé en fait dans
ce jeu puisque l'énergie bon marché,
c'est celle qui est dans le sol, c'est
celle qu'on extrait. Et à part le
charbon dans la roure, on a rien.
Il a la Pologne
et un peu la Pologne aussi. Oui, mais
sinon on n pas grand-chose. Euh et donc
ça va pas très loin en fait hein pour
les millions de de citoyens européens.
Euh donc il y a cet aspect-là. L'aspect
contrôle évidemment à partir du moment
où l'énergie est chère, bah on le voit
avec la voiture électrique hein, ça
prend pas. La voiture électrique c'est
beaucoup trop cher. Le parc automobile
en France c'est des voitures qui ont
plus de 12 14 ans parce que les gens
n'achètent pas de voitures neuves. Ça
coûte beaucoup trop cher. Mais on les
pousse malgré tout parce que c'est un
système qui tourne à vide. On est
vraiment dans un truc où ils sont pas
rendus compte que ça arrivait au bout du
mur. Et donc l'Europe pousse pour la fin
du thermique en 2035. Il se rendent
compte que ça marchera pas. Donc on
revient, on détricote, on dit pardon,
excusez-nous, heureusement qu'on est là
parce que sinon vous vous rendez compte,
on aurait eu la catastrophe. Derrière,
ils se rendent bien compte que les les
Français, particulièrement les Français,
mais aussi aller dans d'autres pays
européens n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter
un parc automobile neuf. Donc ils
gardent leur bagnoles hein. Alors
pourtant on leur en met hein des des et
des badges ZFE et des contrôles
techniques tous les 6 mois et des
machins et des trucs. Mais tant pis, on
n pas le choix. Euh le but ultime c'est
quoi ? C'est de dire bah tu auras plus
le droit de prendre ta voiture euh parce
que finalement bah c'est un produit de
luxe. On va encore laisser ça un peu
comme le le problème du tourisme de
masse hein. Le jet privé c'est bien mais
quand ça devient un super avion alors
c'est mauvais pour la planète.
C'est ce qui arrive avec les affeux. Et
c'est ce qui arrive avec les aff bien
sûr puisque ta vieille bagnole n'a plus
le droit de ta cario n'a plus le droit
de rentrer dans la ville des nobliaux.
Euh donc on se retrouve à une sorte de
de nouvel octro de voilà de nouvelles
gestion des des mobilités he ils
appellent ça comme ça avec quand même là
où c'est extrêmement drôle ce que
faisait la Chine il y a une cinquantaine
d'années c'estàdire le vélo.
C'est bien le vélo.
C'est super le vélo. Mais bon il faut
expliquer que c'était la Chine
communiste he le vélo. Maintenant la
Chine communiste, c'est la voiture
électrique. Eux ils ont réussi.
Nous, on est un parc automobile qui a 14
ans. Par contre, les bobos à Paris ont
des vélos.
Il y a juste une faille dans le
raisonnement d'ensemble qui pourrait
être celui de cette oligarchie. Euh
c'est qu'au travers de la question que
tu poses et du sujet qu'on développe là,
on est à nouveau dans l'obsession
homéostatique de ceux qui font de
l'ingénierie sociale. Bah oui,
c'est-à-dire gérer par le thermostat
notre niveau de consommation et faire en
sorte que ni trop, ni pas assez et
cetera. Et la grande faille, c'est à ce
moment-là, puisqu'il semble obtenir de
la part des sociétés avancées comme les
nôres une baisse de la natalité, comment
se fait-il en même temps qu'ils ouvrent
complètement le robinet de la submersion
migratoire ?
On verra ça. Attends, j'arrive. Fa check
en direct de Mathieu ou de MTA, pardon.
Euh source que choisir ? Le chauffage au
bois. Non, le chauffage au bois ne sera
pas interdit. La rumeur de
l'interdiction du chauffage au bois.
J'ai pas dit le chauffage au bois. J'ai
les cheminées à foyer ouvert.
D'accord.
reprends.
Euh, du coup, j'ai oublié.
Ah oui,
donc première première faille dans le
raisonnement, si tenter que le cheptel
humain commence à poser problèmes dans
sa consommation énergétique, pourquoi
encourager la submersion migratoire ?
Donc, c'est qu'il y a probablement une
volonté de gérer un peuple de plus en
plus obéissant, mis en concurrence avec
le précédent, les légataires de les
générations précédentes, les combats
sociaux. essaie toujours de de penser
contre toi. La natalité se casse la
binet. On a un système de retraite qui
ressemble plus de plus en plus à une
pyramide de Pond.
Ils ont décidé de faire rentrer de
nouveaux travailleurs très qualifiés et
pour payer nos retraites.
Et tu connais pas le principe de la du
diable toi.
Ouais. Non mais
et donc le le ils ont fait il faut voir
son air gognard au moment où il pose la
question pour comprendre le sous-entend.
OK.
J'ai pas d'ergognard je sais pas tout le
temps Gognard. Exactement.
Mais surtout là,
concentrez-vous. C'est un sujet
important.
Ouais.
Et c'est euh pour tout vous dire
pourquoi c'est un sujet important. On a
bosser sur les flux migratoires il y a
une vingtaine d'années de Mayottes en
passant par quelques pays de la ceinture
méditerranéenne. On a croisé des gens
qui étaient abandonnés dans le désert
sans bouteille d'eau, sans rien. On a
croisé des gars maillotte, ce qu'ils
appellent la campagne, c'est la jungle
profonde où ils essayaient désespérément
de faire pousser les tomates et il y
avait des gars qui avaient la lèpre.
C'est gens qui souffrent. Donc soyez
sérieux, c'est un sujet qui me plaît
beaucoup et on d'ailleurs on embrasse
monsieur Zigler en Suisse
et et on espère qu'il va bien.
Donc sur les flux migratoires, tu
voulais rajouter que il quoi ils sont en
train de faire rentrer des gens parce
que ils veulent changer les votes. C'est
l'argument classique.
Alors déjà nous quand on en tant que
collectif agissant, on est toujours sur
les épaules de nos prédécesseurs et on
hérite de leurs combats sociaux. Donc
pour ceux qui se se réclament toujours
de Marx et de et de la gauche, ils ont
pas lu le livre 1 du capital dans lequel
il est pas simplement question du
réservoir de main d'œuvre, mais aussi la
du processus de substitution de main
d'œuvre qui a très bien vulgarisé
d'ailleurs Francis Cousin qui parle de
Marx. Donc j'incite tout le monde à
aller chercher ces conférences et il
explique en fait c'est l'aboutissement
logique hein du cycle capitalistique
dans lequel on a l'épuisement des marges
de profit et il y a un moment donné on a
plus d'autre marge de manœuvre que
d'aller chercher en fait un peuple
corvéable à merci et qui ne va pas se
réclamer des luttes sociales de ceux qui
les ont précédés. Donc un peuple plus
facile à gérer. En tout cas, c'est sa
thèse. Alors, si j'essaie de réfléchir
contre moi-même à ce moment-là, la seule
autre possibilité que je vois de
d'explication, c'est leur complète
incompétence et le fait que tout ça leur
échappe. Euh mais il y a un tel laisser
aller qu'on peut difficilement le
qualifier de non crapuleux, hein, se
laisser aller. Je je vois mal comment on
peut s'affranchir de cette manière de
réfléchir.
Non, non, il y a il y a clairement une
volonté et comme tu disais, c'est pas
des travailleurs qualifiés, hein. Il y a
il y a les chiffres qui sont sortis il y
a quelques jours. Euh on a affaire à à à
des gens qui fuient la misère comme tu
le disais hein et et la France est un
pays d'accueil et on dit après tout
c'est vrai pourquoi ne pas tenter sa
chance en France quand on la on la
laisse et c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement mais il faut pas être non
plus aveugle ou borgne sur le fait que
ce ce problème migratoire il est certes
lié à la démographie mais il est aussi
lié aux politiques internationales de
déstabilisation aux marches de l'Europe.
C'est-à-dire que Afghanistan, Libye,
Syrie, on n pas arrêté en fait de faire
en sorte que des points chauds autour de
l'Europe soit là pour que
on l' remporté la démocratie. Alors
ouais bah la démocratie n'a pas été
vraiment un succès et les Américains
sont à la manœuvre. Encore une fois,
d'ailleurs c'est drôle de voir Trump
Trump qui qui a deux deux griefs par
rapport à l'Union européenne. Un, vous
faites n'importe quoi avec l'énergie, de
vous faites n'importe quoi avec la
migration. Euh les États-Unis sont au
cœur de ces deux crises provoquées en
Union européenne. Donc c'est vraiment
rigolo de voir ça. Et tu as tous les
leaders, les Mark Rut, les Young leaders
qui sont de toute façon des l'équipe du
McDonald's hein, qui sont là en disant
"Ah ouais, non mais d'accord mais bon
alors que" et qui et qui disent pas en
fait que c'est un problème qui a été
créé par le le grand le le grand copain
les États-Unis.
Question internet d'ailleurs pour toi
Alexis que je vois passer juste à
l'instant de Jean Jeff pardon
j'ai pas
bon
je ne connais pas Frédéric Bascoun
j'arrive jamais prononcer
je je suis pas hispanophone. Je connais
pas Bascunen
mais Poulin est clairement un
complotiste. Non point interrogation.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux qu'est-ce que tu
peux répondre à Jean
? Alors déjà, c'est quoi un complotiste
? Évidemment,
aujourd'hui le mot complotiste, c'est le
mot valise qui permet de dire qu'il faut
pas réfléchir, il faut surtout pas aller
là parce que ces gens-là sont dangereux.
Dangereux parce que justement c'était
par rapport au barentre. On va aller
chercher un peu où ça
où ça sent la merde he excusez-moi de
l'expression. Mais mais je suis
populiste aussi. On peut aller plus
loin. Moi, je fais des choses évidemment
c'est comme l'endouillette, ça se mange
mais ça sent pas très bon. Mais c'est de
la gastronomie. Et après il y a des
gens, ils préfèrent le McDo, ils
préfèrent des des cordons bleus comme
Macron. Faut pas que ça sente, faut pas
y aller. Et donc le complotisme, c'est
la même chose. On met un peu les mains
dans des trucs où on se dit "Ah, c'est
un coin quand même particulier. Est-ce
que finalement la politique sanitaire du
Covid n'était pas une politique de
contrôle social pour voir jusqu'où on
pouvait aller, apprendre les gens pour
des cons avec les autoattestations de
sortie ?" Enfin, ce moment-là, moi m'a
fait effectivement, on peut le dire,
basculer dans le complotisme si vous
voulez, si vous utilisez ce mot-là. En
fait, ce moment-là m'a fait prendre
conscience d'une chose, c'est que c'est
très facile de manipuler une population
à l'échelle d'un pays.
Tu as pas peut-être pas compris la la
politique du gouvernement.
Alors, je l'ai très bien comprise. Euh
avec ton prisme de lecture.
Avec mon prisme de lecture.
Est-ce que tu m'autorises à faire
l'avocat du diable ? Vas-y, avec
plaisir.
Bon, alors tu sais que nous on a une
communauté à l'échelle mondiale qu'on a
des gars en Chine qui nous ten au
courant qu'à partir du 17 janvier, on
était au courant que ça partait en
sucette en Chine et je t'en passe et des
meilleurs. Tu sais peut-être aussi que
mon parrain était le plus jeune
professeur en médecine en maladie
infectieuse et tropicales et que on
connaît un peu le secteur que le
gouvernement a peut-être pris peur. Mais
complètement
et qu'en prenant peur, il a mis des
conseils de guerre en secret défense et
que machin et que peut-être que la
France a développé ou a aidé les Chinois
à faire peut-être n'importe quoi là-bas.
Bah la France a clairement confinancé le
labo P4 de One
et Petro aussi peut-être et et que
peut-être que ils ont ils ont flippé et
que peut-être ils ont mis une chappe de
plomb parce que ils ont vu un virus qui
avait un degré de rémanence sur les
surfaces importants,
qui était aéroporté
et que l'autoattestation, ils sont dit
bon les Français sont peut-être pas si
cons que ça ils vont se se signer leur
papelard pour s'autoresponsabiliser
parce qu'ils ont bien compris que nous
si on commence à prendre peur nous le
gouvernement c'est que c'était peut-être
important que les Français nous suivent
dans cette histoire là. Quand j'écoute
Fred nous dire "Oui, il s'est fait
verbaliser en pleine montagne, il était
tout seul, il avait pas son arrivé à
tellement de gens,
attends, laisse-moi terminer." Et et il
a pas compris que les gendarmes bon,
peut-être les gendarmes comprenaient
pas. Moi je dis à Fred, tu sais quand tu
as un mec qui se balade avec un virus
qui peut se transmettre et créer un
foyer en forêt auprès des cres des
servidés et que les servidés ensuite
pouvaient être un un bassin de mutation
et queon peut on allait peut-être se
retrouver avec un variant en forêt qui
allait toujours revenir et ainsi de
suite. Arrête de te marrer.
Pardon.
Ouais bah dis pardon. Laisse-moi
terminer.
J'ai dit pardon.
Donc peut-être que il faut toujours
prendre la défense des autres et essayer
de les comprendre. D'accord.
Donc peut-être que le gouvernement avait
dit "OK, on va empêcher les gars."
Alors, j'ai pas compris sur la la plage
mais la forêt nous, on a compris que bah
les ser avait aussi pouvit. Moi je pense
que le gouvernement est pas allé assez
loin. C'est-à-dire qu'il fallait non
seulement que je pote un porte un
masque, mais étant donné que c'est réman
sur les surfaces, il fallait que j'ai
des sacs plastiques sur les chaussures.
Tu tu quand on a tourné pendant le
Covid, ici on avait un protocole qui
s'appelait le protocole Ébolard et je
les faisais désinfecter de la tête au
pied les claviers, les mains vous rempl
les gars le la parce que on a préféré
mettre le curseur très très haut parce
que quand on a vu commencer Macron à
paniquer, on s'est dit si lui commence à
paniquer, c'est que ça doit être très
très grave. Mais c'est l'occasion de
rappeler de rappeler un un précept clé
de l'ingénierie sociale, c'est que elle
est opportuniste.
C'est-à-dire que on n pas besoin d'être
complotiste sur l'origine du virus pour
comprendre qu'ils vont tirer parti comme
une prise de judoca si tu veux de ce de
ce mouvement quoi, de de l'histoire qui
est en train de se faire sous nos yeux,
pandémie mondiale et cetera pour induire
des transformations mais
de leur prisme idéologique, il serait
presque fou de ne pas en profiter.
Je reviens à à euh Alexis Poulin, le
complotiste complotiste confusionniste
ainsi de suite. Donc je te laisse
continuer.
Bah en fait c'est le mot valise qui
permet de de d'essayer de décrédibiliser
absolument une parole non officielle qui
va aller justement dans les marges et
qui va dire bah attendez des sources.
Vos chiffres vous les lisez de cette
façon-là mais on peut les lire aussi de
cette façon-là. Euh j'ai quand même
plusieurs sources étrangères qui nous
font dire des enfin voilà qui sont
officielles, qui ne sont pas des sources
complotistes. Moi ce qui m'a fait
extrêmement rire euh ma chaîne Twitch a
été bannie par Twitch. J'ai reçu un mail
à 19h tu as plus le droit de parler. Euh
c'était euh pendant le Covid justement
parce que je faisais ma revue de presse
hein du monde moderne et que j'avais lu
un article euh un article du Parisien
hein, le journal complotiste comme tout
le monde le sait sur les masques
infectés au graphè voilà qui n'était pas
donc une théorie complotiste qui était
reprise par la presse mainstream sur le
fait que des lots de masque avaient été
rappelés parce que
pollué par du graphè
ça ça a été pris pour discours
complotiste et puis après il y a eu des
signalements et cetera et Twitch a fermé
ma chaîne sans sans sans avoir d'alerte
au auparavant. Donc voilà. Donc c'est
c'est ça le complotisme, c'est faire
fermer des des robinets, des des des
voix discordantes parce que juste on va
sortir une info et il faut pas la sortir
plus que ça. Et puis ça permet aussi de
donner faire arbitre des élégances, de
dire voyez la République, l'arc
républicain, c'est ça, la démocratie
c'est ça. Si vous commencez à rentrer
là-dedans, mais vous êtes dangereux,
vous êtes sédicieux, vous êtes c'est
c'est le mot qui commence en fait à
créer l'ennemi de l'intérieur et à dire
c'est
tu peux créer la panique. et tu crées la
panique parce que bien sûr bah c'est la
la guerre des mondes même si elle a pas
existé cette panique mais on peut on
peut revenir là-dessus c'est c'est le le
fait c'est la peur c'est c'est le
premier élément de peur pour les gens
qui veulent être assurés
systématiquement et le complotisme
vraiment euh ce terme-là et d'ailleurs
c'est c'est très drôle quand on quand on
suit les émissions de conspiracy watch
parce qu'ils inventent maintenant le
turbocomplotisme.
12 soupes, 18 soupes, tu sais pas, mais
ça turbo conspire. Il y a les les la
trumposphère, la conspisère, la
complosphère. Donc ils inventent des
mots pour justement dire que là il y a
des gens qui racontent n'importe quoi.
Et c'est vrai, il y a de la
désinformation, il y a des gens qui
racontent n'importe quoi, il y a des
gens qui créent des fausses informations
volontairement avec des faux sites
internet. J'ai vu passer là dans les
dossiers Einpstein un nombre de faux
incroyable. Donc faites attention.
Évidemment, sur les réseaux sociaux, il
y a à boire et à manger. Euh mais par
contre euh associer quelqu'un comme moi
à cette sphère-là, ça n'a aucun sens si
ce n'est pour dire bah n'y allez pas
parce que lui il raconte n'importe quoi,
il fait des fake news. Je ne fais pas de
Est-ce que tu as essayé de de contacter
des avocats, de porter plainte, de faire
laver ton honneur ? Est-ce que tu as
essayé de
les de monter un dossier pour leur dire
maintenant les gars, on va on va
s'expliquer devant la justice parce que
c'est une attaque à mon honneur. Vous me
créez des problèmes professionnels,
c'est une concurrence déloyale parce que
vous aussi vous avez un site internet
qui parle de machin et vous faites votre
beurre maintenant et moi j'ai quand même
l'impression que vous essayez de
m'assassiner pour récupérer des parts de
marché. Euh est-ce que est-ce que tu as
essayé euh de consulter la justice parce
que euh tu tu penses être de bonnes foi.
Alors alors pour pour euh Oui, je vais
te répondre. Pour Twitch, oui, on est en
procès avec Twitch. Euh alors on est
passé par euh le système français. Euh
on a une énorme un énorme cabinet
d'avocat anglo-saxon face à nous et
maintenant si on veut un procès, faut
aller aux États-Unis. Ça coûte une
fortune. Donc on va voir si on le fait,
si on fait un crowdfunding, si je fais
un truc à la Michael Moore où je me file
moi contre Jeff Bezos. Euh voilà, parce
que ça dit les choses, he c'est-à-dire
que on vous fait croire que vous avez
des recours, que la justice va protéger
les entreprises françaises. Le DSA sert
à ça, protéger les entreprises
française. Donc je voulais jouer sur le
DSA pour dire "Regardez, c'est abusif
puisque mon business qui reposait sur le
stream a été débranché immédiatement par
Amazon Web Service. Qui est propriétaire
de Twitch.
Ça veut dire que tu peux démontrer qu'il
y a un préjudice."
Exactement. Donc voilà, il il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire là sur toutes
les allégations complotistes. Enfin,
c'est tellement flou euh que légalement
je pense qu'il y a rien. J'attaquerai si
on m'accuse évidemment
de de d'autres choses beaucoup plus
graves.
On t' accusé de quoi ?
On m'a accusé bah d'être rouge brun
pareil. C'est c'est ultra flou d'être
confusionniste, hein, puisque je parle
sur des médias d'extrême droite comme
sur des médias d'extrême gauche, comme
je parle sur mon médiia pour une raison
simple, c'est que on a la chance d'être
dans une démocratie libérale, ce que je
disais et donc on a la chance d'avoir
autant d'opinions de de de et de de voix
différentes qui peuvent se parler
encore. Et si vous ne faites pas le
petit trait, la le petit électron qui va
voir tout le monde et qui va non pas
voir un ennemi mais voir quelqu'un avec
qui on n'est pas d'accord tout
simplement, alors ça va très mal se
passer. Et je vois dans des deux côtés
des gens extrêmement sectaires qui
expliquent et et qui font des articles
ensuite pour dire il a pas le droit
d'aller là, vous rendez compte ? Mais ça
va pas, mais c'est n'importe quoi, mais
vous rendez compte ce qu'il fait ? Mais
mais c'est interdit ça, ça il y a il y a
un enclos, il faut pas en sortir.
Attention, soit vous êtes là, soit vous
êtes là. Vous pouvez pas être nulle part
ou partout ou enfin le principe de
Schrodinger. Or, si on n pas cet
électron libre dans la démocratie,
parle pas de chat, j'ai perdu mon chat
la semaine dernière.
Ben moi, c'était en fin décembre. Ouais.
Ouais, faut pas en parler de ça. Euh,
accusé de quoi d'autre ?
Euh, on m'a accusé euh de
dernière en date, on essaie de me coller
l'étiquette antisémite.
Alors, ça c'est ignotte.
Alors, ça je le ferai. Si jamais on
m'écrit des articles et qu'on balance
des trucs, je porterai plainte parce que
j'ai vraiment alors ça c'est
insupportable et j'ai jamais eu un
discours antisémite et jamais de la vie.
J'ai toujours condamné le racisme et
l'antisémitisme. Et ça ça vient. Alors,
c'est des petits réseaux pour dire "Ah
oui, mais regardez à qui il parle.
Regardez ce qu'il fait quand même Dieu
donné machin et cetera." Moi, Dieu
donné, je suis pas d'accord avec une
grande partie de ce qu'il a fait.
Forisson sur scène, c'est pour moi
insupportable. Et voilà, c'est tout. Je
mais après il y a d'autres choses encore
une fois l'électron libre et puis aller
voir et penser contre soi. Donc me
coller des étiquettes parce que j'ai le
courage d'aller parler à des gens avec
qui je suis pas d'accord, je trouve ça
lamentable. Et c'est ce qui fait que la
démocratie est en train de se mourir
tout simplement. Enfin la démocratie de
basse intensité, démocratie
représentative.
Euh donc
je voudrais toi tu as terminé
euh bah oui parce qu'après j'ai plein
d'autres étiquettes si tu veux mais ça
sert à rien. Bah complotiste,
confusionniste extrême gauche et extrême
droite hein. Alors les deux euh
tu es payé en rouble toi. C'est ça.
Agent des agent des russes. Absolument.
Ça tu peux porter plainte.
Ça je peux porter plainte mais pareil
peux porter plainte.
Je pense que tu es surveillé par les
services de renseignement parce que
forcément
j'espère forcément vu ton degré
d'influence sur internet, tu peux créer
des flash mob.
Je veux dire ça ça remonte à loin. Je
sais que j'ai une fiche en France et en
Belgique déjà donc
parce que quand il y a eu la la le
massacre de Charlie Hebdo, j'étais à
Bruxelles et j'ai créé une page Facebook
en disant il faut qu'on se les Français
là faut qu'on fasse un truc parce que je
bossais pour une boîte belge et puis bon
les Belges étaient là un peu choqués
mais pas plus. Puis ah bah quand tu as
Cabu qui se fait butter tu vois Volinski
merde quoi. Enfin moi j'arrête de bosser
quoi. Top il dis faut qu'on fasse un
truc à Paris. Ils font un truc place de
la République. L'équivalent à Bruxelles,
c'est place du Luxembourg. C'est la
grande place où il y a tous les tous les
hobbis de de Bruxelles qui se
retrouvent. Je dis rendez-vous 19h place
du Luxembourg est mort au con. Voilà. Et
je lance le truc sur Facebook sans sans
voilà sans plus. Bon, ça ça prend des
proportions énormes. Euh le consulat
français m'appelle en disant "Bonjour,
vous êtes qui ?" Ben bonjour. Bah, je
suis un citoyen français, pardon. Ah
oui, non parce que nous on avait prévu
un rassemblement devant le consulat euh
de France. Bon, alors bon, la page
Facebook avec trois likes. Donc bah, on
viendra. Mais alors, est-ce que vous
avez prévenu les autorités, les chevins
et tout ça ? Non, pas du tout. Je sais
pas. Bah vous inquiétez pas, on le fait
et cetera. Puis après par des par des
amis, il m'ont dit "Ah ouais ?" Donc du
coup, la police belge a dit "C'est qui
Poulin ?" Les Français ont dit "C'est
qui Poulin ?" Et là, bon, c'est c'était
le début de ma grande carrière de voilà.
Et la fiche, c'était quoi comme fiche ?
Ah, c'était juste c'est qui ce con quoi
? Mais voilà.
Et donc le fait que tu sois payé en
rouble ou pas en rouble, tu peux prouver
grâce à
Ah, je peux prouver que je suis pas payé
en roule. Oui, bien sûr. Mais
et quand quand on te balance ça la à la
figure,
écoute, je
Pourquoi on te balance ça la figure ?
Qui te balance ça ? Est-ce que tu as
cartographié les gens qui te jettent
l'eau propre comme ça ? Oui, globalement
c'est euh c'est le le les médias de
gauche moral hein. Euh donc c'est
conspirac
ça veut dire quoi que gauche moral ?
Bah c'est médiia part c'est conspiracy
watch. C'est les gens qui définissent la
taille de l'enclos et qui disent
"Attention vous savez c'est là ça sent
trop l'endouillette, n'y allez pas."
C'est les gens qui expliquent ce que
c'est que la gauche pure, ce que c'est
que le le fait de de ne pas parler à
l'adversaire politique ou et qui
organise un peu ce théâtre d'une
certaine façon et qui le font bien. Moi,
j'ai j'ai eu donc un article dans Media
Part il y a quelques jours parce que
j'ai j'ai eu la chance d'interviewer
Sopia Shikirou pour la mairie de Paris
qu'elle est en campagne sur mon média et
là immédiatement comme elle a donné la
seule interview c'était sur le monde
moderne tout le monde a regardé et ils
sont dit mais comment elle a pu aller là
mais regardez mais il a invité Charles
Gave il a invité Lauronzon il a il a osé
inviter tu vois et c'est pas possible
parce que en même temps j'ai invité
Clémence Sénéchal j'ai invité
Frustration Magazine enfin bref mais
confusionniste.
Je suis totalement confusionniste.
Absolument. Mais je ne sais pas ce que
ça veut dire en fait. Moi, je
revenons, revenons sur le fait que tu
peux porter plainte parce que on
t'accuse d'être un agent de l'étranger.
Si la situation dégénère queon rentre en
guerre avec la Russie, tu t'attends à
avoir des gendarmes auprès de ton
immeuble qui Non.
Ben non. Si le buz
quand on balance ça quand on balance ça
sur les réseaux que tu es un agent
d'affluence, un agent machin, un agent
mais regarde c'est aller très loin.
C'est simplement parce que j'ai le
malheur comme vous ici de de remonter à
2009 et 2014 concernant l'Ukraine. Quand
on fait ça aujourd'hui, on est accusé de
reprendre le narratif des Russes et puis
j'ai travaillé pour RT France. Alors là,
c'est évidemment c'est à partir de ce
moment-là où j'étais ostracisé
d'ailleurs sur sur les médias
parce que je travaillais pour les Russes
déjà à l'époque. Donc et RT France
était, je le rappelle, une société de
médias français avec des cartes de
presse françaises certes
financé par le créelin,
financé
par de l'argent public russe,
par de l'argent comme France 24, par de
l'argent public français évidemment. et
et donc on se retrouve avec cette
étiquette là et puis on reste là-dedans
en disant voilà, ça ne va pas plus loin.
Sauf que quand vous avez justement ce
principe d'électron libre un peu
provoque aussi bah vous allez là où on
vous dit enfin il y a de la liberté
parce que bizarrement c'est là qu'il y a
de la liberté et donc on l'utilise. Moi
j'essaie
c'est peut-être une liberté qui est
instrumentalisée pour que tu foutes le
bordel. Évidemment, c'est ce qu'ils ont
dit sur les gilets jaunes. Les gilets
jaunes, c'est les Russes. Les punaises
de lit, c'est les Russes. Poulin, c'est
les Russes. Bien sûr. Dès que quelque
chose, c'est Russ
Stein, c'est les Russes. Voilà, c'est le
dernier qui est Russe. Non, mais à un
moment, tu dis "Écoutez, les gars,
peut-être les Russes d'ailleurs."
Et ben c'est peut-être les Russes.
Alors, c'est un peu plus le M6 et le
Mossad sans doute, mais
preuve,
il y a beaucoup de mails en fait qui
vont plus de ce côté-là que du côté
russe. Alors après, peut-être qu'il a
bien caché ses
Peut-être que tu as pas tu as pas lu
tous les mails. Ah,
j'ai pas tous les mails et puis surtout,
il n'a pas fait que des mails. On a vu
que les mails publics et donc peut-être
qu'avec les Russes, il était beaucoup
plus malin qui suivait un protocole
beaucoup plus pointu.
Crypt revenons sur le fait qu'on te
jette l'eau propre régulièrement avec
des accusations.
Pas plus, ça me fait de la pub.
Bon, il y a encore de la DGSI en France.
Il y a encore la DGSE en France. On sait
nous qu'on est on est surveillé comme le
lait sur le feu.
On est protégé encore par la
constitution française. On a arrêté de
chiffrer depuis bien longtemps pour
éviter qu'il devienne paranoïque. On
prend toujours un téléphone qui borne
comme ça ils peuvent toujours nous
surveiller de Z.
Ah on est transparent.
Toi quand tu te fais accuser, est-ce que
tu penses à porter plainte un de ces
quat ?
Je te dis non. Sauf si c'est vraiment ça
rentrait dans dans du du du légal.
Faire faire des papiers qui vont changer
ta fiche Wikipédia.
Non mais ça ça j'ai pas de fiche
Wikipédia et tant mieux. Bon te faire
une réputation quand on tape Alexis
Poulin.
Mais elle est faite ma réputation, elle
est faite euh et j'en suis fier. Je vais
pas faire semblant. C'est ce que vous
voulez que je sois. Bah on va jouer. Je
vais jouer à ça. Mais c'est un jeu. Très
bien. La réputation tu vas pas faire
contre. tu vas dire "OK, vous voulez que
je sois ça, ça vous plaît ?" Moi ça me
déplaît pas non plus parce que justement
je suis l'emmerdeur de service. Euh bah
si c'est ça maintenant, c'est tout ce
que vous avez pour dire c'est un
emmerdeur de service.
Quand quand j'ai eu la la journaliste de
médiia part au téléphone, je dis "Mais
vous rendez compte ce que vous faites en
fait ? Vous êtes là juste pour mettre
une étiquette ?" Bon c'est bien, c'est
votre boulot mais ça sert à quoi par
mettre une étiquette ? Parce qu'on va
rentrer dans son
boulot avec journaliste.
Non ça c'est fini. Ça c'était avant mais
aujourd'hui c'est des gens qui sont là
pour mettre une étiquette pour expliquer
comment penser, comment bien faire.
Attend la peur. Enfin on parle de ça
depuis le début de l'entretien. Donc moi
je suis fier de de de ça.
Tu as déjà été convoqué par la DGSI pour
une audition sur le fait que
je veux dire attends je dire ça va plus
loin. Alors ça va plus loin parce que
j'ai bossé pour les Anglais. J'ai bossé
pour l'ambassade de Grande-Bretagne à
Paris et là je suis passé par la
case en quelle année ?
En 2002 anné
et là je suis passé par la case euh
vérification et j'avais un petite carte
même du ministère des affaires
étrangères. Donc là, j'ai eu le droit à
mon enquête. D'accord.
De proximité,
tout. J'ai tout eu. D'accord. et j'étais
porte-parole adjoint à l'ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne. Donc, j'étais là pour
expliquer au porte-parole qui était un
diplomate du FCO, du forign Office, qui
était Maurice Douillon, qui était machin
parce que il arrive en France, le mec,
il a 5 ans pour comprendre comment ça
fonctionne, avec qui il faut dîner et
comment ça voilà. Et j'étais même le
seul français de l'ambassade à pouvoir
envoyer des des télégrammes en fonction
des déjeuners que j'avais avec les
journalistes français. Donc j'étais là
un agent de la Grande-Bretagne, hein, on
aurait pu le dire. Non, j'étais
français, je bossais simplement pour
l'ambassade de Grande-Bretagne. Euh donc
oui, j'ai rarement bossé pour des
Français. Après, j'ai bossé pour des
boîtes belges, allemandes, pour RT
France. Euh voilà, c'est comme ça. Euh
sauf qu'à l'époque, ben on voilà, on m'a
on m'a pas fait chier pour ça parce que
j'étais pas public. J'étais pas un
personnage public. Là, je deviens un
personnage public. Et effectivement, à
partir du moment où tu es dans la
lumière, c'est plus facile de te tirer
dessus.
Fred, est-ce que tu veux rebondir ou lui
poser des questions ? Euh déjà, je le
remercie pour son combat et je voudrais
dire que complotiste est en effet un
compliment et tant mieux si ça se
professionnalise puisque c'est l'art de
et oui, ça devrait on devrait être
complotiste professionnel. Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est l'art de faire des
hypothèses du pire. Euh si tu lis par
exemple ça me vient à l'esprit parce que
là on est entre entre geek tu je sais
pas je me rappelle plus le nom du
attention le vocabulaire
le je comment s'appelle le créateur de
la société Intel ? Il a publié son
autobiographie en expliquant que la
paranoïa, c'est ce qu'il a toujours
sauvé. C'est l'importance selon lui de
prévoir le scénario du pire. Dans un on
a repris un général sur le côté
paranoïque, c'est pas
être paranoïque, c'est être alerte
évidemment vigilant. Et justement, il y
a une a s'il y a bien confusionnisme,
c'est sur ces termes-là.
Le général en question, c'était le
général Didier Castre et on vous
recommande chaudement cet invit cet
invité qui est passé sur notre
interview. Il y a plein de private jokes
et il y a plein d'œufs de pack caché à
l'intérieur de cette émission et on vous
la recommande chautement et surtout à
nos détracteurs parce que quand ils vont
comprendre quand on va commencer à se
fâcher nous aussi parce que nous aussi
on nous on a fuble de tout un tas de
trucs parce que nous aussi on traîne un
peu partout et qu'on essaie d'avoir un
prisme de lecture perforant
quand on va commencer à sortir du bois
euh ça va saigner entre guillemets et
reviens
donc euh mon cher Alexis est-ce que tu
penses qu'il faut professionnaliser le
le complotisme,
bah c'est déjà un peu le cas parce que
on est dans ce système là où on voit
bien enfin les études sur la confiance
dans les médias traditionnel se suivent
et se ressemble, ça ne fait que ça.
C'est-à-dire que un maximum de de gens
commencent à se dire "Mais on m'aurait
menti mais tous ces t tout toutes ces
nouvelles, tous ces médias n'étaient pas
là pour m'informer. Et donc
effectivement la la sphère la complère
pour reprendre le langage et coucou
Tristan des France prend une ampleur
évidemment large mais c'est pas ça ce
qui ce qui prend de l'ampleur c'est les
sources alternatives
d'information sûr c'estàdire on va avoir
accès à des sources auxquelles on avait
pas accès auparavant et ça c'est
peut-être une chance sur internet et on
va pouvoir aussi faire de l'osint de la
recherche ouverte du journalisme citoyen
parce que justement on a ces moyens de
le faire et on le fait et la Ferpstein
est vraiment emblématique de ça parce
que les médias traditionnels,
je te coupe.
Ouais,
je me fais l'avoqué du diable parce que
tuinterpelles des gens, il y a beaucoup
de gars qui sont perchés sur internet,
les platistes, les gens qui font
repousser des oreilles avec des jus de
fruits, euh des petites sectes, des
microsectes, des grosses sectes, euh euh
des partis politiques, non, je déconne.
On se il faut quand même avoir un phare
dans la nuit.
Il faut avoir un cerveau bien fait, bien
structuré et être conscient justement de
ce que c'est qu'une information sourcée.
Le problème, c'est que beaucoup de gens
ne l'ont pas. Alors, il y a de
l'éducation média et heureusement.
Et c'est Julien Pain qui s'en charge
parfois. Il est
Julien Pain, c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille sur le service public de
l'info et qui est un fact checker comme
on appelle. qu'il est là pour vérifier
les faits et s'assurer que les faits
sont bien des faits et que il y a pas de
fake news. Donc c'est comme ça qu'il
avait expliqué à l'époque du Covid
beaucoup de choses, qu'il explique
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses.
Donc l'éducation média c'est une chose
formidable mais elle doit aller de pair
avec la critique des médias. Alors
aujourd'hui on a une éducation média qui
dit simplement rester dans l'enclos.
Voilà manger cette paille génétiquement
modifiée. C'est pas grave, ça se passera
bien. Et puis n'allez pas n'allez pas
voir ce qu'il y a de l'autre côté de
l'enclos. C'est la chèvre de monsieur
Sega hein. Euh vous serez mangé par le
loup, le complotiste. Enfin ce qui va se
passer qui qui va vous retourner le
cerveau.
Mais justement ce qui est très bien dans
le complotisme c'est le fait que tu sais
un peu c'est le théorème qui dit pardon
tu permets
pour
non mais je vais dans son sens c'est au
contraire on est sur le thème de la la
nécessité des complotistes. C'est vous
connaissez le théorème qui dit que pour
résister à une diffamation il faut
dépenser 10 fois plus d'énergie. Mais
les complotistes qui sont montrés comme
tels en fait on leur rend un vrai
service. Pourquoi ? Parce que pour les
plus sérieux d'entre eux et bien ils
vont passer en effet 10 fois plus
d'énergie à démontrer qu'ils ne sont pas
complotistes. Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire ? De la rhtorique ? Non, ils vont
chercher plus de sources.
Oui.
Donc quand tu te fais traiter de
complotiste au départ effectivement
c'est c'est bon chic bon genre et ça
permet de d'ostraciser euh voilà des des
personnalités comme Alexis.
Mais maintenant pourquoi je parle de
professionnalisation ? parce qu'ils ont
intégré le raisonnement et que je pense
que la meilleure des prises de Judoca à
faire maintenant, celle qui consiste à
dire oui oui et je le revendique parce
que maintenant avec cette étiquette, je
suis obligé de vérifier les faits
beaucoup plus que vous.
Qu'est-ce que disait Maavel ?
À quel propos ?
Avec les serpents et les hommes.
Euh
le plus grand pouvoir, c'est le silence
quand euh de tête le plus grand pouvoir,
c'est le silence quand les
hommes agissent en serpent.
Hm. Alors, j'en ai une meilleure du
cardinal Mazarin qui disait "Il faudêtre
il faudrait être fou pour voir des
complots partout, mais il faudrait
l'être bien plus encore pour n'en voir
nulle part."
Voilà. C'est c'est exactement ça.
C'est-à-dire que euh face à l'idée du
complotisme, il y a quand même l'idée du
complot. Euh et les complots, c'est 80 %
du travail des États. Enfin, d'une
certaine façon. Euh alors, on peut
appeler ça la planification, la
stratégie, mais lisez par exemple le le
le rapports de la Rand Corporation. lis
le le le le gouver le le document sur la
stratégie de sécurité nationale qui a
été publiée par l'administration de
Trump. Euh bah c'est du c'est on peut
appeler ça du complot. Du moins, c'est
c'est un plan pour dire voilà comment on
voit le monde, voilà comment on veut
arriver à une lecture du monde et à une
domination enfin faire valoir nos
intérêts dans cette lutte
informationnelle mais aussi réelle. Donc
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de l'information ? disais sur
l'éducation média, c'est important parce
que il faut être conscient de cette
information et savoir ce qui va ce qui
va ce qui va déboucher.
En août, si on parle de complotisme, me
permet une dernière sailli à ce sujet,
n'oublions pas qu'il y a des mécanismes
d'autorégulation collective qui sont
loin d'être mauvais. Euh je veux dire
même quand on se fait traiter de
complotist, c'est un peu ce que je
voulais aussi exprimer tout à l'heure,
c'est un défi qui est lancé à la raison
pure, si j'ose dire, de se justifier.
Donc si tu veux, soit tu peux endosser
l'étiquette de manière provocatrice en
disant bon ok, tu as raison, cause
toujours, moi je fais mon travail. Mais
tu peux aussi l'exploiter comme le défi
qui t''est lancé donc d'apporter
évidemment plus de solidité, mieux
consolider l'effet, l'analyse des faits.
Donc ce qui est important, c'est de le
voir au niveau collectif. Je pense que
c'est en train de se retourner contre
ceux qui ont créé le concept.
On va on va sortir on va sortir de notre
rôle. On va juste offrir 2 minutes de
notre raisonnement pur. Euh nous, ça
fait une quinzaine d'années qu'on
bringue sur internet, qu'on infiltre
tout ce qu'on peut infiltrer, qu'on
essaie d'aller comprendre et écouter
tout ce qu'on peut comprendre, tout ce
qu'on peut écouter, n'importe où pour
essayer de comprendre ce système. euh
les anticomplotistes, les
déradicalisateurs, ainsi de suite. Nous
ce qu'on en a vu, c'est qu'ils n'ont
fait que radicaliser les mecs d'en face.
Ben ou
en les traitant de débiles, en les
traitant de attends d'imbécile
euh au lieu de leur tendre la main,
d'essayer de leur écouter, de les
écouter, de les challenger gentiment.
Euh euh alors certes, il y en a des
indécotables qui mériteraient qui
mériteraient 15 années des des
rencontres lunaires, tu vois où ah il
faut que je te présente Christian, tu
vas voir, il a des thèses un peu
particulières où le mec m'explique qu'il
y a pas seulement une base russe et et
nazi sur la face cachée de la lune, mais
il y a aussi les Américains qui sont là
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps. Bon, tu
fais
Ah, ils sont forts les champignons cette
année.
Ouais. et et mes premiers degrés donc tu
fais bah ouais mais enfin bon ben
et donc ouais non mais ça c'est mais sur
le les gens qui se posaient des
questions, le fait de se faire insulter
dans tous les sens, le se faire le fait
de se faire emmerder jusqu'au pied de
leur boulot ça les a endurci. Ils ils se
sont euh regroupés au tout départ, il y
a une quinzaine d'années. On les a vu se
regrouper pour se soigner entre eux à
force de se faire insulter
et ils se sont auto radicalisés dans une
bulle parce que au lieu d'avoir une
main, une épaule et une oreille, on leur
a proposé un bâton, des insultes et des
colibès.
Et encore, je je peux dire que cette
radicalisation se passe bien. Ça aurait
pu être beaucoup plus tragique parce
qu'à partir du moment où on s'isole où
on va rentrer dans des cercles de
réalité alternative et cetera,
je trouve que globalement il y a pas eu
de drame, enfin pas plus de drame que ça
sur des des projets d'attentat, des
sectes, des suicides de masse, enfin
voilà. Donc globalement, je pense que
même la la branche complotiste, si on
veut dire, elle est raisonnable,
extrêmement raisonnable. Elle connaît
ses limites aussi. Euh
est-ce que vous pensez que ça vient du
fait que euh notre système éducatif part
à volau, que notre éducation nationale a
plus de budget, que les profs ont plus
le temps de faire leur boulot, euh que
on le on les a fait maigrir, maigrir,
maigrir, maigrir et que maintenant ils
ont plus le temps en fait d'endurcir les
cerveaux de nos nos jeunes du fait de de
du fait que euh comme ils sont pas
endurcis, comme notre système éducatif
ne permet pas de les endurcir
correctement, ils sont au vent de toutes
propagande. Est-ce que quelles sont vos
préconisations pour éviter ça ?
C'est-à-dire éviter ou endurcir et aller
dans le bon sens vers la raison.
C'est quoi vos préconisations ?
Bah, je parlais de l'éducation média
mais qui va de pa avec la critique des
médias par exemple. Ensuite, il y a il y
a une formation sur les les ce qu'on
appelait autrefois les humanités euh
c'est-à-dire la philosophie, la langue,
le le contrôle, la maîtrise de la
langue, c'est quand même la clé ensuite
du d'une compréhension et d'une façon
aussi de retranscrire le monde. On voit
bien que cette marche là même elle elle
est tombée.
Donc on se retrouve dans un moment de de
de
flou de effectivement il y a le film
Idiocratie qui montre très bien ce
processus là de manière humoristique
mais c'est pas drôle quand ça se passe
et et le supplement à cette faillite de
l'éducation nationale qui devrait être
en fait la fabrique du de l'homme libre
la fabrique de du gentilhomme qui va
être éduqué qui va avoir des références
qui va se dire mais moi ça m'intéresse.
Moi, j'ai eu la chance encore de passer
par un système éducatif où j'ai pu
découvrir plein de sources parce que
j'avais des profs justement qui me
donnaient des clés. C'est peut-être pas
le cas aujourd'hui malheureusement et et
et arrive par-dessus les réseaux
sociaux. Et là, je vais être très
critique des réseaux sociaux parce qu'en
réalité oui, quand des gamins de moins
de 15 ans ont TikTok, Snapchat et
passent la journée à faire et moi je les
vois taper dans le métro avec une
rapidité confondante des messages avec
des emojis partout, des machins pour se
raconter bon hein, avec la peur du
physique qui va se lier à ça puisqu'on
va passer sur le numérique d'office,
qu'on va avoir des des heures et des
heures d'attention prise par des vidéos
qui sont toutes similaires parce que
l'algorithme a décidé que tu regarderais
que ça. C'est quelque chose
effectivement qui fait que votre cerveau
devient de la bouille. Et donc limiter
l'accès, OK, mais c'est pas forcément ça
la solution.
Alors, limiter l'accès, c'est pas ça la
Donc la solution, c'est quoi ?
C'est l'éducation encore une fois et
mais peut-être que la case parentale
déjà, elle est tombée aussi et donc il y
a plus de parents qui éduquent et donc
il y a plus que des gamins qui sont
livrés à eux-mêmes.
Et le fait que l'État souhaite éduquer
tes gamins, c'est-à-dire rentre dans la
sphère privée des parents.
Ouais.
Ça vous ça vous interprète pas ?
C'est un c'est un c'est un énorme red
flag. En réalité, c'est quelque chose,
c'estàd qu'on va non seulement prendre
les enfants pour ce qu'ils sont,
c'est-à-dire des enfants, mais on va
prendre leurs parents aussi pour des
enfants. Et et donc l'infantilisation
globale de la société qui se retrouve
dans la politique, la façon de faire les
messages. D'ailleurs, les politiques
sont les premiers à utiliser les réseaux
sociaux. He faut voir les TikTok de
Gabriel Atal ou d'Emmanuel Macron. Euh,
ils sont là pour justement utiliser la
force de l'algorithme quand c'est dans
leur intérêt euh fait que moi, pour moi,
le le le le c'est le drame, c'est que on
acte le fait que l'hydratie est là, les
gens sont devenus bêtes volontairement
ou pas, mais
non, il faut pas dire bêtes.
Idot, idiot au sens grec. Alors pour le
coup, l'idiot, celui qui s'occupe de son
mais qui émotionnelle.
Quand tu es en catatonie émotionnelle,
bah tu utilises moins de vocabulaire
pour exprimer ce que tu sens.
Oui, voilà. Voilà. C'est sans doute ça.
Où le côté je je ne vais pas
m'intéresser à des concepts, je
m'intéresse à des choses très
matérielles, ça aussi parce que le
concept demande du glucose mental, de la
brandette intellectuelle et plein de
gens disent ça sert à rien. Et c'est
vrai en partie. Et donc il y a ça donc
on acte ça mais par-dessus on rajoute
une couche où on va traiter tout le
monde comme des enfants. Passage qui
plus
c'est le fameux concept de l'état
nounou. Voilà.
Euh l'État nounous crée euh ce vaste
utérus artificiel dans lequel nous
sommes globalement déresponsabilisés. Et
ce dont on oublie de parler quand on
parle quand on aborde ce sujet de
l'interdiction des réseaux sociaux au
plus jeunes et cetera, on oublie aussi
quand même la faculté d'adaptation
et de résilience d'une grande partie de
la jeunesse qui nous enseigne aussi qui
est en ayant grandi avec ses outils a su
apprendre à se créer 40 profils et ne
pas devenir schizophrène. Peut-être que
nous aussi nous manquons de aussi de
lucidité sur la réalité de cet usage. Et
je voulais surtout dire que
l'interdiction, c'est peut-être le
meilleur des moyens d'optimiser
l'aspiration à y aller. C'est-à-dire de
justement comme on le disait tout à
l'heure Alexis, tu parlais de
radicalisation des complotistes.
Tu radicalises souvent par l'interdit.
ça devient le fruit défendu d'autant
plus désirable qu'on te l'a défendu et
on sort de la case éducation pour passer
à la à la à la case infantilisation ce
qui a un bon quantique entre voilà 1000
nuances possibles par lesquelles on
aurait pu faire progresser la population
sur ce sujet
la politique du gouvernement que ce soit
espagnol italien français ou d'autres
australiens
de supprimer l'accès aux réseaux sociaux
pour les moins de 15 ans.
C'est quand même bénéfique.
Je me fais l'avocat du raison parce que
c'est bénéfique parce que c'est la
mauvaise réponse. C'est un vrai
problème. Les les algos sont designés,
je parle surtout contrôle fréqu de
l'héroïne
euh qui pousse à des dépendances et
quand il y a un sevrage trop rapide, les
gamins font des dépressions quand ils
ont ils n'y ont pas accès.
La fameuse captologie,
neuromarketing ou ce que tu veux.
remarque bien sûr euh
les leur éviter ça parce que ce
phénomène de dépendance en terme de
construction cérébrale, c'est peut-être
pas bon pour le futur.
H h h
ça peut peut-être créer d'autres
addictions ou être plus prédominant.
Alors d'abord honnêtement, on a aucun
recul scientifique sur la chose.
Peut-être qu'on pourrait démontrer si on
étudiait sur de vastes populations ce
qui se passe sur le cerveau de jeunes
qui utilisent les réseaux sociaux.
Peut-être qu'on arriverait à une
démonstration très simple. Euh je dis
bien peut-être he je fais une hypothèse
pour dire que quand on a une approche en
sciences humaines à peu près sérieuse,
on va essayer de rationaliser le réel.
D'accord ? Si on faisait par exemple une
étude sur 140000 lycéens, d'accord, euh
et qu'on se demandait dans quelle mesure
ça va amplifier les troubles psychiques
préexistants ou peut-être
40000 lycéens du 7e ou
ouais je dis je dis ça non justement
tirer je dis ça parce que il y a eu
notamment une expérience démocratique
faite aux États-Unis sur 140000 lycéens
pour essayer de comprendre quelle était
leur appétence
au à la démocratie délibérative. Donc si
tu veux, ça peut-être un véritable sujet
parce que sur internet, on a en effet le
les dans les réseaux sociaux donc d'un
phénomène d'amplification des
vulnérabilités des plus vulnérables
hein, pardon d'enfoncer une porte
ouverte mais on a absolument aucune
certitude euh quant à ce qui se passe
chez des très jeunes qui grandissant
avec ces outils sont au contraire très
conscients de ces limites parce qu'ils
les incorporent vite. Ce que je veux
dire, non, je veux dire par là
simplement toutes les hypothèses sont
possibles. Il n'y a pas d'études
sérieuses dans la matière. Il y a
peut-être justement un autre
tu as lu toutes les études
mais justement il n'y a pas d'études
sérieuses en la matière puisqu'on n'a
pas le recul. C'est presque comme si on
on parlait du du Covid. On n' pas suivi
sur 5 ans ou 10 ans des usagers de moins
de 15 ans de ces outils euh dans l'état
actuel des outils. Puisque-temps la
captologie et les sciences qu'on
évoquait ont été améliorées. Je voudrais
dire un truc aussi quand même
fondamental, c'est que si tu as été
privé de réseaux sociaux jusqu'à l'âge
de 15 ans et qu'à 15 ans, le jour de tes
15 ans et un jour tu dis "Ça y est, je
peux y aller," tu ça sera peut-être bien
pire. He donc je pense pas qu'on qu'on
soigne.
Tu es en train de dire qu'il faut
Attends parce que là on fait du scrabble
depuis le début de l'émission.
Reprends-moi sur l'orthographe. Tu es en
train de nous dire qu'il faut une
mratisation.
Oui, tout à fait.
Qui veut dire
euh c'est le fait de d'acclimater
progressivement,
c'est de s'injecter une petite t tous
les jours pour se désensibiliser.
C'est de l'im.
Je te prends au scrap quand tu veux.
Fabriquer surtout avec ce mot. tu fais
un gros scorp. Euh c'est l'immunité est
peut-être justement fabriquée par une
partie euh à mon sens, je le dis là pour
le coup he d'intuition mais je me
mouille. OK, je peux me tromper mais
tant pis, j'y vais à pied joint. Euh moi
je pense en fait pour beaucoup côtoyés
de jeunes qui utilisent les réseaux qui
sont incroyablement plus méfiants que
nous et ceux qui ont grandi dedans, il y
en a en effet qui peuvent rier parce que
ils avaient peut-être un terrain propice
à vriller. Ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est toujours la même histoire avec
l'ingénierie sociale. On met le pied
dans la porte avec une très bonne
intention et un discours qui d'un point
de vue rhtorique est imparable. D'accord
? Et on va nager dans le sens du dans on
va nager dans le sens du courant pour
dire aux gens qui sont prédisposés
eux-mêmes à le recevoir et à se
déresponsabiliser. Vous inquiétez pas,
everything is under control. D'accord ?
Bon donc
français
et donc tout est sous contrôle parce que
l'État noun nous prend ça en charge.
Mais c'est une manière aussi d'aller et
pardon, je vais aller dans la
psychologie des profondeurs 2 secondes,
tu me tu m'y autorises. C'est une
manière aussi euh d'approfondir de façon
de moins en moins réversible la
suppression. euh du père symbolique
capable de dire non. Euh c'est-à-dire
c'est l'État qui se substitue alors qui
est faible sur plein de sujets mais qui
se substitue en quelque sorte aux
familles. Quand on parle d'éducation,
c'est bel et bien aux familles de
prendre cette responsabilité. Et moi qui
suis euh laien d'une certaine manière,
je crois que c'est le rôle du père de
dire non et que ce n'est pas à l'état de
se substituer au père. Donc c'est pour
moi en terme de typologie, je dirais de
régime, une forme d'incursion dans la
vie des familles qui est d'ordre
totalitaire même si on n'est pas
évidemment un état totalitaire comme le
serait la Chine, mais c'est en soit je
dirais une émixtion dans les interstices
de l'intime qui ouvre en quelque sorte
la boîte de pandore d'autres formes de
contrôle et évidemment tous les autres
risques qui vont avec et qu'on a évoqué
sur le plan de nos libertés civiques.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est-à-dire que il y a
il y a cette volonté d'entrer dans la
cellule familiale au plus proche, la
transparence qui doit être partout et
l'idée de dire que c'est l'état qui va
régir la vie biologique, la vie sociale
et la vie de la cellule familiale avec
moi cette loi qui et et toujours l'enfer
est pavé de de très bonnes intentions.
La loi fin de vie par exemple qui qui
part du principe qu'il faut abréger les
souffrances si on le décide en plus en
âme et conscience. C'est donc c'est une
très belle loi, sauf que c'est la le
rendre administratif la mort. Tu
as déjà accompagné quelqu'un jusqu'à la
mort ?
Oui, je te l'ai dit. Oui, oui, oui. Mais
avec des souffrances, sans souffrance,
c'était métastasé, c'était métastasé,
pas métastasé. C'était coma pas coma.
C'est coma de toute façon et c'est
morphine voilà jusque jusqu'à ce qu'il y
a un organe qui lâche.
Toi si tuas je te pose la question si si
par exemple
je te jette par la fenêtre parce que tu
me fatigues et que tu deviens
tétrplégique et que tu sens plus popo et
que tu baffes de partout et que tu es
dépressif
que tu en peux plus
et que que ça devient dramatique.
Si je t'apporte un soin psychologique
pour accepter ta nouvelle situation, que
tu prends conscience que tu vas avoir un
beau fauteuil électrique qui sera
remboursé à 100 % et que les tarifs vont
pas augmenter et que et que ton ton
appartement va être bien fait, ta femme
te quitte, tu perds goût à la vie. H
h ça arrive à plein de gens. Ouais.
Bon, ça arrive à plein de gens.
Tu as un autre accident, là tu es
complètement pratiquement végétatif.
Tu as en plus de ça une énorme maladie,
un cancer qui se déploie. Tu souffres
énormément, ça devient dramatique.
Si l'État te permet de dire maintenant,
je veux m'éteindre la lumière, tu
choisis quoi ?
Bah, tu choisis d'éteindre la lumière
évidemment. Le problème, c'est que là,
tu parles d'un cas personnel. Tu parles
pas de tous les débordements qui sont
possibles ensuite par cette
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Tu
as raison. Et et c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est encore une fois l'enfer
est pas de très bonnes intentions parce
que évidemment qu'on est pour une voix
comme celle-là, on va dire mais c'est
très bien de pouvoir dire écoute en mon
âme et conscience je choisir d'arrêter
de souffrir parce que c'est
insupportable tout simplement. La vie
est insupportable mais la question du
suici prenons la dépression le moment
dépressif où tu vas dire bon là j'en
peux plus. Si tu as pas la main, il y a
peut-être des moyens aussi d'en sortir
autrement si c'est pas irréversible. Or,
des gens vont se dire c'est irréversible
et peut-être passer à l'acte alors qu'il
pourrait faire autrement. Et puis
derrière, il y a l'aspect économique
hein. Il y avait beaucoup d'articles qui
expliquaient qu'on économiserait mais
des milliards parce que ce qui coûte le
plus cher, c'est les trois dernières
semaines de vie. Et donc si on arrive à
enlever ces trois dernières semaines de
vie de la sécor mais quel bonheur c'est
ce qui fait toute l'humanité d'une vie
ces trois dernières semaines
bah oui
ben c'est de toute façon ce qui fait
l'humanité d'une vie c'est tout ce
parcours et quand l'État va s'imisser il
va commencer évidemment à changer les
choses et puis viendra la question du
moment où un âge obligatoire de mort
sera
voilà tu tu suputes tu suputes
je suputte mais on est aujourd'hui
certains disent que l'homme qui vivra
plus de 150 ans est né d'accord
avec les progrès de la de la biomédecine
et cetera. Bon, peut-être qu'à un moment
les mecs vont dire "OK, on a on a réussi
à à contrer la mort, on va vivre jusqu'à
200 300 ans
avec un système de retraite extra
avec bah justement qu'est-ce qu'on fait
?" Et est-ce qu'il faut pas dire à un
moment faut débrancher de toute façon,
même si tu es en pleine forme, tuas tu
as le droit à 300 ans, ça suffit
maintenant. Tu
vois, j'ouvre une parenthèse. Il y a des
gens pour aider les gens dépressifs,
il y a des il y a des psychologues, des
psychiatres. N'hésitez pas à demander de
l'aide. Euh euh les gens peuvent vous
tendre la main. Euh restez pas seul,
parlez-en, restez pas dans votre bulle.
Euh euh il nous reste encore ça en
France. Euh n'hésitez pas.
Même si la santé mentale est quand même
le parent pauvre
avec le avec le confinement, ça a été un
compliqué. Fred, tu veux rebondir
là-dessus vite fait ou on peut passer
autre chose ?
Euh non, sur l'euthanasie, c'est
toujours parce que j'appelle pas ça
l'accompagnement en fin de vie, hein,
j'appelle ça le l'euthanasie. Oui,
on utilise toujours le cas singulier
légitime pour inférer à un niveau
systémique quelque chose d'infiniment
plus dangereux qui est de l'ordre de
l'État régulateur du cheptel humain.
Ouais. Bon,
il faut renforcer les crédits, du moins
les budgets pour les soins palliatifs,
les écoles les écoles du moins les
cellules de
les cellules volantes de soins
palliatifs, il faut leur donner quand
même les moyens parce que c'est
ça tout existe. La loi Lonetti, elle est
là.
Revenons à un sujet plus joyeux.
L'affaire Epstein
qui n'est pas joyeux du tout. Désolé
pour le bordel. Pédophile,
traite des humains, torture, suspicion
grandissante de meurtre, d'enterrer des
gens dans des dans des ranches.
Le le sujet bien compliqué d'un
pourrissement d'une élite. Euh vous avez
eu ça comment ? Vous avez été sur le le
justice.g américain, vous avez regardé
cherché des gens, regarder ce qui se
racontait, vu des trucs horribles, pas
flouter flouter.
Vous pouvez nous en dire un
d'abord les les complotistes avaient
raison. Euh
c'est quoi les complotistes avaient
raison ? Alors justement les les plus
les plus vigilants, ceux qui avaient
fait les hypothèses de scénario du pire
et qui avaient utilisé un certain nombre
de signaux faibles pour dire le
pizzaget, c'est ça ? Ben là, ça joue
énormément quand même hein euh puisque
là euh on voit les Non, le pizza non
enfin pizza c'est qu'on bouffait des
enfants dans des tunnels et qu'une pizza
servait de proxy et Hillary Clinton
allait se servir avec un mec qui arrive
avec un fusil à un moment pour dire je
vais libérer les gosses évidemment il y
a rien à part un
là tu dis ça va loin et c'est justement
c'est là où je dis on a évité le pire
parce que la radicalisation des
complotistes peut aboutir à ce type de
comportement Ouais.
Euh simplement pour revenir sur
l'affaire Epstein, euh soulignons au
passage qu'on devrait peut-être
s'inspirer nous de cette logique de
te sauver làin.
Non mais cette logique de Non non, c'est
je dis vraiment je préfère un
complotiste qui va trop loin euh qu'un
journaliste niaiseux qui me vende la
guimauve. C'est ça que je dis. Et je
préfère justement que les hypothèses
soient risquées quit à ce qu'en effet on
est euh on est on soit non mais je la
deuxième partie de la phrase est plus
importante. On soit dans l'obligation de
vérifier les faits. Et là on est dans
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
c'est que les signaux faibles qui
étaient peut-être suranalysés par des
gens potentiellement excessifs voire
cinglés he si vous voulez moi je j'ai
pas de problème à aller là-dessus mais
s'avère là confirmé dans un scénario qui
est encore pire que tout ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer étant donné les noms de
célébrités qui qui affleurent. Donc la
réflexion sur laquelle ça doit nous
amener, c'est celle plus philosophique
euh de l'ibriss humaine, hein,
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont du pouvoir,
qui se coopte et cetera, créer
manifestement des rituels de cooptation
euh dans lesquels ils peuvent exprimer
une forme de je dirais de d'attitude
prométéenne de nous, on est au-dessus de
de tous les autres et cetera. Voilà la
réflexion à mon avis. Alors évidemment,
je travaille sur cette affaire depuis
depuis le le suicide en prison de
Jeffrein. Enfin, son emprisonnement.
Comment tu travailles ? Bah euh je fais
mon boulot, je suis allé voir source
ouverte, euh il y avait le Blackbook qui
est immédiatement paru. C'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que le
l'affaire Ipstein commence de manière
grand publique euh avec Goker qui était
un site internet qui a lancé tous les
documents, les flight log à l'époque, on
avait donc tous les logs de l'avion
privé, Lolita Express de Jeffrestein
avec les passagers. Où est-ce qui se
passait ? On voyait la triangulaire
entre les pays de l'Est, le Maghreb,
Monaco, Paris, New York et cetera, les
Bahamas euh avec des témoignages à
l'époque. Il y avait un journal de
Floride qui avait fait un travail
exceptionnel pour sortir beaucoup de
témoignages de gens qui disaient "On a
vu le balai des filles qui venaient et
cetera."
Euh,
il y avait des victimes dedans aussi
dans les témoignages.
Il y avait des victimes Virginia Joffrey
qui est morte hein euh l'année dernière
dans des circonstances voilà
particulières qui a fait tomber le
prince Androu hein. Son témoignage a
fait ça été la première pierre qui a
fait tomber le prince Androu et et donc
il y avait déjà beaucoup d'informations.
Il y avait le volet français, le major
d'homme, il avait encore un profil
Facebook, on pouvait voir qui
connaissait. Il y avait un Racing Club
sportif où tout le monde se rencontrait
de du Black Book. Enfin, il y avait
beaucoup d'informations qui étaient en
source ouverte au final où on pouvait
commencer à voir et puis à l'époque
Jean-Luc Brunet était encore en vie
après son arrestation et lui aussi a été
retrouvé mort dans sa cellule. Qui ce
monsieur ?
Jean-Luc Brunel, c'était le patron de
d'agence de de Mankina, Karine Model et
autre qui était le recruteur en fait
parisien français d'Epstein pour les
parties fines et qui donc allait
chercher des filles de mineur pour le
plus souvent pour agrémenter les les
soirées où on invitait après le toutpis
Paris. D'ailleurs, Jack Lang dit je fris
le tout Paris le connaissait. Voilà.
Sauf que le tout Paris, tout le monde
ferme sa gueule he tout le monde se
cache derrière Jack Lang. Euh c'est
pratique, il a 86 ans. C'est un peu
comme Madnef hein. En France, on prend
les les pé quand ils sont passés passés
d'âge ou quand ils sont morts. Voilà.
Donc c'est c'est facile, ça permet
d'éviter les dossiers chauds. Mais
derrière, il y avait du monde.
L'angue a quand même inventé une
nouvelle forme d'esquive qui est
J'assume.
Oui mais non mais c'est pas nouveau.
Mais mais d'ailleurs, il
attends attends. Il assume ses relations
avec monsieur
Oui. qui n'ont rien de répréhensible
puisqu'il aimait l'art et que il a fait
des dîners tout à fait charmants avec
Woody Allen, avec voilà ces gens-là
vivent dans un monde où c'est
formidable. Sauf que on apprend qu'il y
avait pas que Woody Allen, qui avait
cette gamine qui était aussi invité dans
certains de ces dîners.
Jacquel qui était peut-être pas là.
Si, a il y a un listing d'un dîner dans
les dans les documents du DOJ où tu as
Jack Lang, tu as un prince Saoudien, tu
as le prince Andrew, tu as Jeffrestein
et tu as sûr de ça ?
Ouais. Ouais. C'est dans les documents
du DOJ et tu as Woody Allen aussi. Mais
il y a des gens qui sont dans les
documents Epstein qui ont rien à voir
avec tout ça.
Alors, il y a des gens qui sont dans le
Blackbook qui ont rien à voir, qui sont
dans les documents duid qui ont rien à
voir euh simplement parce
tiens, au fait, lui qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait ? Et cetera. Euh ça veut pas dire
que c'est des potes. Après, il y a tous
ceux qui ont échangé des emails et
encore les emails qu'on a dans ce qui a
été publié par le DOJ, le Departement of
Justice, sont des emails de l'adresse
euh Gacation, c'est-à-dire l'adresse que
Epstein employait quand il se baladait,
quand il était en vacances pour dire
tiens, dans 2 jours euh je serai dans
ton bled à New York, tiens, tu fais quoi
? Dans 4 jours, je suis à la barbade,
est-ce que tu veux ? Voilà. Donc il
invitait les gens dans à ces soirées par
semaine là, mais Epstein était sur Xbox
Live. il utilisait des messages
récryptés, il avait plein d'autres
adresses chiffrées, il avait plein
d'autres adresses email et cetera et
puis on peut imaginer qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de d'appels téléphoniques et
cetera. Donc le dossier qui est publié
malgré ces 3 millions de sources et
cetera, c'est rien par rapport à
l'intelligence qu'il y a derrière et et
l'enquête est longue parce que je pense
que Jeffre Epstein justement faisait
attention hein et donc les mails qu'on
voit c'est pas les mails où il parle de
choses plus graves. D'ailleurs, souvent
il dit "On en parlera quand on se voit.
Il y a il y a des mails où il dit "Non
mais ça on en parlera quand on se voit."
Pourquoi il y avait des caméras partout
chez lui ?
Ah bah ça c'est sans doute pour le
compromate ou alors parce qu'il avait
peur du cambriolage. Le
compromate.
Le compromat c'est quand tu prends une
personne célèbre, tu lui mets une gamine
dans les pattes et tu filmes les ébats
et ensuite tu dis tiens regarde au fait
tu as parlé à ta femme de ce qu'on a
fait ce weekend et puis après tu en fais
ce que tu veux. Alors c'est le
renseignement qu'utilise ça aussi hein.
On on parle de ma compromat
les Russes c'est compromat mais les
enfin dans dans le monde du
renseignement c'est monnaie
c'est quoi ego ? Euh IF c'est euh
je sais plus.
Allez voir la chaîne de Beréril 614, il
en très très bien. Explique très bien ce
que c'est. Euh et donc à partir de là,
tu as les leviers pour tenir quelqu'un
ou le retourner, hein, les deux. le
compromade, tu le tiens, hein. Voilà, il
a pas le choix, il est obligé de se
taire et de faire ce que tu lui
demandes. Donc, on peut euh il faut voir
que il y a eu des perquisitions en 2019
dans l'appartement parisien Avenue Foche
de Jeffrestein où on a saisi un
ordinateur portable, des clés USB, des
disques durs et cetera euh et on peut
imaginer tout ce qu'il y avait dessus.
La justice française n'a rien sorti
contrairement au Déogi. C'est pas nos
façons de faire. Bien sûr, l'enquête
soi-disant est au point mort puisque
Brunel s'est tué dans sa cellule et que
Epstein aussi s'est tué dans sa cellule.
Enfin, ça c'est la version officielle.
Après, il y a toutes les les versions
complotistes de dire "Mais le soir du
suicide de Jeffrey Epstein, il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se sont passées
pour que ce soit rendu possible. Les
caméras ne marchaient pas, le détenu qui
devait être avec lui dans sa cellule
avait été transféré, euh le gardien
n'était pas là où il dormait." Enfin
bref, euh et puis vous avez les
témoignages euh du médecin qui a fait
l'autopsie, qui a assisté à l'autopsie,
qui était celui qui avait fait
l'autopsie aussi, qui avait après
confirmé l'autopsie de GFK euh et qui
explique
quoi quoi quoi
mais le médecin qui a fait l'autopsie de
enfin qui a assisté à l'autopsie de
Epstein était celui qui avait aussi
ramené des preuves sur l'autopsie de
GFK. C'est le même.
Il a quel âge monsieur ? Il a
il a 86 ans. 86. Ouais, c'est ça. Ouais.
Ouais. Il a il a pas d'âge.
Et il y a un témoignage he qui est
d'ailleurs qui qui est passé sur les
médiat français. Complément d'enquête
complément d'enquête. Voilà, vous y
allez, il y a le témoignage sur
complément d'enquête, service public de
l'info, de ce médecin qui explique que
il y a quand même des points qui posent
question sur un potentiel sucide parce
que on retrouve pas ça en cas de sucide,
c'est plutôt qu'on l'a étranglé avec une
certaine force qui était pas celle de la
du linge attaché au lit. Enfin voilà, ce
genre de de témoignage. Complément
d'enquête. Voilà. Euh donc euh et qui
avait intérêt à faire terire euh ou à
arrêter l'enquête hein euh Guillen
Maxwell qui était sa recruteuse, elle
elle est pour 20 ans en prison. Alors
pourquoi elle est en prison pour 20 ans
? Alors pour trafic humain
effectivement. Donc il y a bien des
clients de ce réseau. Or aujourd'hui et
toute la question c'est qui sont ces
clients ? Quels ont été les crimes qui
ont eu lieu ? Et surtout dans les
déclassifications américaines. Les noms
sont noircci évidemment. Alors pour
protéger les victimes certes, mais aussi
pour rendre les choses plus compliquées.
Les enquêteurs ont toutes ces
informations, mais est-ce que l'enquête
avance ? Enfin voilà, ce dossier
Epstein, euh il est là pour dire euh
oui, les élites sont corrompues, pas
toutes hein, mais une partie des élites
sont corrompues. Euh et surtout ce qui
choque, c'est au-delà des
C'est plus que corrompu là. Oui, desprav
criminell, on peut dire pour certaines.
Euh mais au-delà de l'aspect criminel,
il y a l'aspect et là qu'on pourrait
dire euh plus officiel de la de la haute
trahison en fait euh de d'élites qui ne
travaillent pas pour leur pays. Le cas
de Peter Mandelson euh britannique qui
est incroyable. Peter Mandelson, il
était l'équivalent de Bruno Lemire,
ministre de l'économie enfin du budget.
C'est pas possible. Il y a aucun
équivalent à Bruno Lemer.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai. Mais bon euh
c'est notre fierté nationale.
Oui, c'est vrai. Bah Peter Melson,
c'était la fierté nationale du Labour,
hein, du New Labor. C'est-à-dire qu'avec
Tony Blair, ils ont créé cette troisème
voix qui était le parti centriste, avant
le parti centriste du New Labor. Et donc
il est euh alors qu'il est euh donc au
trésor euh il échange des mails avec
Jeffre Epstein pour sortir des
informations confidentielles euh qui
vont faire gagner des millions à Jeffre
Epstein sur des futures lois euh de
taxation des multinationales sur la
démission de Gordon Brand qui était
premier ministre. Il il informe Jeffre
Hipstein 24 heures avant d'ailleurs
500 millions les 500 milliards de
renflouement de l'euro.
Exactement. Euh et Gordon B a porté
plainte ces jours-ci justement. Euh et
et là Mandelson est quand même un peu
euh gêné et risque peut-être euh de la
prison si euh la justice en
Grande-Bretagne fonctionne pour haute
trahison tout simplement. Et cet
homme-là a été nommé ambassadeur aux
États-Unis l'an dernier par Kir Starmer,
l'actuel premier ministre qui avait
totale confiance en lui. Et aujourd'hui,
Kir Starmer fait une vidéo pour dire "Je
m'excuse auprès des victimes, comment
j'ai pu croire Peter Mandelson ?" alors
qu'il appelait Peter, c'est son pote en
fait. Voilà. Quand tu as bossé pour les
les j'allais dire les roses beefs, mais
quand tu as bossé pour les Britis euh
désolé euh l'enquête de proximité, c'est
les Français ou les Britanniques qui
l'ont fait
les Français et les les Britanniques,
ils ont forcément fait une enquête de
proximité.
Après, ils travaillent entre service
évidemment, ils sont passé
Non, ça c'est pas sûr qu'ils travaillent
entre services.
Alors, ils ont sans doute fait leur
enquête aussi et ça va
si c'est la même enquête qu'ils ont fait
par rapport à l'ambassadeur.
Ah, je ne sais pas. En tout cas, moi
j'ai j'ai eu accès au télégram. Voilà,
c'était quand même un poste.
Tu parlais de Mais euh cet acronyme
angloaxon résume les quatre leviers de
la manipulation employé en matière
d'espionnage à savoir monnaie,
argent,
idéologie, entre parenthèses, l'adhésion
à une cause,
compromission, le chantage, égau, les
frustrations personnelles ou le besoin
de reconnaissance.
Exactement. Voilà. Merci.
Et donc l'affaire montre ce réseau
international de gens de pouvoir qui
aussi se comportait quasiment comme des
agents avec un agent traitant. Bill
Gates, il y a des méos dans le des
documents du DOJ où Bill Gates écrit à
Ipstein pour dire "J'ai déjeuné
aujourd'occ
ça, ça ça c'est quasiment un même mot".
Euh tu dis "Mais pourquoi Bill Gates
fait ça ? Enfin, quel est le comment il
a réussi à avoir ce euh cette ce poids
sur ces gens-là pour avoir comme
Frédéric l' expliqué, il a été programmé
parce que le mec est un super
manipulateur qui l'a suffisamment fait
baigner dans des trucs salires.
Sans dout sans doute. Et au-delà de ça
parce que euh vous avez après le le nom
de de femmes. Alors, vous avez Sarah
Ferguson qui était l'ex épouse d'Androuw
qui dit "Épouse-moi".
Vous avez ma Marite, la princesse de de
Norvège euh qui pareil n'attendait que
des faveurs sexuelles d'Epstine et qui
demandait des conseils d'éducation à son
fils qui accusé de viol en ce moment et
qui est au mains de la justice
norvégienne. On a faire une sorte de de
de de cours des miracles de de monstres
assez obsènes.
La maladie du pouvoir,
je pense qu'il y a le le sentiment
d'impunité absolue. C'est-à-dire que
c'est des gens qui passent leur vie sur
des yachtes dans des jets privés. Donc
on passe pas les frontières comme nous
hein, ça c'est beaucoup plus facile.
Tu as déjà été sur un yachute ?
Oui.
Quelle taille ?
Euh de taille
petite deux étages à Cann. Bon c'est pas
c'était à Cann festival de Cann. Tu as
des yautes. Bon voilà.
Qui c'est qui t'a invité encore ? Un
russe qui t'a proposé une valise de
rouble ?
Non non c'était c'était un émirati
c'était il y a assez longtemps et
c'était une soirée où ce qui m'a choqué
c'est c'est la moquette quoi. La taille
de la moquette. C'était impressionnant
quoi.
Tu avais enlevé tes chaussures bien
entendu.
Absolument. Ouais. Ouais. Tu es obligé.
Ouais. Euh
les filles avaient encore une cloison
nasal.
Alors à Cann, il faut savoir j'ai jamais
vu autant de ces de ma vie.
C'est absolument dramatique.
Moi je tape pas. J'aiur de ça. Je trouve
que c'est la pire drogue qui existe. Euh
j'ai jamais vu autant de coquaut pas
prendre de drogue. Jamais.
Non jamais. Et surtout pas celle-là. Euh
voilà. Donc parenthèse fermée. Mais
Ouais. Ouais. Et puis enf c'est le
moment où tu as plein de de canoises qui
s'inventent une vie aussi, tu vois, qui
expliquent elles sont un peu
consultantes internationales. Enfin
c'est
Je vois que tu souffles Fred.
Oui, parce qu'on est on est toujours
dans dans l'écume des jours hein, si
j'ose dire. On est là, on est condamné à
Non, non, mais de toute façon, on n pas
d'autre choix que de le faire, hein. Je
dis pas le contraire.
Euh simplement pendant que voyez là on
est dans la destruction psychique pour
moi pure et simple par l'actualité qui
indirectement sert le propos de cette
oligarchie qui se dit c'est bon on a on
a livré en pâure le plus con d'entre
tous parce que rappelez-vouscock
lui-même s'intéressait au crime parfait.
Moi c'est pas Epstein qui me
m'intéresse. D'abord c'est tous ceux qui
n'ont jamais été goulés qui sont
élémentairement plus malins eu égard aux
traces qu'il a laissé. Oui, le sentiment
d'impunité mais un peu au passage.
L'affaire n'est pas close encore.
Elle n'est pas close. Mais dites-vous
bien qu'à ce niveau, je dirais de
puissance financière, organisationnelle,
logistique et puis en référence à des
gens qui qui se pensent eux-mêmes comme
des supranationaux, d'accord,
il y en a forcément d'autres qui sont
beaucoup mieux organisés. Euh donc quand
on parle de cette affaire-là, il faut
imaginer le le je dirais l'iceberg, mais
là où ça devient beaucoup plus
intéressant, je pense en terme en tant
que simple citoyen, en tant que père de
famille. Là, je j'ai envie même de te
répondre plus comme en essayant de faire
d'intellectualiser le sujet, mais comme
un père de famille. D'accord ? Je vais
te répondre avec le avec le cœur. Euh je
ne fais qu'envisager, si vous voulez au
travers de ça,
euh la réalité de de ce qui dépasse de
loin le terme de décadence. On est dans
le pourrissement, on est dans une élite
dysfonctionnelle qui se coopte au
travers de ses vi et je me dis que nous
sommes collectivement incapables de nous
lancer dans une dans une dans une
réflexion autour des actions
correctrices. C'est-à-dire que nous
sommes tellement enlisés dans la ce que
tu appelais tout à l'heure la catatonie
émotionnelle que tout ça nous rend
incapable de coaliser d'intelligence
collective et cetera. Et le pire étant
peut-être que on a un fantastique
mécanisme de bouqu émissérisation. Moi
je girardien là-dessus he justement
qu'on a trouvé le bouqu émissière idéal.
C'est on prend le le gars le plus
diabolique et le plus bête, on le
pendule et cetera où il s'est pendu peu
importe. Là les hypothèses, je m'entends
pas honnêtement mais je dirais en fin de
compte que l'on peut cristalliser une
forme de grogne populaire là-dessus à
partir du moment. D'abord il est déjà
puni et on va peut-être y compris au
travers d'un lent poison qui va
se se distiller dans la société avec
cette affaire. Bon, mais y compris y
compris par ce processus, il est
vraiment très imparfait, le résultat est
le même pour tous ceux qui ont envie
qu'on regarde ailleurs en fait et qu'on
ne soit incapable d'autre chose. C'estàd
que moi, pour moi, c'est limite euh
c'est limite de l'entertainment quoi.
C'està-dire qu'on est encore dans la
matrice, on est enlisé dans quelque
chose qui nous fait que nous aim voir en
fait. Tu te trompes peut-être parce que
le fait que ça sorte l'indignation que
ça va créer pour les victimes,
pour les pauvres gamines qui ont été
corrompu jusqu'à l'os qui ont été
maltraité la traite la traite comme de
la traite d'esclaves sexuel le fait
qu'il se soit affranchi pour avoir cette
vibration d'être au-dessus de toutes les
lois, cette maladie du pouvoir
euh peut-être que ça avoir l'effet
inverse.
sont tellement méga euh qu'ils ont fait
une une extrême erreur.
Alexis, tu voulais rebondir ce que
c'est. Oui, parce que je pense qu'il y a
il y a il y a le le principe de
révélation, c'est-à-dire l'ampleur de du
réseau qui choque mais c'est pas
nouveau, hein, je veux dire, les les
élites corrompu, pédocriminel,
pédosatanistes, enfin il y a eu les
baloses, il y a eu Gill de Rey, enfin
tout le temps cette idée que l'élite est
corrompue et et va tuer la jeunesse ou
utiliser son sang et cetera. Donc
connerie,
c'est-à-dire que ça va avec,
c'est-à-dire que le pouvoir
effectivement c'est sanguinaire. Euh le
pouvoir c'est la violence, hein. Donc
c'est comment tu veux utiliser cette
violence ? Et après, il y a la question
de de l'ubrice du pouvoir et ce qui fait
que tu te dis "Mais oui tiens, si je
cherchais les limites et est-ce qu'il y
a des limites après tout ? Est-ce que
moi je peux m'affranchir de de l'espèce
humaine ?" Et et derrière le projet
d'Epstein, il y a pas seulement donc
cette ce ce réseau pédocriminel, il y a
il y a tout un projet transhumaniste de
créer le premier bébé entièrement cloné.
euh fait par ADN. Euh d'ailleurs,
c'est pas Rel qui avait fait ça.
Alors Raël ne l'a jamais fait. Il a dit
qu'il l'avait fait mais il l'a jamais
fait. Ce n'était qu'un précurseur.
Oui, mais on est là pareil. C'est Raëel
est aussi éit violence sexuelle et
cetera, ce que vous voulez. Lui, il a
choisi le chemin de la secte. Euh très
bien, il en a fait son beurre, il est
toujours pas en tôle. OK, ça marche. Euh
pour ce qui est du reste, Jeffrey
Epstein avait ce projet transhumaniste,
son ranch tu as parlé où où il avait
cette idée d'inséminer un paquet de
femmes pour créer des petits Jeffrais
parce que lui était l'être suprême et
créer surtout ce bébé totalement
fabriqué avec des messenes qui
resteraient cachées, privées hein pour
que le projet aboutisse. Or, les gens
qui travaillaient sur ce projet, ils
sont toujours làin. Donc eux, il y a des
échanges de mail avec des gens qui
disaient "Ah oui, oui, c'est super, ça
passerait par un labo en Ukraine."
Bon, très bien. Euh et on verrait et ça
changera définitivement. C'est dans le
DOJ, c'est un email euh et c'est quelque
chose qui vraiment est un des un des
pires trucs je pense dans le dossier
c'est ce projet de l'homme nouveau,
enfin du transhumanisme qui est qui est
qui est clairement la nouvelle religion
des élites hein. L'homme de 150 ans,
j'en parlais tout à l'heure, Elon Musk
et son neuralink. l'idée de dire qu'on
va dépasser la condition humaine et
qu'on va inventer l'homme nouveau. Ce
projet là, il est porté par la l'élite
techno, mais aussi l'élite telle qu'elle
a été représentée par Epstein. C'est un
délire. C'est un délire qui, je reviens
à ce que je disais tout à l'heure, le le
combat du siècle, les libertés et et le
sauvetage de ce qui reste de l'humanité.
Question internet des Chinois du FBI.
Bonsoir. Combien de francmaçons sur ce
plateau ce soir d'après Emmanuel Gave ?
Hein
? Euh Emmanuel Gave euh euh bonsoir.
Combien de franc-maçons sur le plateau
ce soir d'après Emmanuel Gave ? Sky et
franc-maçon. Voilà. Bon courage.
Ah c'était françon.
Ah d'accord.
C'est les chinois du FBI. Vous êtes
franc-maçon. Non.
Tu es franc-maçon ? Non pas du tout.
Nonçon les francmaçon il pourrai pas
dire parce que sinon on te tranche la
gorge si tu dis les secrets.
Par contre on m'a on m'a beaucoup
proposé.
On m'a proposé. Ouais.
C'estàd qu'on t'a proposé de tirer des
boules noirs.
Euh non non. Je je j'ai eu la curiosité
intellectuelle il y a une dizaine
d'années. Je me disais ça doit être
intéressant ces conversations
philosophiques et je suis pas allé au
bout. Par contre, j'ai trouvé leur
démarche extrêmement structuré
et je me fais rétrospectivement à la
réflexion qu'il y a probablement une
raison pour laquelle ces gens-là
existent depuis des siècles. C'est qu'
ils sont très structurés, très malins,
très déterminés, très résilients en tant
qu'organisation.
Quelqu'un invité à leur tenue blanche où
ils font
ils se font des poignées de main de
gangster.
Non, j'ai été pour reprendre ton terme,
j'ai été tamponné pour voir si je
pouvais les les rejoindre. Euh voilà, ce
qui était très intéressant, c'était le
off. On m'a dit "Si jamais j'ai des amis
qui t'appellent, il y a des trucs dont
tu dois pas parler. Je très intéressant
et notamment ne pas me montrer mon côté
souverainiste, identitaire de droite que
voilà." Et j'ai dit euh "Oui, d'accord,
mais en fait tu me demandes de travestir
qui je suis et c'est comme ça que ça n'a
pas marché." En fait, voilà, c'est tout.
C'était une loge euh diste pas.
J'ai j'ai un appart dans le 9e, hein.
Donc, j'étais pas loin du Grand Orient,
donc rue Cadé.
Donc forcément
de le savoir, cet ami d'ailleurs un bon
ami dont je ne savais pas qu'il était
Franc Mac m'a dit "Tu sais franchement
tu prendrais beaucoup de plaisir avec
nous, ça te plaira et cetera." Et
d'ailleurs, il m'a approché sur le
plateau que tu connais euh voilà en 2009
à Saint-Tourin, le plateau que tu as
utilisé au tout début là où quand on a
changé,
il m'en a parlé en sortant d'un plateau,
on m'a dit "Tu tu serais génial et
cetera." Et donc et donc sous-entendu
pour nous. Donc j'ai compris en fait
aussi que bon cit peut-être pas
intentionnel chez lui, il y avait aussi
de la sympathie, de la bonomie. Je suis
pas allé plus loin. Mais ce qui me
frappe aussi rétrospectivement euh
c'est qu'il a pas proposé à des
personnes qui à côté de moi
eurent été autant sinon plus
intéressante. À l'époque, j'étais un
petit peu avant-gardiste sur l'animation
comme tu le sais he de plateau sur
internet avant qu'il y ait YouTube si
puissant et cetera. Donc je pense qu'on
m'a identifié comme quelqu'un de
potentiellement influençable et capable
de devenir un influenceur.
Voilà. Mais je suis pas allé au bout.
Non non, j'ai
donc pas de Chinois du FBI ce soir.
Tu veux rebondir ?
Non. Non. tu as été initié euh machin n
salut gangster. J'ai j'ai eu la
documentation euh et j'ai des amis
évidemment euh et après j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'il y a un côté euh
Rotari Club enfin le lead
aussi. Oui. Euh et la question se pose
quoi. Ouais. de de du recrutement qui
parce que le le message c'est tout le
monde peut rentrer voilà tout le monde
est égal
et tout le monde peut sortir
et tout le monde peut sortir oui bien
sûr mais mais
voilà voilà voilà c'est faux
tout le monde peut pas rentrer. Ouais
tout le monde peut pas rentrer.
Je crois pas non je crois qu'il y a des
profils sociologiques euh et que on est
dans un club. C'est pour ça je parlais
du Rotary Club quoi. Ah mais moi il m'a
tout de suite identifié comme un profil
à risque. Donc c'est pour ça il m'a dit
"J'aimerais bien
profil à risque
mais justement trop identitaire
trop à droite et cetera." Donc il m'a
dit "Moi, j'aimerais beaucoup que tu
viennes mais est-ce que tu peux s'il te
plaît ne pas trop insister sur certains
aspects de ta personnalité ?" Je dis
"Bon bah donc je viens pas
mais à l'époque j'étais encore naïf he
il y a 10 ans sur ces sujets là mais
voilà c'était incompatibilité totale. Je
fais passer un message à la communauté
qui crée les questions. Euh lisez les
questions entre vous. Faites monter les
questions avec des petits pouces vers le
haut.
Euh comme ça, on fait une gamification
de vos de vos questions et comme ça on
prendra les meilleurs très rapidement.
Désolé, courage pour ton chas sky. Et
ouais, tu imagines même pas comment ça
m'a fendu le cœur. Valkyrie, on répond
euh on passe à autre chose. La
couverture médiatique de la Ferstein.
Bah oui, je
attends, tu as pasouplé Frédéric.
Ah mais c'est le plus c'est lui le plus
compétent là.
Ah oui, tu vois, on comprend pourquoi
les franc-maçons, ils ont essayé de te
recruter avec les Chinois du FBI. Tout à
fait. Cour
cours Emmanuel,
c'est mon esprit bienant.
Ouais. Euh bah ouais parce que je oui,
je suis parti sur le fond du dossier et
ce ce jeu de pouvoir et de petit
bonhomme. Mais la couverture médiatique,
elle est révélatrice encore une fois.
C'est-à-dire que là, on est en plein
dans une épiphanie. À la fois le DOJ
révèle les documents, mais ça révèle
aussi le comportement des médias. Et ce
qui est exceptionnel, particulièrement
en France, c'est que les médias de
milliardaires nationaux ont deux
messages à faire passer au français. 1,
attention, c'est c'est compliqué, c'est
complotiste. De attention, ça génère un
sentiment anti-élite. Voilà.
Ah non, il y a un 3.
Ah bah, il y a un 3.
Innocent.
Le premier le premier point, c'est
tant qu'il y a pas d'enquête présente
son
parce que quand quand j'entends le vieux
Attends, je peux dire mon point 3 vite
fait.
Non, mais c'est rapide. C'est vous allez
faire le bonheur des complotistes. Moi
j'ai entendu que ça
mais c'est ce que j'ai dit. Un c'est
conflotist.
Non mais donc ça va renforcer le le
l'évid
enfin c'est ce qu'ils ont dit plein de
fois
et bien sûr présemption d'innocence pour
ce qui concerne Jack Lang puisque
quand on l'écoute il était pas au
courant il a pas fait ses recherches tu
était condamné à la prison 2008 il a pas
regardé. Non
bah oui
bah en même temps tu sais pas hein. Puis
le mec était charmant il lui filait de
la tune comme ça tranquille. Alors, il a
jamais reçu sa citation pareil sur
France info. Jack Lang explique qu'il
aura jamais reçu un centime, un franc,
un copec ou un yen de la part de Jeffre
Epstein. Mais combien de dollars ?
Non mais non. Combien de roubles aussi ?
Non mais c'est pas ça. C'est que il a
peut-être pas eu directement de la main
à la main. Non, évidemment, ça passait
par des fondations. Alors, ça passait
par des fondations, ça passait par
évidemment des des des organisations qui
faisaient la promotion du cinéma
français, de la culture. Lui était
bénévole, il était même habité par cette
mission qui est la chienne de en sorte
que la culture française rayonne à
l'international. Pas
respectueux avec ce monsieur de 86. Su
est-ce que j'ai eu un mot désobligeant
pour Jack Lang ? Ça prouve qu'on peut
bosser jusqu'à 86 ans et directeur de
l'Institut du monde arabe pleine forme
et en pleine forme.
C'est une bonne nouvelle pour les caisse
de retraite.
Bon, arrêtez vos conneries. Euh revenons
à la couverture médiatique.
La couverture médiatique. Donc deux
messages enfin ou trois si tu veux mais
deux vraiment un attention ses
complotises de attention le sentiment
anti-élite. Euh trisème apprentissage
aucune place pour les victimes. Alors je
comprends que les victimes ne veulent
pas parler. Très peu l'ont fait
d'ailleurs et ça s'est plutôt mal fini
où il y a la peur évidemment de prendre
la parole face à ce réseau extrêmement
puissant. mais très peu de de place pour
les victimes et et euh ou de compassion
du moins de de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé avec on parle quand même de d'acte
de torture euh de disparition enfin là
là on a que la partie qu'on veut bien
nous montrer de choses qui sont
inavouables et totalement condamnables.
Euh tu as vu le film 8 mm ?
Je l'ai pas vu. Ouais
un des un des pires films de de toute ma
vie
sur les réseaux p
sur les SNF movie.
Sur les SN. Ouais, bien sûr. Oui, oui.
Bah,
si vous m'autorisez à mettre une
parenthèse et ils vont me dire que je
parle trop encore. Et on va vous
raconter une petite histoire, peut-être
qu'on devrait pas raconter. Un jour, on
a été invité pour discuter avec des gens
très importants sur comment les chefs
d'entreprise français étaient protégés à
l'étranger par la DGSE où la DGSE met
des hommes de paille à la tête
d'entreprise pour éviter les phénomènes
de mafia, de chantage, de compromat à la
Epstein, du genre de tête.
Vous êtes dans un gel privé, on vous met
un petit peu de truc pour vous faire
dormir dans le verre et puis on vous met
des gamines sur les genoux et ensuite on
prend des photos et on dit maintenant tu
vas nous dire ce que tu fais avec ton
entreprise, d'ailleurs tu vas nous
donner un peu de pognon et ainsi de
suite.
Donc il y a grâce à la DGSE, on protège
des des des chefs d'entreprise qui vont
dans des pays un peu à risque. Et on
avait testé le mec qui nous parlait de
tout ça et on disait "Est-ce qu'il y a
des chefs d'entreprise qui se retrouvent
dans les cercles où ils se tiennent tous
par la barbichette parce qu'il y a des
trucs innommables en face ?" et on lui
avait parlé de SNF movie et ainsi de
suite et le mec avait laissé planer le
doute en disant euh peut-être et c'est
pour ça qu'on est là et qu'on intervient
pour éviter que nos boîtes soient
menacées. Continue ce que tu racontais.
Ouais, mais enfin, je veux dire le le le
le rabbit hall, le trou du lapin, il est
il est très profond si tu commences à
partir de ce côté-là. Euh parce que les
SNF movie, on a la preuve que ça existe,
hein. Il y a un Australien qui a été
condamné qui filmait le débandrement
d'enfants, euh et donc ces vidéos
existent, elles ont été faites par des
salopards euh innommables. Euh donc euh
oui et et là quand c'est fait à dessin
de tenir quelqu'un ou d'aller au-delà,
euh c'est encore plus maquiavellique, on
va dire, qu'un psychopathe qui fait ça
pour son plaisir personnel. Euh on est
là vraiment dans le le pouvoir qui a qui
a de plus sanguinaire, de plus violent,
de de pire en fait hein, la euh la
négation de de l'existence humaine, les
les chasses d'humain, enfin tout toutes
ces choses qu'on a pu entendre. Euh et
donc euh les médias français passent à
côté de ça, hein, en disant attention,
il y a beaucoup trop de trucs justement
dont il faut pas parler parce que ça
choque le public. Euh
ont pas été suffisamment creusé. Il faut
aussi défendre il faut défendre aussi
les médias.
On peut pas on peut pas se permettre de
parler d'un truc s'ils ont pas eu le
temps de creuser.
Stop. Euh l'excuse des médias français,
c'est faut le temps d'ingérer ces 3
millions de documents. D'accord ? En 48
heures, Peter Mandelson était
démissionné en Grande-Bretagne.
Alors faut peut-être que les médias
français se former en Grande-Bretagne.
Question internet ou pas ? Question
internet. Monsieur Poulin, n'êtes-vous
pas excessivement gonflé de nous dire
que vous n'êtes pas payé en rouble alors
qu'il y a quelques heures, vous nous
vous moquiez de Jacques Lang qui affirmé
ne j ne jamais avoir touché un Copec
d'pstein.
Bah c'est ce que je viens de faire la
blague.
Voilà.
Ouais.
Euh
question internet. Que pensent nos
invités des techniques de médiation type
pleine conscience pour la plus connue
pour aider son cerveau à prendre de
recul et maîtriser ses émotions ? Ça ça
demander à lui. Moi je
Non non, je je boîte en touche. Il y a
des gens qui en parleront beaucoup mieux
que moi, mais par contre je serai
intarissable sur les techniques qui
consistent à créer des collectifs
liquides capables de recréer l'immunité
hein collective contre les ingénieries
sociales si tu veux qu'on en parle. Mais
je pense que c'est le moment où tu as
prévu de me défoncer la gueule ou pas.
Après revenons revenons à la couverture
médiatique. C'est c'est il faut prendre
aussi la défense des médias. Nous nous
on est en train de bosser dessus là sur
sur les 3 millions de doc. Euh, on est
en plus en train de bosser dessus en
utilisant un réseau parallèle qui
connaissait le gars, qui connaissait son
réseau et ainsi de suite. On remonte au
rond. Ça prend un temps de d
Et quand tu vois le niveau
journalistique, mis à part une poignée
de journalistes qui font un boulot de
Titan, la majeure partie des
journalistes qui ont traité ce truclà,
c'est c'est des soit des mis à part
Médiapar qui s'est penché sur le truc,
la plupart c'est des c'est des bleus.
Oui. Non, il y a complément d'enquête,
je te dis he qui a quand même fait un
boulot intéressant puisqu'ils ont réussi
à avoir des témoignages très bien. Euh
il y a médiia part, il y a deux trois
médias qui ont fait le taf
mais globalement c'est un sujet qui
reste tabou qu'il faut pas trop creuser,
faut passer à autre chose. C'est un
sujet comme un autre, on va dire. Voilà.
Alors que c'est pas un sujet comme un
autre. C'est l'épiphanie. C'est le sujet
révélateur d'un système ultra corrompu
où vous avez des gens qui vivent sans
limite et qui vous expliquent que vous
vous devez pas prendre l'avion parce
qu'il faut sauver la planète. Euh donc
c'est c'est ça en fait qui fait qui fait
peur et qui fait que ça se prend un peu
les pieds dans le tapis avec la question
des services de renseignement
évidemment. Quelle proximité avec le
FSB, avec le MI6, avec le MOSAD, la CIA.
Alors on parle jamais des des services
français. Bon pourtant Epstein avait un
appartement à Paris. Euh j'imagine qu'il
y avait quand même quelques informations
sur lui et les rencontres qu'il pouvait
faire compte tenu hein des des
personnalités qu'il approchait, qu'il
rencontrait. On parle de banque
d'affaires, on parle de d'hommes
politiques, on parle de de grands
réalisateurs qui ont reçu des des
Oscars. Euh donc on peut se poser là
aussi la question euh
attends va pas nous mettre nos services
de renseignement dans la sauce. Je dis
pas, je dis peut-être que justement on
est très très très bon et euh voilà, on
apparaît nulle part dans dans le
dossier. Euh mais l'idée c'est de dire
que c'est cette information comme une
autre. Euh et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que Trump a été gêné parce qu'il avait
promis la la révélation à sa base maga.
Et puis la première révélation arrive,
c'est une blague, c'est des classeurs
avec que des pages en noir où tu as
quatre influenceurs qui disent "ça y
est, on a tout, vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir." Et rien du tout. Donc
là, il est poussé à sortir cette
nouvelle révélation avec le DOJ, bien
rédactide quand même hein, donc avec les
les les les bandeaux noirs sur beaucoup
de noms et beaucoup de d'informations.
Mais ça permet de dire voilà, je l'ai
fait maintenant circuler et d'ailleurs
Trump a dit on va passer à autre chose
peut-être maintenant. Euh et ça montre
que il y a une vraie gêne profonde de
tous lestablishment démocrate comme
républicain
et pas seulement aux États-Unis. Et
c'est ça le la nouveauté, c'est que avec
Einstein, on a affaire à un réseau
global là où autrefois on avait les
balets roses, hein. Voilà, on parlait de
truc au national et puis ça n'allait pas
plus loin. Là, on a quelque chose qui
touche tout le monde occidental.
Oui, mais là, on a aussi la révélation.
Je peux me permettre de te poser une
question ? Oui.
Euh, il me semble aussi que c'est un rê
Alors, je vais me lancer dans un
exercice complotiste. Je vais faire une
hypothèse en essayant de me
faire une expérience de pensée.
Ben, je vais une expérience logique.
Euh, si tent qu'il y ait une caste au
plus haut niveau qui soit dépravé à ce
point, qui se cope mutuellement et qui a
l'air quand même d'avoir une présence
mondiale, d'accord ?
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un lien
aussi ténu soit-il entre ces pratiques
sexuelles et les efforts qui semblent
quand même de plus en plus visibles pour
faire passer la pédophilie pour une
simple orientation sexuelle ? Il y a
énormément de vidéos si énormément de
vidéos sur ce thème là aux États-Unis
qui non non non qui font des Ah oui
d'accord, j'ai compris la provocation
ironique bien sûr. Donc énormément de de
prises de parole publique avec des
millions de vues. Je même des femmes qui
en parlent, des jeunes femmes qui en
parlent sur des sites américains et dans
les réseaux sociaux en disant il faut
être moins dur avec les les pédophiles
parce que ce sont des gens qui souffrent
et tout et on pourrait presque
l'entendre d'ailleurs hein si ce n'était
dit de manière si tendancieuse et
mignonne. Et donc, est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas un lien entre le entre les pouvom
derrière ?
Alors, non, mais justement, est-ce qu'il
n'y a donc pas un lien entre les
pratiques de cette de cette caste hors
sol et la logique de sexualisation des
enfants ? Le le cette ingénierie qui
pousse à transformer les mœurs, mais
imposer la réflexion sur le genre parce
que
il y a de toute façon un courant
effectivement qui vise à ça, l'art
contemporain.
Il y a jamais de simple question,
attention.
Ouais. Mais mais l'art contemporain en
fait partie. On se rappelle de de cette
œuvre d'art euh pédophile qui qui était
exposé euh au palais de Tokyo et qui qui
est resté hein contre la vie du public.
Dis c'est pas possible en fait. Euh vous
avez Balanciaga qui a eu des campagnes
avec des gamins avec des des des oursons
euh en SM dans des chambres. Les photos
étaient ultra gloques. Ces campagnes.
Voilà, elles étaient le monde de la mode
est pas indépendant du dossier Epstein.
Il est même intrasec par le mankina. Le
recrutement se faisait par des agences
de manquina ou par des mannequins. Naomi
Cambell aussi a servi de ma Macrel d'une
certaine façon enfin au pas à certaines
mannequin.
C'est sourcé ça.
C'est sourcé absolument. Il
des soirées à sa à Saint- Tropé.
Alors la source c'est dans le DOJ et
c'était aussi des témoignages de
victimes en l'occurrence. Donc on a
beaucoup de d'informations de de ce type
là et et on voit bien que oui Yve
Saint-Laurent et et sa BD sur l'horrible
Lulu avec voilà c'est donc le monde de
la mode aime bien aussi tester les
limites, voir jusqu'où on peut aller et
et c'est et ça fait partie de cette
alors je sais pas si c'est pour pousser
l'acceptation, c'est simplement pour
voir jusqu'où on peut aller. Voilà et
chez Epstein, on allait très loin. On
passait des très bonnes soirées
visiblement entre gens du monde. Non, je
dis pas pour pousser l'acceptation, je
dis juste que c'est peut-être justement
le le signal à Florent
d'un changement de paradigme. C'estàd
l'interrogation moi que j'ai maintenant,
c'est est-ce que tout ça comme tu le
suggérais tout à l'heure démontre qu'on
on a peut-être voilà trouvé une forme de
garde fou en faisant éclater le le toute
l'affaire, d'accord ? et que donc avec
le temps on puisse mettre en place des
actions de de peut-être
il y a des juges, il y a un parquet
enquête, il y a des journalist mais ça
veut peut-être dire que c'est la partie
émergée de l'iceberg et que la tectonie
des plaques va en ce sens-là plus
profondément. Ce n'est qu'une
interrogation. Bon la légitime, je pense
attends on a quand même un minimum
confiance dans nos services de sécurité
et dans nos services sensant de la
justice. La justice son court. Peut-être
qu'ils sont peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas
bougé parce que la blague sur internet
en ce moment c'est que il y a plus
d'écureuils qui ont été mis en prison
que que de mecs persécut que de clients
d'stein en français. Bah zéro, il y a
pas un client qui a été devant un juge.
Il y a peut-être des Vous êtes pas au
courant, il y a peut-être des enquêtes,
laissons bosser les services de sécurité
parce que la Mondaine a forcément laissé
traîner des yeux et des oreilles et des
moustaches quelque part. Donc ils sont
peut-être en train de de bosser. Voyons,
on va se revoir dans 6 mois pour voir.
Question internet. Merci aux deux
invités. Que pensent les invités du
sujet suivant ? Si le système cognitif
sont piratables, pardon, si les systèmes
cognitifs sont piratables par les
manières qu'ils ont décrit et que nos
démocratie libéral ne protégeit
pas une certaine immunité collective,
aujourd'hui mise en défaut quelle
solution immunitaire et ou de protection
active d'un groupe ou d'une société sont
envisageables contre ces pratiques sans
tomber dans l'ouverture d'un ordre moins
de moine. guerrier,
c'est rédigé.
C'est rédigé. Et ben je pense là c'est
pour toi. En tout cas, ça me semble pas
une une question déplacée. Non mais tu
pardon, il me fait des blagues Montréal.
La la la personne qui pose cette
question euh nous enjoint à réfléchir en
terme de fragmentation de la société.
C'est-à-dire que si tentez qu'il y a une
une réaction immunitaire possible, il
faut que il faudrait évidemment dans nos
rêves les plus fous, hein, là je je suis
[__] je rêve, je sais pas comment il
faut dire, mais je fais l'hypothèse euh
qu'on a deux chances de s'en sortir que
si l'on retrouve une forme de
transcendance collective ou en tout cas
de méthode pour nous retrouver, rétablir
le dialogue et cetera. Euh puisque là ce
qu'on peut constater, c'est que
l'atomisation de la société que je
nommais tout à l'heure par un terme
technique hein qui vient quand même d'un
employé de la CIA qui s'appelle la
chismo jeunèse hein donc générer des
chismes dans la société on sait de
manière absolument certaine et
documentée
que ça fait déjà 3 qu générations que
tout ça est actionné à l'échelle de la
société. Alors je voudrais faire une
petite remarque. On citait tout à
l'heure Margarette Med. Ce que personne
ne sait c'est que enfin personne ne sait
c'est un peu moins connu on va dire
c'est qu'elle était devenue la compagne
de Gregory Baiteson donc un des
cfondateur
de l'école de Paloetto. Et en 1941 dans
un hôtel à New York où il y avait une
grande conférence entre cyberneticien on
va dire et passionné de de la de la
cause sociologique, elle pose une
question en public à Grégory Bideson. Je
vais le faire en substance, hein. Et
elle dit euh mais maintenant qu'on est
en train de de rentrer dans cette ce
nouveau paradigme, justement pour
ressortir un gros mot euh à savoir que
l'on va être capable de manipuler le
sentiment des foules, à minima de le
mesurer, d'en faire quelque chose,
qu'est-ce qui se passe si ça tombe entre
les mains des puissants ? Et Gregory Bon
se lève et il dit "Alors, bon ben bonne
question, mais c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut la poser." En fait, il faut savoir
ce qu'il dit en substance. "J'ai
vraiment étudié le truc, ça m'a
passionné. Ce que j'ai trouvé absolument
ahurissant, c'est qu'il ne parle pas de
garde fou. Il dit "C'est trop tard et le
premier métier des de tous les
ingénieurs sociaux", dit-il en
substance, consistera à dissimuler les
finalités de ceux qui utiliseront ce
pouvoir démesuré. parce que si le public
est au courant des finalités, il va les
questionner et donc ça va introduire un
facteur perturbateur dans la logique
manipulatoire et donc ça ne marchera
plus et donc les gens vont se hérisser
le poil, ils vont résister et on ne sera
plus on ne sera plus en mesure
d'utiliser nos nos logiciels prédictifs.
Donc leur première leur première
obsession doit être de dissimuler leur
finalité. Je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte de l'énormité de la veu et
on parle de 1941 voilà il y a 80 ans.
Donc voilà où on en est en terme 85 ans
en terme d'évolution.
On va passer à un autre sujet. Vous avez
peut-être quelque chose à rajouter
là-dessus
sur la réponse à ça. Oui. Non, c'est
l'organisation collective aussi le fait
de faire ce travail là de de prise de
conscience populaire qui est en train de
de je pense effectivement de fonctionner
mais au-delà des
des différents
états des lieux qu'on peut faire et
qu'on fait à longueur de journée, c'est
la solution. Enfin les solutions.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Et là,
c'est le l'idée de de Frédéric du paris
de l'intelligence collective,
c'est-à-dire de s'organiser de manière
stratégique. Euh le pic le pic pic pic.
Oui, le pic c'est le rice. Alors,
c'est là qu'on se fait défoncer ou pas ?
Oui.
OK.
Attends Alexis, vas-y.
Non, non, mais je vais passer la la
Donc quand tu m'as appelé, tu m'as dit
que tu lançais un parti politique.
Un mouvement citoyen.
Un mouvement citoyen. Bon, j'ai dit
parti politique.
Un mouvement citoyen. Et qu'est-ce que
je t'ai répondu ? Tu m'as dit euh en
tant qu'am sache que ça ne servira à
rien, tu vas dans le mur, c'est foutu,
il faut quitter la France. Et
personnellement,
j'ai pas dit il faut quitter la France
tout de suite.
Mais tu voilà, je sais pas, je dis tout,
je suis en full disclosure ou pas ?
Bah vas-y.
Bah, tu as dit que tu en pouvais plus
toi non plus et que tu n'y croyais plus.
Et à ce moment-là, qu'est-ce que je t'ai
répondu ? Qu'est-ce que je t'ai répondu
?
Donc pour te provoquer, je t'ai dit ça
et tu m'as répondu, il faut y croire.
Non. Alors ce que je t'ai je t'ai
répondu ça, je t'ai je t'ai parlé avec
le cœur mais ça je le garde pour après.
Là j'ai une réponse, on va dire
méthodique et rationnelle à te faire.
Déjà celle-là c'est celle que je pose
toujours sur la table quand je discute
avec des gens qui sont devenus qui se
sont désengagés qui deviennent
niilistes. D'accord. Qui disent c'est
foutu
trouve que nous on est désengagé ?
Non vous n'êtes pas désengagé. Par
contre vous n'avez plus d'espérance et
nuance importante avec l'espoir. C'est
pas vrai ? Non non, nuance importante
avec l'espoir. Je parle de l'espérance
comme on va dire une vertu cardinale
quoi, qui imprègne notre notre
civilisation he quelque part. Bon mais
attends, la première des choses que je
mets sur la table quand je suis face à
des gens qui se évidemment je ne pense
pas que tu sois désengagé, c'est la
moindre des choses, mais on rebondissait
sur tes termes. D'accord. Bon, on va
dire sceptique aussi peut-être quand à
certaines initiatives. Voilà, ce qui est
peut-être plus juste bon
sceptique ou vigilant d'ailleurs hein.
Peut-être une manière aussi très
protectrice de de ta part. C'est pour ça
que je l'ai dit, de dire à des amis ne
va pas là-dedans, tu vas t'en prendre
plein la gueule. Je comprends crave,
je comprends. Mais regarde, ne va pas
là-dedans, tu vas t'en prendre plein la
gueule. C'est foutu, euh c'est
dangereux, ça sert à rien. Bon et bien,
j'estime que c'est le résultat d'une
ingénierie sociale. Quiconque
démissionne d'une certaine façon euh
c'est-à-dire ne sortira plus du
diagnostic de la situation qui est
pourtant, je le répète, je le dis en
présence d'Alexis qui fait un travail
extraordinaire de diagnostic. Je veux
dire, c'est le journaliste par
excellence. Si je dis pas ça pour le
flagorn évidemment non mais c'est vrai
c'est il fait partie des derniers vrais
journalistes. C'est bien pour ça que le
système a eu besoin de trop tu le tapes.
Non non il peut pas le dire lui donc je
le dis moi
é
je pense que beaucoup on est beaucoup à
le penser.
Comment tu dis élevé avec le point en la
cota ?
Alors là ça dépasse mes compétences mais
je veux bien t'écouter.
Tuattends qu' ça c'est bison.
Ouais avec le point. Vas-y.
Et avec le point on dit comment
Darman ?
Non tu es horrible. Tu es possédé par le
démon toi. Maintenant, on est un petit
persuadé.
Quand je te dis ça, quand j'essaie de te
démotiver, quand je te mets une
balayette dans tes petits jeux test.
C'est un crash test. Tu me connais sûr.
Oui, je t'ai dis merci. Et j'y ai vu la
preuve d'une forme d'intégrité
journalistique. On
n'est pas journaliste.
D'ailleurs, je t'ai même dit si si
jamais tu avais l'air trop sympa avec
moi, au moins je parle de mon mouvement,
euh tu vas le décrédibiliser et et toi
avec. Donc
très bien, le scepticisme est
nécessaire. C'est pour ça que je te dis,
on n'est pas journaliste.
Bah évidemment,
donc pour te chauffer un peu,
tu pars quoi
avec tu tu habité ton couteau, il y a
c'est financé comment ? Tu touches des
roubles, des dollars ? Tu mises sur quoi
? Tu tu crois en la marmotte ? Comment
ça se passe ?
Alors concrètement, prends ça comme une
riposte cognitive. Il y a des
ingénieries sociales. C'est bien pour ça
qu'on a parlé du on a passé du temps à
parler.
Euh et si tentez qu'il y ait des
officines, on parlait la
franc-maçonnerie qui durent des siècles,
je réfléchis avec cette aspiration qui
peut sembler c'est pas une officine, il
faut les défendre aussi. C'est un
mouvement.
Oh non !
Si tentez en tout cas qu'on est
on les connaît pas assez pour pouvoir se
se formuler. Évite de faire ça. Bon
alors si tenter en tout cas qu'il y ait
des entités qui de façon obscure et pas
toujours en tout cas très nettes
des associations
des associations d'êtres humains
qui s'échangent des petites bouts de
pain avant de manger qui
voilà qui s'échangent des petites bouts
de pain des des voilà qui font des ce
qu'on appelle des comment on appelle ça
déjà
des soirées à thème rour
soiré à thème voilà et cetera si tentez
que tout cela existez-vous
combien est-ce que nous sommes à avoir
réussi à entériner dans la durée euh
sous forme de repost des associations
qui a une chance d'être à peu près aussi
solide et capable
de leur rendre l'appareil, on en a pas.
Donc la première des étapes
rendre l'appareil,
bah rendre l'appareil, c'est-à-dire être
nous-même aussi organisé, structurer,
avoir un plan, une stratégie, une
méthode. Voilà, en effet l'ingénierie
sociale d'ailleurs he c'est un petit peu
tout à l'heure, on en parlait comme le
nudge. À l'origine, il y a même une
dimension de déontologie à l'intérieur.
Quand on parle du nudge, on dit
aujourd'hui le nudge, tu demandes à
Inia, elle va si elle est un peu
empathique envers toi, elle va dire
"Ouais, c'est mal." Mais à l'origine le
nudge, c'est "J'architecture
l'information de telle sorte que je te
confronte à ta liberté. D'ailleurs, pour
ça qu'on parlait de paternalisme
libertarien, paternaliste parce que je
te dis ce qui est bien pour toi, mais en
même temps, j'ai l'intention par
honnêteté intellectuel de te dire tous
les autres choix que tu pourrais faire.
Donc cette espèce de de d'étrange
expression fonctionne à l'origine et
elle est source de de désaliénation
même. D'accord ? Et puis évidemment,
c'est dévoyé parce qu'en tant que
méthode, en tant que technique, on peut
l'utiliser aussi pour manipuler des
peuples. Alors pour moi qui me suis
intéressé au Nudge dès le départ, c'est
un dévoiement. Et d'ailleurs le
co-auteur de Richard Teller publie
énormément,
on revient à Picp.
Oui, mais justement je je suis en plein
dedans. Le cohoteur de Cast Susttain
notamment de de Richard Teller qui
s'appelle Cast Sustainstein a publié
beaucoup de matières pour dire on est
dans le dévoiement du nudge. Quand on
fait le quand on s'intéresse à
l'intelligence collective, on
s'intéresse de la même manière à ce qui
fait qu'on devient bête
individuellement. Le contraire de
intelligence collective, c'est bêtises
individuelles. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
naturellement on est naturellement bête
individuellement ? parce que d'abord il
y a un immense dévoiement par les
ingénieries sociales, d'accord, de c de
cette possibilité, de cette capacité de
coalition de appelle ça comme tu veux un
transcendance collective, synergie entre
les gens, synergie citoyenne. Tout ça en
fait est abîmé par la persécution
psychologique, le bombardement psychique
dont nous faisons l'objet. Et là, je
veux insister sur un point absolument
pas fait consciemment parce que des fois
la géopolitique te bombarde.
Oui, on peut dire même que il y a des
réflexes de cast qui sont tout à fait
organiques et qui sont de l'ordre
d'ordre reptilien. Ce sont des gens qui
protègent la prospérité de leurs empires
pour pouvoir les transmettre à leurs
enfants. Donc quand tu as compris ça et
que tu réfléchis selon leur prisme, tu
te dis bah peut-être qu'à leur place, je
deviendrai aussi tout aussi cinglé.
D'accord. Bon, donc l'intelligence
collective, c'est la puissance
immunitaire qui, si on parvient à la
rétablir, nous permettra de de justement
d'organiser la rpost. Et là, je voulais
justement, je me suis interrompu pour
avant de dire un truc essentiel. Ce qui
fait très très peur à cette caste, c'est
pas 98 et5 % des gens en tant que masse
potentiellement
à même de se transformer en meut très en
colère. D'accord ? Ce qui fait très peur
au pouvoir, c'est les 1 et demi à 2 et
demi 4 % maximum de la population qui à
un moment donné pourrait se réengager
avec une telle puissance de conviction,
avec un plan suffisamment solide et une
stratégie suffisamment lumineuse pour
embarquer les autres. Donc quand il y a
caractère assassination comme on en
parlait, quand il y a oblitération euh
des chercheurs de vérité comme dans le
cas d'Alexis et de temps d'autres et et
quand il y a visibilisation de cette
chaîne par exemple, il y a une volonté
d'empêcher une émergence et non pas un
phénomène de meut. La meute en fait on
la manipule en la laissant dans ce
comment dire cet environnement rassurant
qui est l'état nounou qui est tout ce
qu'on a dit en terme d'hypnose et de
translective. la scotomisation des
esprits. On en parlait tout à l'heure
pour sortir des gros mots et ce que ça
intéresse. On connaît ces méthodesl
raison de rappeler tout à l'heure aussi
qu'on peut pas forcément prévoir les
incidents extérieurs qui pourraient
déstabiliser tout ça. Mais l'ingénierie
sociale encore une fois c'est pas la
prédictibilité exacte de la géopolitique
et de ce qui peut se passer à l'échelle
d'une nation ou de ou de d'une
civilisation. D'accord ? C'est l'heure
et la manière d'en tirer parti quand ça
se produit. Donc c'est une façon, comme
l'explique très bien Naomi Clin,
beaucoup de gens ici doivent connaître
parmi notre audience, la stratégie du
choc n'est consiste pas forcément à
provoquer le choc he ce qu'ils ont fait
notamment au Chili, Salvador Aliend
quand les Chicago Boys sont allés là-bas
et ont utilisé en quelque sorte l'état
de la société pour faire passer de
grandes transformations. C'est
exactement ce qu'ils font dans notre
pays. Moi, j'ai aucune preuve à apporter
ni même aucune conviction en la matière
pour savoir s'il y a intentionnalité
voir provocation des crises. vous
recommande chaudement le dernier
discours de monsieur Alliendé.
Voilà. Alors pour revenir au au paris de
l'intelligence collective, d'abord,
pourquoi le paris c'est un paris au sens
pascalier, on va dire hein. C'est-à-dire
que si on n pas un minimum de capacité à
lui accorder un peu de foi à ce à cette
intelligence collective, ça a aucune
chance de de fonctionner. Mais ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans la notion de Paris,
c'est que c'est un peu aussi le
contraire si on regarde bien le terme de
l'excès de certitude. C'est-à-dire qu'en
effet, la rhtorique c'est quoi ? Quand
on l'applique à la politique, au partis
et et je dirais au discours ambiant,
c'est toujours un excès de certitude,
hein, vous savez. C'est le fameux terme,
les ultra crépidarianiste
qui amène toujours un lot de certitude
euh sur les plateaux et qui sont
déclarés experts parce qu'ils arrivent à
aligner trois mots et qui ils ont un
espèce de vernis mondin comme on dit sur
tel ou tel sujet. Ils affichent des
certitudes parce que la certitude est
binable comme on pourrait dire. Ça donne
envie euh d'acheter et d'écouter mais
économique et on regard tout court et
c'est si vous reprenez les déclarations
des gars sur 4 ans, c'est quand même à
mourir de rien. Bien sûr. Bien sûr.
Alors dans cet excès de certitude, nous
qu'est-ce qu'on dit ? On dit que on vit
euh alors dans mon métier, on parle
souvent, tu dois connaître je pense cet
acronyme qui dit vuka hein. Donc quand
le traduit en français vola-il un
certain ambigu imprévisible. Nous vivons
dans un monde vuka. Je traduis en
français directement. D'accord. Donc
volat-il un certain ambigu et
imprévisible. Bon, déjà ça ramène un
petit peu d'humidité parce qu'en effet,
dans mon métier, on part de cette
donnée-là et on essaie de voir ce qu'on
peut éventuellement consolider pour se
préparer au pire. Donc là, on revient
mon panégiérique des euh des
complotistes. Système robuste.
Un système robuste, c'est un système qui
fonctionne comme une matrice de risque
et qui dit voilà là où ça peut planter.
Donc pic pic.
Donc le pic, justement celui-là observe
la première matrice de risque, c'est
qu'on arrive pas à se mettre d'accord.
Et ouais. Alors quand je dis je parle
d'intelligence collective à des
imbéciles se
mettre d'accord ou trouver un consensus
?
Ah pardon.
Se mettre d'accord ou trouver un
consensus ? Alors justement le dissensus
c'est le signe que le collectif est en
bonne santé. Le consensus d'abord il est
emmerdant, pas stimulant et ça veut dire
queon a que justement des imbéciles
entre eux. Et justement j'allais parler
des imbéciles un peu méchamment qu'ils
ne m'en veuillent pas hein. Pardon aux
imbéciles généralement ils ne se
reconnaissent pas. Faut il faut que tu
arrêtes de dire imbécile personne
d'imbécile.
Non non non, prends-le au sens
étymologique. L'idiot on va dire du
village qui reste dans son enclos. Bon
mais pourquoi ? Parce que ça n'est
d'ailleurs pas une nature que d'être
imbécile en ce moment hein. D'accord.
C'est une c'est un état qui est induit
par une société qui nous abrutit et qui
nous chrétiennise de plus en plus. Donc
qu'est-ce que font généralement ceux qui
sont complètement endormis ? Ils te
disent "Ah bon l'intelligence collective
? Donc vous pensez être spontanément
intelligent ?" On dit ben non pas du
tout. Ça se travaille. L'intelligence
collective exige que l'on réunisse un
certain nombre de paramètres. Donc je
reviens sur mon environnement incertain.
L'environnement est incertain parce
qu'il est fragmenté. Il est fragmenté
parce qu'il y a des courants de pensées
euh concurrentiel. D'accord ? Qui chacun
qui mieux mieux dans l'attractivité va
dire "Venez chez moi, j'ai la meilleure
des solutions." C'est il se passe
exactement la même chose que dans les
chiquers politiques au cœur de des
mouvements citoyens dans leur ensemble.
Les mouvements comme on dit parfois
citoyennistes. D'accord. qui ne mèent
jamais à rien
qui
qui ne mè jamais
qui ne mèent jamais à rien pour une
raison simple, c'est que vous en
trouverez très peu qui sont capables
justement de définir la dans cette
matrice des risques le principal facteur
de division à savoir que je veux dire un
truc tout bête qu'on dit jamais hein
franchement et j'ai beaucoup creusé bah
que quand quelqu'un te dit je suis
démocrate tu as plein de gens dans la
salle pour dire ah donc il doit être
sympa mais démocrate ça veut rien dire
rien en fait on a un corpus scientifique
de référence sur des générations et je
je remonte pas à l'époque grecque hein
je te parle même allez on juste au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondial
de gens qui sont tous les penseurs du
système délibératif ou participatif ou
démocratique idéal. Ils ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux. Il n'y a que des
querelles entre eux. D'accord.
Des fois ça mè quelque chose, ça donne
les gilets jaunes puis ils se font tirer
dans la tête
comme des des comme des mesures de
contre-insurrection de pays du tiers
monde. C'est ça. Ouais. Ouais. C'est ça.
Non, même pas. Je suis désolé.
Alexis, tu vas rebondir sur Est-ce que
tu connaissais Pic ?
Bien sûr.
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que Fred m'en a parlé que moi
j'avais j'avais l'idée de faire
l'alliance populaire. euh qui était de
réunir tous les mouvements citoyens
justement de démocratie directe parce
qu'ils sont nombreux et en fait ils ont
pas la visibilité parce qu'il y a pas de
de marketing autour de ça.
Vous connaissez le DAR ?
Euh c'est le Vas-y, cit ça. C'était
Patrick Sébastien.
Exactement. Donc tu as de la mémoire
toi.
Ouais. Et là il se relance, tu as vu
pour
il relance le D.
Il relance un autre truc. Il dit "Je
veux faire un sorte de single tank là
maintenant. Il parle plus de partie.
Mais entre- temps, il y a eu des
chansons comme la Kqueta Raou. Est-ce
que tu l'as vu mon cul ? encore plus à
évoluer quoi. Mais c'est vrai
mé par surprise.
Ouais. Et donc l'idée que j'avais
c'était ça l'alliance populaire et de
dire tous ces mouvements citoyens font
leurs trucs et ils font des trucs
incroyables. Essayent de politiser les
gens, essayent de voir qu'il y a des
alternatives à la démocratie
représentative qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui on demande jamais ou très
peu la vie des des citoyens. Etth et
puis Fred est arrivé avec le pic en
m'expliquant ce qui était que le paris
de l'intelligence collective. le travail
qu'il y avait derrière euh et je
trouvais que c'était vraiment euh ça
s'inscrivait dans cette démarche-là et
qu'il y avait un travail d'équipe que
moi j'avais pas et il faut trouver aussi
les les moyens de de s'organiser. Et
donc euh c'est comme ça que j'ai j'ai
euh j'ai j'ai rejoint l'initiative en
disant bah on peut on peut je pense à
partir de là construire quelque chose
euh de l'ordre de l'action, pas du
verbiage. C'est-à-dire que là on parle
beaucoup. Ce qu'on veut maintenant c'est
s'organiser de manière efficace. Alors,
il y a il y a Ran Brco qui a lancé les
ruches, hein, où on peut dire lui alors
il se projette pour 2027 en disant "Je
vais jouer le jeu du tribin, je mets ma
gueule et je dis qu'il y a des ruches et
puis on va faire quelque chose." Le
programme est déjà fait. Bon, c'est pas
forcément euh euh c'est pas du tout
d'ailleurs la démarche du pic puisque
l'idée c'est de de construire d'abord un
cadre pour ensuite avoir un système et
dire "Nous euh on va pas jouer le jeu
hein. Alors ça va prendre du temps
évidemment puisqueon va pas jouer le jeu
euh tribunicien de de l'incarnation et
euh du jeu de de la présidentielle euh
mais on peut hacker je disais voilà
peut-être en faisant semblant de jouer
au jeu. Moi, j'ai inventé un personnage
qui s'appelle le président d'Inde où je
mets un chapeau de d'Inde et je me
présente comme un président d'un pays
fictif, la président d'OT et le
président a des ambitions pour 2027 en
France. Donc pourquoi pas ? Et plutôt
qu'annexer un pays par la force, allons
allons devant la l'alè populaire voir si
on peut faire quelque chose.
Et le pic avec le président ne s'est mal
barré là.
Alors
tu as laissé faire ça.
Alors puisqu'on parlait tout à l'heure
d'étymologie,
tu étais d'accord pour qu'il se mette
une dente sur la tête. Oui oui pour
parce que parce qu'on était sur
l'étymologie des mots tout à l'heure.
Attends avant que tu repartes sur le
mode scrabble.
Ouais.
Non mais celui-là il rapporte pas
beaucoup.
Vas-y.
C'est humour. Humor en latin. C'est les
fluides. L'humour permet de d'apporter
une certaine fluidité au message.
Et je pense que c'est notre plus fidèle
bouclier. C'est celui d'ailleurs qui
éveille aussi l'esprit critique et donc
il a raison de décaper le jeu politique
en s'en moquant. Mais je rappelle que
quand Coluche a fait son discours 3
semaines plus tard, il était lui-même il
était lui-même surpris d'avoir 17 %
d'intention de vote et on sait que ça
s'est mal fini. Mais ce que l'histoire
ne dit pas, c'est qu'il a lui-même été
un complot là, c'est pour savoir à quel
niveau là. Tu penses que Coluch il s'est
tué tout seul ou pas tout seul ?
Je n'ai que des hypothèses.
Très bien
encore une fois enquête.
J'ai aucune preuve. Bon
non mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
c'est le résultat c'est et et de
regarder le processus comme je t'ai dit.
Moi je suis analyste stratégique, je
regarde toujours les processus. C'est
c'est une déformation professionnelle.
Bon ben c'est simple à dire, il avait
pas d'équipe, pas de logistique alors
que c'est Coluche. Nous on a une
conviction qui est qu'il faut d'abord
commencer à être, tu te rappelles du
terme qu'on utilisait en parlant de la
strotter film, on est grass route,
c'est-à-dire qu'on part d'en bas et on
va chercher ceux qui par le cumul de
leurs audiences et de leur notoriété
sont capables de porter le message.
C'est pour ça que la présence d'Alexis
Poulin, immense merci parce qu'il a
entendu le truc, il a dit "OK, il y a
une équipe, il y a un dispositif et sur
la tête." Oui.
Non, ça c'était
Tu fais de la moto ?
Non,
ça va.
Et donc pourquoi la dinde sur la tête ?
Euh alors parce que j'avais que ça à
disposition en fait parce que avec les
gamins, on était allé acheter des trucs
pour rigoler et il y avait ce chapeau de
dinde. Voilà et je voulais faire un
discours pour singer les discours de
Nouveland, de Macron. Et donc je m'étais
dit bon il faut trouver un truc pour que
ce soit un peu plus rigolo que juste
singer un discours. Et donc j'ai mis un
chapeau de d en disant je suis le
président d'Inde et voilà et après ça je
me dis mais en fait le président a un
énorme succès. Par exemple là sur
YouTube cette année j'ai fait les vœux
du présidente. Il y a eu plus de vues de
vues du vœux des présides que des vues
de des vœux de Macron sur YouTube.
C'est QFD.
Voilà donc déjà un signal faible. Euh
voilà mais c'est vrai que on comment
dire on commence à sensibiliser les gens
avec des mêmes avec l'humour. On voit
bien la la puissance subversive euh du
même et je dirais de la Satire.
N'oublions pas que la Satire est est
globalement étouffée en France hein et
beaucoup d'évolutions récentes. Oui.
Euh mais les gens aiment bien aussi
queon soit capable de complémentariser
ce type de campagne avec un peu de
sérieux derrière pour dire non et
d'ailleurs j'ai un plan.
Bon alors là si tu veux bien je voudrais
parler un peu de démocratie.
Avant que tu parles de démocratie parce
que on va en prendre pour 15 piges.
Minimum minimum.
J'essaie de l'énerver mais il est très
difficile à l'énerver. Ça fait des
années que je connais. arrive jamais à
l'énerver.
Non non, il s'énerve pas.
Ça dépend des jours hein.
Ah ouais.
Tu t'énerves pas ?
Bah là, j'ai fait une vidéo qui a qui a
qui a dépassé 25 millions de vues en
cumul sur tous les réseaux juste parce
que j'étais très en colère ce jour-là.
C'était quand ?
C'était en mars
2024.
Tu disais des bêtises dedans ? Parce que
nous
Non, pas du tout. Je l'assume
totalement. Je l'ai même mise sur le
site du pic euh parce que elle a eu un
effet déclencheur et que je l'ai mise en
ligne à 2h du mat en disant c'est mon
suicide social mais j'assume de dire
tout ce que je pense et puis après
j'arrête. Donc à 2h du mat, l'algo est
contre moi. La vidéo explose. Elle est
reprise partout. Personne ne sait qui je
m'appelle. On dit juste c'est un père en
colère. Je mets tout le monde au défi
d'aller sur le site du pic pic.vote pour
la trouver.
Ouais. Tu as calibré tes serveurs
derrière et ta vente passante ?
Non, on est foutu de ce côté-là. Donc
allez sur YouTube sur politoscope, vous
tapez mon nom paradia mon pseudo
paradis.
Alors non. Et donc très intéressant les
offres de contribution massives que j'ai
reçu par centaines et par milliers. Elle
a même été diffusée sur LinkedIn. Il y a
trois amis dont les comptes ont sauté
parce qu' ils ont mis cette vidéo, leurs
comptes ont sauté définitivement et je
suis désolé, c'est un rire nerveux,
pardon les gars. Euh et donc ce qui
était très intéressant, c'est c'est que
derrière on a philosophé sur la la
notion de colère, la dimension je dirais
structurante
sursaut de vie de la colère. Moi-même,
ça m'a surpris. J'ai j'ai je me suis
aperçu que dans ces moments-là, en se
mettant en acceptant de se mettre en
scène, hein, comme le dit au marcharif,
il dit euh j'ai fait le plus beau métier
du monde parce qu'il m'a appris à
enlever le masque social. Donc parfois
quand on a une caméra et quand on sait
qu'on est filmé, on se dit dans le doute
je vais être transparent, je vais être
moi et parfois on va plus loin que
prévu. En fait, tout à coup, on atteint
quelque chose qui est très surprenant et
qui a une osmose qui se fait avec des
gens qui disent "Merci, tu l'as dit pour
moi, on pouvait plus le dire." Moi, je
pensais que c'était terminé après, hein.
Et donc, cette vidéo a été beaucoup
beaucoup reprise. Elle m'a éclairé déjà
sur alors pardon, je plpp les grands
mots, mais sur la reprise de ma
souveraineté individuelle qui est la
condition euh syéquanon avant de se
mettre dans un groupe où l'on pourrait
collectivement retrouver une
souveraineté. Euh donc, je veux dire
bien sûr à l'échelle de la nation, à
l'échelle d'un peuple, d'accord ? Et la
condition première, c'est en effet tout
ce qu'on a évoqué jusqu'ici, c'est le
diagnostic, c'est de le mûir, de le
maturer et après quand on est prêt, on
est une toute petite proportion de la
population prête à créer la bonne
alliance, le bon partenariat pour
reprendre le pays et rendre le pouvoir
au peuple.
Question au présidente.
Donc pic pic pic euh d'art tr piqu hein.
Attention. Bah oui, pic pic depuis tout
à l'heure, il nous fait le por ruche.
Ouais, on est sur un thématique. Ouais.
Euh vous pensez faire des
faire
faire des alliances
des mainsidess
de construire pense que tout ça fait
partie d'une ébullition
nécessaire
parce que le diagnostic est fait
suffisamment
voilà
et que on a atteint un se critique où
assez de citoyens se rendent compte que
le jeu de la démocratie représentative
bon un les règles sont pipées c'est
toujours les mêmes qui gagnent de Ça va
être de pire en pire avec on parlait du
DSA en introduction et la volonté
d'Emmanuel Macron de voilà de contrôler
davantage enfin pas que de lui mais on
va dire des États et des acteurs publics
de contrôler davantage les les réseaux
sociaux. Euh donc il faut trouver euh
une alternative, quelque chose qui
justement permet de dire l'action
politique euh a encore euh un déboucher
possible dans un une construction
différente du système actuel qui alors
assure sa survie au prix euh de notre
mort collective. C'est bien ça le
problème. Et donc l'idée c'est de
d'aller chercher les gens, de dire
"Ouais, voilà euh toutes ces toutes ces
initiatives euh elles sont
complémentaires, elles sont même
similaires. Et donc l'idée c'est pas
d'être concurrent ou dire "On va faire
un truc et on va refaire le jeu des
parties où on va avoir donc un une part
de marché et puis on va on va on va
jouer de ça parce que le jeu des parties
c'est ça, c'est des entreprises qui
prennent du du temps de cerveau
disponible et qui ont une part de
marché. Euh et et donc plutôt que de
faire ça, essayons justement d'être
malin dès le début. Et le pic et cet
outil, je pense qu'il permet de d'avoir
cette vision-là.
Hm hm. Alors, je voudrais revenir à la
démocratie si tu permets.
On y était, hein.
Non, mais de de bien sûr. Euh, mais je
voudrais euh expliquer pourquoi ça
marche pas jusqu'ici. Euh, parce que
depuis que je creuse ce sujet et je suis
moi-même
très très engagé sur ce thème-là puisque
dès 2009, quand j'ai eu mon ce plateau
télé sur lequel on s'est connu euh à
Paris, euh je tout va bien. Non non mais
je suis en train de réveiller le deux
là. Ça va les gars ?
Euh j'ai j'ai dû faire je sais pas une
centaine de talk et de plateaux et
d'interview ne serait-ce qu'avec Étienne
Cho d'accord. Bon alors depuis depuis
quelques années que je m'intéresse à
tout ça, j'ai compris un truc en fait
tout bête. J'avais pas encore je réalise
en fait qu'il y a un vrai coup d'entrée.
C'est que la réflexion donc ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la pensée démocratique,
elle est incroyablement riche mais
bourrée de contradiction intrinsèque. Et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on n'y
arrive pas. Toi qui est toi qui est
assez mat et qui a un esprit
scientifique, essaie d'imaginer un
diagramme en croix. D'accord ? Et sur ce
diagramme, non attends écoute-moi,
écoute-moi. Non, écoute-moi, t'énerve
pas.
Je vais aller jusqu'au bout du truc. Ça
va ça vaux, il connaît. Et alors un
diagramme on croit. Vas-y, je t'écoute.
Ah
oui, non mais pour que tu visualis
fonce fonce.
Non, non mais bon, je pense que tu vas
apprécier la rationalisation du truc, la
tentative on va dire défoncer qui
m'énerve.
Toi, tu peux pas et tu t'es sourant.
Donc ça me fait plaisir. Au moins on se
marre un peu.
Parce que quand je souris, c'est que je
les d je je je pense pouvoir réussir
mais peut-être que je me trompe et le
débat est ouvert et c'est sincère, c'est
pas une posture. Je pense pouvoir
réussir à dire comment on peut
cartographier les courants de pensée
démocratique. Pourquoi ? Il y a une
première il y a un premier élément de
dialectique entre deux extrêmes, on va
dire à l'intérieur de la pensée
démocratique. Ceux qui pensent que la
substance du message,
c'est-à-dire la possibilité d'éclairer,
de faire un citoyen éclairé, tu sais,
qui qui développe ses connaissances avec
l'aide d'expert désintéressé et c la
substance du message est plus importante
que la procédure. Donc tu as déjà ces
deux notions qui sont en dialectique
permanent. Pourquoi ? Parce que la
procédure, c'est pour dire la procédure,
si elle est hyper rigoureuse, c'est pas
une question d'éclairer le citoyen,
c'est de s'assurer que tout le monde
participe de la même manière et qu'on a
bien une photographie à un instant téé
de ce que c'est que le peuple. Je donc
premier point maintenant, je te fais la
arrête de parler comme un politique avec
les mains qui s'agitent. Ça ça m'énerve.
Ouais, ça t'in ou ça me permet de
visualiser la croix. Ça te permet de ton
raisonnement pour toi-même y a il y a
deux Moi, ça m'aide, c'est vrai,
j'avoue. Il y a deux autres termes qui
dialectis en pose tes mains.
Il y a deux autres termes qui dialectis
en permanence.
Euh c'est la délibération versus la
participation. Je m'explique. La une
délibération de de qualité est
impossible si trop de gens participent.
D'accord. Oui. Une délibération de
qualité est impossible si trop de gens
participent. Non mais ça c'est le cœur
du on va dire du corpus scientifique de
tous ceux qui bossent depuis longtemps.
James Fishkin, vous avez Liskin, vous
avez Henè Landmor, vous avez voilà, je
fais un peu de name dropping mais les
gens auront peut-être envie d'aller
chercher et c'est passionnant en plus on
a des résumés de leurs pensées un peu
partout. Bon et donc quand tu as ce
pardon pour les mains, quand tu as ce
diagramme en tête,
tu as des gens par exemple qui disent
"Mais ce qui est plus important étant
donné que le le citoyen lambda est
complètement ignar, c'est de l'enfermer
dans une pièce comme on le fait par
exemple dans l'état de l'Oregon depuis
2010. On prend 25 citoyens tirés au sort
et on leur dit "On a un projet de
référendum et vous allez l'analyser en
amont." On s'est aperçu et ça c'est une
donnée scientifique factuelle bruit. Tu
nous as demandé d'être factuel que ces
24 25 personnes qui sont tirées au sort
inspirent plus confiance au peuple de
l'État d'Oregon que le Congrès
américain, ce qui est une donnée quand
même intéressante. Et là, on a le recul
de plus de 15 ans d'expérimentation.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ? En petit comité, ils analysent ce
qui fera l'objet d'un référendum. Mais
là, vous avez encore des d'autres
penseurs de des courants démocratiques
qui disent "Non, non, mais attendez, ça
c'est pas bon." Parce qu'en fait, le
peuple n'est pas aussi éclairé que ces
personnes-là qu'on tir au sort et qui
font une petite délibération. Euh donc,
ils ne sont pas représentatifs du
peuple, ils sont peut-être déjà
manipulés. Est-ce que vous comprenez ?
Alors, je passe à la solution. Pourquoi
est-ce que c'est intéressant de
cartographier les courants démocratiques
? Parce que d'abord, on le fait jamais h
et qu'on va dans le mur à cause de ça.
Et une fois qu'on est dans le dur, on a
quelqu'un qui dit "Bah ouais, désolé,
moi je suis pour que le temps de parole
de tout le monde." Donc tout le monde a
le même temps de parole. Ouais, très
bien. Il y en a qui vont dire "Oui, mais
attends, est-ce qu'on est représentatif
? Est-ce qu'on est un échantillon
vraiment représentatif du peuple ?" Et
puis tu as des gens plus scientifiques
qui vont dire "Oh [__] mais les gars,
vous allez dans le mur, les billets
cognitifs, tu connais ça et des effets
d'entraînement." D'ailleurs, les gens
qui ont donné tort au mini public
délibératif sont des gens qui ont dit "À
chaque fois, vous allez voir, c'est
l'homme blanc de plus de 50 ans qui a
une capacité de tribun qui va prendre la
parole." Or, ces dernières décennies, on
a eu la totale contradiction de ça. On
s'aperçu que c'était faux. On a la
preuve scientifique et factuelle qu'en
fait des gens de absolument de toutes
les classes sociales participent. Quand
donc tu remets tout ça à l'intérieur
d'un même logiciel, tu sais ce que tu
changes la chronologie. Tu dis pas
"J'appartiens à un tel segment de pensée
démocratique", c'est-à-dire ceux qui
sont là pour la substance versus la
participation versus la délibération. Tu
t'en fiches ? Tu sais ce que tu fais ?
Tu le segmentes en étape chronologique.
Exemple très bon d'ailleurs de l'état de
l'Oregon que je donnais. Au lieu de par
exemple de lancer une démocratie
référendaire en disant c'est ça et rien
d'autre, tu peux le faire en deux temps.
Tu peux combiner le le mini public
délibératif, d'accord, avec la partie
référendum qui s'adresse à tout le
monde. C'est-à-dire que le mini public
délibératif pourrait être celui qui
conçoit les questions qui seraient
posées au peuple. Et ensuite les bonnes
questions. Donc on n'est pas dans le
solutionnisme d'un petit groupe de gens
qui se croient plus éclairés que les
autres, d'accord ? Et mieux renseignés.
Cela travaillerait principalement à la
création de questions pour ensuite les
passer au peuple. Rien que ça, c'est une
petite révolution dans la pensée
démocratique. Voilà, je m'arrête là mais
OK. Euh question. Est-ce que tu as
essayé de réfléchir en terme de vélocité
et d'inertie ?
Oui, puisque le
D'accord. système ton système d'accord
de d'assemblée où on se consulte on
essaie de faire émerger des propositions
des problèmes
le système réveille-toi président
donc vélocité inertie euh je te mets des
facteurs contraignants exotiqu
ouais bien sûr d'accord
crise énergétique
euh crise écologique
je te crise de guerre économique crise
attends crise de tu as consulté tes
petits copains autour de la tablette et
de la marmotte. Et donc crise de guerre
économique, comportement prédateur de
superpuissance
à deux doigts de la troisème guerre
mondiale. Hm
hm.
Tu as pas l'impression de faire de la
petite pognette pour les petits enfants
qui qui s'énerve pour délibérer pour un
chef de classe là ?
Alors justement non. Justement non parce
que je mets sous pression.
Non non mais bien sûr et c'est une très
pression
c'est pas de la branlette
intellectuelle.
Non. Alors la
est-ce que est-ce que les solutions en
terme
tu me dis quand je peux répondre ? Ben
je t'écoute.
OK. La branlette intellectuelle c'est
celle de gens qui se réunissent enfin
ton projet mec.
Je suis en train la branlette
intellectuelle comme tu l'appelles,
c'est celle de gens qui se réunissent en
comité privé et déclarent secret défense
les discussions autour de la gestion de
la crise Covid.
Et oui. Alors et là à ce moment-là ils
se mettent en secret défense. Ça veut
dire qu'il y a un ennemi. L'ennemi c'est
le virus. Il pourrait entendre les
réunions de secret défense. Non ça veut
dire que l'ennemi c'était nous.
Voilà c'est QFD. C'est ma réponse.
Alors, les mini publics délibératifs,
est-ce que tu veux que ça soit encore
une oligarchie élective euh qui pratique
la pédophilie pour une partie ? Parce
que maintenant, on en a la preuve, on en
a parlé. J'espère que ça nous aura servi
ce soir.
J'ai pas dit tous hein, j'ai dit pour
une partie. Non
néglable. Qu'est-ce que tu as dit
président que j'ai dit ?
Qu'on a pas les preuves justement, il y
d'indice mais à part. Alors, passons.
Très bien. On a des signaux faibles,
admettons. Mais enfin, tu veux laisser
tous ces gens-là qui fonctionnent euh
aujourd'hui qui carburent euh d'abord
avec un narcissisme hypertrophié qui est
quand même assez évident, excuse-moi,
mais ça c'est presque factuel, euh mais
qui surtout abuse de ce qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure, cybernétique, ingénierie
sociale, manipulation de masse pour
faire avancer leurs agendas. Voilà.
Alors, comme je le disais, les gens très
dangereux sont ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
capables d'abnégation pour se mettre
dans un groupe qui lui va euh essayer de
restaurer la souveraineté du peuple. Tu
es avec moi ?
Oui. Oui, bien sûr.
Tu regardes une question du public ? Je
suis en train de lire les questions du
public mais tu sais comme j'ai trois
cerveaux euh je suis capable de faire
trois trois choses en même temps.
C'est c'est vrai.
Continue.
Bon alors euh puisque tu parles de de
branl intellectuel si tu veux on peut
passer beaucoup de temps à parler de
tous ces conseils, toutes ces officines,
tous ces gens là qui ont les prébes de
la plutôt euh poser des questions à
président si tu veux.
Et toi tu as déconné de te mettre une
dinde sur la tête. Franchement si vous
arrivez à faire quelque chose avec le
coup de la la de la dinde sur la tête,
c'est bon. Ouais, je range mon chapeau.
Ouais bah tu vas voirêche pas l'autre.
Tu vas voir,
je vais voir quoi ? Ce qui va se passer,
ça va ?
Ça va être une vague populaire inédite.
Les gens attendent le président,
les gens attendent l'incarnation d'une
façon. De quoi ?
Le réclame
le réclame bien sûr. Dans la rue,
j'entends partout présidente. Président,
sauvez-nous. Euh, tu vois, ça c'est le
président qui parle.
Ça fait un peu grosis quand même he
mais c'est totalement grolandais. Mais
ça va encore un peu plus loin parce
qu'il y a le côté grotesque du chapeau
qui sert à rien. Ça permet de dénoncer
le fait que on nous vend des candidats
qui ont des projets, des programmes, des
machins. Non, ils ont simplement des
médias de milliardaires qui les poussent
devant disant "Allez-y, regardez, ils
ont un microparti mais ça joue quoi le
parti."
Je suis pas d'accord. Le le communistes
boss, ils bossent ils bossent sur
l'énergie. Je pense que c'est les seuls
qui sont penchés réellement sur le
dossier énergétique de tous les partis
politiques. Euh, tu peux pas mettre tous
les partis sur l'industrie, tu peux pas
mettre tout tout le monde dans le même
sac.
Non, je mets pas tout le monde. Je mets
ceux, on va dire les plus médiatiques.
Les communistes, je pense pas que ce
soit les plus médiatiques. On les
invite, ils viennent pas
ici.
Oui.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il paraît-il qu'on est
d'extrême droite.
Ah ben parce que tu as eu les articles
de Media Part avant déjà. Non non, on n
pas les articles de Mediaapart mais on a
eu des trucs de gauche qui nous
crachaient dessus parce qu'on avait
écouté des gens, on avait discuté avec
des gens des droite problème en fait de
de de cet enclos et qu'il faut briser
parce que derrière il faut pas les
briser, il faut faire sans eux.
Oui alors on fait sans eux, tant pis.
C'est eux qui enf c'est ça ça me fait
penser à ce mouvement je quitte X qui
avait il y a un an euh je sais pas
combien d'élus ont dit "Je quitte X de
de d'association de truc". Euh beaucoup
sont revenus comme ça sans le dire euh
parce que ben ailleurs il y a c'est pas
le mieux, c'est pareil. Euh Blue Sky bah
c'est bien, vous êtes entre vous, mais
même entre vous, vous arrivez à à créer
des des euh des chapelles, des gens qui
s'insultent et puis ça repart pareil.
Donc euh alors X, c'est affreux. Elon
Musk est un suprmaciste néonazie. Voilà,
tu peux dire ce que tu veux. Enfin
voilà, mais n'empêche que c'est là que
ça se passe. Donc tant pis, tu utilises
cet outil, tu sais les limites de
l'algorithme ou tu les sais pas. Mais
bon, je t'explique, c'est que voilà,
c'est tu es pas libre, il y a pas une
liberté d'expression.
Qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de la
perquisition au siège de X
récemment en France ? C'est ça va
exactement dans la suite de ce qui s'est
passé avec Telégram et Pavel Durof qui
avait été arrêté. Euh l'idée c'est
d'aller voir un peu ce qu'il y a dans
les dans les algorithmes euh dans les
tiroirs euh pour trouver au moins une
raison de faire fermer ses réseaux ou
les limiter leur portée parce
qu'aujourd'hui X euh emmerde les les les
milliardaires nationaux parce qu'il
prend trop d'audience.
C'est ton interprétation ?
C'est mon interprétation et je pense que
derrière enfin c'est un député Macronis
qui fait un signalement. C'est une juge
du parquet nommée par un gouvernement
macronis qui qui se charge de l'enquête.
Indépendante. Non. Bah oui, comme tout
comme t comme tous les juges en France
du parquet. Oui. Euh enfin, la justice
est politique. C'est quand même un truc
l'affaire Fillon qui arrive en pleine
campagne. Incroyable, incroyable. Sans
ça, il y avait pas Macron.
Mais merci la perquisition puisque ça
augmente drastiquement l'indice de de
respectabilité, d'attractivité de X. En
tout cas, pour les pour les les
réfractaires peut-être
les algos de X sont en open source nous
disentilot.
Oui, absolument. Donc c'est pour ça que
là
ont été mis à jour récemment
récemment. Ouais parce que c'est Grock
maintenant c'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui gère l'algo. Donc ça va
être n'importe quoi de toute façon mais
il faut être conscient de ce n'importe
quoi. Mais l'utiliser à dessin aussi et
se dire bon ben voilà on va on va jouer
avec. C'est il y a un côté ludique dans
tout ça et pas
pr il y aura une première dinde,
une première pentade.
Non, ça existe pas. C'est un poste qui
existe pas ça. Non non non. Par contre,
ce qu'il y a d'astucieux dans la notion
de président, c'est que en effet tous
ces gens qui se présentent ont une
obsession solutionniste. C'estàd qu'ils
ont la recette he donc là la recette de
la dame si tu veux.
C'est fou, ils ont un projet. Oui, c'est
vrai. Il y a même plus le programme. On
est passé du programme à une vision, un
chemin, un projet.
Voilà. Gluxman l'a dit, il a repris les
éléments de langagement en disant c'est
pas c'est le projet qui compte. Mais
bon, ça leur permet d'être flou. Mais en
même temps, il se présente comme
l'incarnation de la solution.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avant de passer aux
deux dernières questions ? Présidente.
Je trouve qu'on a
Il faut t'appeler Dindon, faut t'appeler
Dindounette, président Présidente.
Président Président, je
Tu baisseras les frais de fonctionnement
de ton pouloyer.
Ah, je baisse complètement tout. Euh
l'idée c'est de d'abord
ta première réforme ce sera quoi ?
Ma première réforme euh si j'étais élu
ce sera un référendum
sur la sortie de l'Union européenne ou
pas. Voilà. Oui. Oui. Euh parler alors
si si je puis me permettre je peux
choisir le sujet la carte.
Je suis magni
merci. Je suis grande.
Euh la stratégie euh du PIC consiste à
présenter en fait un collectif de telle
sorte que l'on soit une organisation
résiliente euh qui est 17 ou 33
personnes qui feront l'objet d'un tirage
au sort. C'est des gens qui ont fait
leur preuve dans la dissidence. Il y en
a beaucoup qui vont
Ça veut dire quoi la dissidence ? Alors
c'est une question de bon sens à vrai
dire et que j'assume totalement comme
telle. Nous avons l'intuition pour
beaucoup d'avoir des gens qui ont fait
le travail consistant à résister à cette
pression manipulatoire. D'accord ? C'est
le seul facteur, on dirait
potentiellement contradictoire de ce que
serait idéalement la démocratie
puisqu'il aurait fallu que les gens les
choisissent. Et ce que ce qui est notre
doctrine, c'est la suivante, c'est que
nous estimons que les événements ont
choisi ces gens. D'accord ? Mais il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait un seul homme ou
femme ou une seule femme providentielle.
Il faut qu'il y ait un groupe. Et donc
pour être totalement légaliste et
subvertir l'élection présidentielle, on
va pas refaire un coluche. D'ailleurs,
on a Patrick Sébastien maintenant,
d'accord ? On va faire un groupe qui dit
"Au lendemain de notre élection, au
lendemain de notre élection euh on met
en place une démocratie référendaire
intensifiée et on prend le temps qu'il
faut pour poser chaque mois des
questions aux gens pour leur permettre
de choisir
comme les Suisses."
Alors, c'est le système de la votation à
la Suisse mais encore amélioré et
intensifié en l'occurrence pour poser
toutes les questions qui fâchent. Et en
effet, voulez-vous sortir voulez-vous
sortir de l'Europe ? Voulez-vous
retrouver votre souveraineté monétaire ?
Voulez-vous geler la la submersion
migratoire ? Voulez-vous enc pas
d'autres sujets un peu plus cool,
hein ? Pardon ?
Il y a pas de sujet plus cool ?
Ah, de toute façon, on en a déjà listé
au moins une centaine et on estime
qu'une démocratie référendaire accélérée
pour rendre le pouvoir au peuple et
chois qu'il choisit son régime, ses
institutions et cetera, ça peut s'étaler
sur 18 ou 24 mois.
Et le pic, le pic c'est de droite, c'est
de gauche, c'est comment ?
Alors justement le pic, on bosse
ensemble parce qu'on est différent et
pas en dépit de nos différences. On va
chercher activement des gens qui nous
détestent idéologiquement et avec qui on
a envie de se crêper le chignon plus
tard. C'estàdire
ça tu m'as appelé.
Euh oui, c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
forcément les mêmes idéologiquement et
tant mieux. Euh c'est bien pour ça qu'on
a une amitié qui remonte à bien au-delà
euh du démarrage de Syerview et que je
suis jamais venu sur Syerview. Euh
voilà, donc c'est une forme d'honnêteté
intellectuelle et moi-même j'ai pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas demandé, tu vois. Voilà.
Donc qu'est-ce qui est intéressant dans
un collectif qui s'illustre par ce
pluralisme forcené ? D'accord. foré he
vraiment explicite qui est le cœur de la
doctrine, c'est le point de départ je le
répète he on ne bosse pas ensemble en
dépit de différence mais parce qu'on est
différent c'est parce qu'on a envie de
se retrouver sur un ring démocratique
d'accord pour refaire du débat plus tard
non mais c'est vrai on mettra les gants
dans un logiciel assignén donc on ne
veut plus être instrumentalisé on ne
veut plus être je sais pas moi
stigmatisé moqué caricaturé évidemment
labellisé
et labellisé étiqueté comme disait mon
philosophe préféré sur il disait il
n'est pire d'ation que celle d'être
catalogué d'accord on passe notre temps
à être catalogué loger et étiqueter.
Donc là, c'est une manière de dire ben
non, nous sommes insais parce que nous
sommes suffisamment nombreux et après ça
serait peut-être trop long à développer.
Tu vas m'engueuler. Bah,
ça fait 3h 14 interviews. Moi, moi
j'avais pas de montre, désolé.
Simplement, je voudrais dire que au-delà
de ce noyau dur, on va reprendre ce
qu'il y a de mieux dans toutes les
recherches qui ont été faites par des
chercheurs en sciences humaines qui
pendant des décennies se sont penchés
sur les courants de pensées
démocratiques, d'accord ? Pour voir ce
qui marche. Donc, on peut aller à 2500
ans en arrière en Grèce prendre le
fameux conseil des 500, d'accord ? des
citoyens tirés au sort pour certaines
décisions. D'accord ? Mais on peut aller
aussi dans les réflexions, je sais pas
moi, d'un Louis Blandioot que je
respecte énormément, qui est un prof à
Science Po qui a écrit sur la la
démocratie des émotions et qui montre
comment on peut détourner des débats
consultatifs pour en fait domestiquer
les gens et leur donner l'impression
qu'ils ont fait de la démocratie. Donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? B, on va
prendre en fait toutes ces recherches là
qu'on a synthétisé dans un travail, on
va dire, de vulgarisation. D'accord ?
Nous créons d'ailleurs là en ce moment
même l'observatoire l'observatoire
français he de la pensée démocratique
qu'appelle beaucoup de gens de leur
veœux. Nous n'avons pas ça pour faire un
travail de synthèse. Et quand là déjà on
aura réussi donc par plusieurs strates à
réunir les citoyens les plus motivés
mais attention je suis bien en train de
le dire, je suis pas en train de dire
tout le monde va se réveiller demain en
disant ah super il y a une idée
démocratique. C'est pas ce qu'on dit.
C'est un petit groupe de personnes très
déterminées.
Il y a le président qui veut mettre un
mot.
Ouais moi moi je parce que tu diras
peut-être m
lève la main. Lève la main
chef. chef.
Le point
euh le point ou plutôt euh non en fait
c'est c'est le principe de de créer
l'alternative. Aujourd'hui, on a un
système qui est qui est incassable,
enfin très difficilement à câble, qui
fonctionne tout seul, quasiment sans
vote, sans vote, sans citoyen, un taux
d'abstention énorme, mais ça suffit à
exister et donc il faut ça prendra le
temps qu'il faut mais trouver justement
l'alternative ça et et si on fait pas ça
aujourd'hui, il faut il faut jouer sur
tous les sur tous les ponts, ce système
aujourd'hui et la suite parce que
effectivement la réalité, c'est ce que
tu rappelais tout à l'heure, c'est une
réalité énergétique. catastrophique,
démographique catastrophique,
un monde proche de la trème guerre
mondiale et personnes au pouvoir depuis
plusieurs années avec une vision
stratégique d'une taupe morte quoi. Donc
ils savent pas où ils vont, ils vont ta
borne
morte je pense. Euh il voit rien. Enfin
c'est le présitope.
Ouais là on a le présitope. Ouais c'est
un autre concept à explorer
et et donc la réalité est tragique. Ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut baisser les
bras. C'est ce qu'on disait sur le début
hein, sur le fait de la désolation et
que bon bah c'est comme ça et on peut
rien faire. Bon si on a encore l'énergie
de se dire qu'on peut faire quelque
chose, faisons-le.
Bon je je vous ai écouté euh sans vous
sans vouloir vous manquer de respect,
vous me faites penser à un gros honverse
l'autoroute.
Le gros Tu vois ce que c'est un gros hon
?
Ouais. Ouais. Ça pas vite. Ça vite. Il
vole pas vite. Tu l'entends ? Je
traverse, je traverse. Bon et là, il y a
un 33 ton qui passe à 95 km/h et là ça
fait ploc.
Mais si tu permets, j'ai une réponse.
Non, je permets pas.
Donc euh c'est gentil, c'est c'est
gentil, c'est beau.
Sauf que on est dans un climat de guerre
économique, des psychopathes tout autour
de la France
et vous avez pas trop le principe de de
de créer en fait des sparciates
guerriers pour résister à tout ça.
Mais les sparciates guerriers, on les a.
On a on a on est censé avoir une armée,
on est censé avoir de l'intelligence
économique, du renseignement. De quoi ?
De quoi ?
Bah non, ils sont pas là.
Ben non.
Non.
Tu as vu quelque chose ?
On m'aurait menti.
Je sais pas.
Peut-être la mondaine.
Mais bon.
Alors, la réponse au Hanton qui traverse
la route, c'est que tu n'en vois qu'un
seul. Tu es encore coincé dans le
paradigme de du Hanton providentiel.
Imagine une armée de Hon pourra pas tous
les tuer.
Non mais tu vas pouvoir créer un énorme
accident parce que quand on 4 quand on
ton 33 tonnes,
il aura le pare-brise avec plus de
liquide laveglace et il aura écrasé 100.
Mais le 33 tonn c'est celui-là dont on
veut se débarrasser. Ça tombe bien
c'est tu veux ralentir ?
Non, on veut se débarrasser du précédent
système.
Alors d'accord. Alors je t'explique. Le
33 ton c'est singing ping.
H
d'accord. Tu vas dire à Singing Ping on
va se débarrasser de toi.
Pourquoi ? Est-ce que tu penses que
l'oligarchie élective actuelle va nous
nous aider à lutter contre la Chine ?
Le Groon actuellement, c'est plutôt ce
qu'on a.
On doit remettre la France au travail
honnêtement.
Non mais blague à part blague à part la
raison pour laquelle les gens se
compotent comme des espèces de monades
urbaines tous déconnectés les uns des
autres, fragmentés, atomisés dans tous
les sens, complètement en trans
hypnotique, c'est parce que il n'y a
plus aucune sensation d'appartenance de
transcendance collective qui nous
permettrait en fait de se remettre au
travail.
Comprends pourquoi je te dis que ça
ressemble à rien votre truc ?
Oui,
j'essaie de vous faire
Moi, je te je te comprends parce que je
pense que c'est pas assez simple, c'est
pas assez clair et aujourd'hui les gens
ils vont nous regarder, ils vont dire
"Mais qu'est-ce que de quoi de quoi il
parle ? De quoi de quoi on parle ?" Bah
on parle en fait de se dire le système
actuel c'est le groson, c'est clair. Et
si Jing Ping il a un 33 tonnes, Trump il
a un monster truck avec son effigie
devant et des cornes de buffle, tu vois,
avec l'autoradio. Adon
avec l'autoradio. Mais on revient
àoccratie. Tu vois, ça finit comme ça,
tu vois, avec ce duel dans l'arène pour
ce qu'on utile. On est bien dans
Donc on est bien là-dedans. Et le but,
c'est de dire c'est c'est qu'un début.
L'idée c'est aujourd'hui il y a un
système, il faut jouer avec, il faut le
évidemment l'analyser, en poser les
limites, le ridiculiser aussi. Le manque
de satire c'est tragique hein. C'est
vraiment quelque chose qui qui plombe
les gens aussi. Le fait de pas pouvoir
se moquer de ces gens qui sont pourtant
facilement ridicules à se prendre au
sérieux. Et donc il il y a cette partie
là puis il y a la partie
est une arme cognitive
sérieuse qui dit bah voilà on va
construire
un rassemblement populaire un truc
beaucoup plus large qui qui est pas qui
est pas de l'ordre du parti parce que
c'est vrai qu'un parti aujourd'hui c'est
c'est ce truc qui va prendre une part du
gâteau et dire moi je suis là je suis
bien on est d'accord on se fait nos nos
petits alliances c'est ce qu'on vit
actuellement ce qu'on veut c'est
dépasser ce cadre partisan tu parlais
des communistes qui viennent pas ici bah
voilà c'est leur choix ils sont pris
dans ce dans ce jeu du de la barre du
gâteau. Il faut dépasser ça parce que
c'est là que sont les abstentionnistes.
là sont les gens qui ont baissé la tête.
Mais si on leur offre quelque chose qui
va être beaucoup plus simple et qui est
de dire bon écoute aujourd'hui c'est pas
simple, je suis d'accord, le pic n'est
pas simple, c'est pas assez simplifié
pour que beaucoup de gens se disent on y
va et on va penser collectivement et on
va mettre en place ces référendums
citoyens et on va réfléchir à une
nouvelle organisation démocratique. Ça
paraît au-dessus de nos forces, ça
paraît compliqué de la branlette
intellectuelle et pourtant c'est
nécessaire, c'est même indispensable
parce que sans
le diagnostic est fait. Enfin, le
système tel qu'on le vit progressivement
se transformer en dictature, mais
progressivement, gentiment, hein. Alors,
gentiment avec des gens éborniers, des
gens qui vont disparaître, des gens qui
vont aller en prison. Enfin, plus le
niveau va augmenter, plus ça va être
compliqué de se dire qu'on est en
démocratie. Mais on trouvera toujours
des petites pirhouettes pour dire qu'on
est en démocratie, même si on y sera
plus avec le technocrôle qui va être
vraiment dangereux. Ça c'est un monde
que je veux éviter. Ça c'est un monde
que je veux éviter. Alors peut-être
c'est l'ubris hein, c'est l'ego, c'est
la folie, c'est parce que j'ai du temps.
Euh
c'est l'endrouse,
c'est la la crise de la cinquantaine,
j'en sais rien. Euh mais je me dis enfin
j'ai des gosses. Euh la France c'est un
beau pays qui a vraiment tellement de
qualité. Euh si on part du principe
qu'aujourd'hui sa seule chance c'est de
se barrer ou de dire à ses gosses de se
barrer, alors c'est non, c'est affreux.
Moi je suis fier d'être français. J'aime
mon pays, c'est un beau pays qui mérite
qu'on l'aime et qui mérite qu'on se
batte pour lui et pour les gosses et
pour tous ceux qui se battent pas non
plus. Et de dire "Mais aujourd'hui, on a
affire à des gens qui maintenant c'est
officiel sont dans des cercles
globalistes, transatlantiques, que ce
soit la trilatérale, le Builderberg, le
World Economic Forum, tous son côté.
Donz la trilatérale ?
Bien sûr.
Tu as déjà été à la trilatérale ?
Non.
D'où viennent tes informations de la
trilatérale
? Elles sont sur internet, c'est encore
des informations en source ouverte. euh
Kir Starmer qui travaillait pour la
trilatérale alors que il il travaillait
à l'époque pour Tony Blair sans le dire.
Euh enfin voilà, c'est euh donc
c'est quoi la trilatérale ?
C'est l'équivalent d'un d'un builderb.
C'est c'est le c'est c'est-à-dire c'est
le cercle néoconservateur. Nous on
connaît le l'ancien vice-président de la
commission trilatérale Europe.
Ça c'est chouette. Ça c'est chouette. Il
est venu ici ?
Oui deux fois.
Et alors ? Alors, on lui a posé des
questions quand il faisait des
conneries, l'impact général de la
population et il nous a dit euh bon bah
quand il y en a un des nôre qui fait des
conneries euh bon on l'attrape quand
même un peu pour lui dire doucement.
Ouais. Voilà. Bon ben alors c'est club
club euh très bien mais euh ça va pas
plus loin que ça. C'est-à-dire ça reste
un club de gens cooptés qui vont faire à
peu près tout le temps les mêmes
erreurs. Aujourd'hui euh c'est c'est
important d'éviter ça de se dire bon on
on l'évitera pas. Peut-être qu'on
l'évitera pas. Partons d'un principe
pessimiste que euh le processus est
tellement enclenché.
Est-ce que le pic discuterait par
exemple si a la trilatérale qui lui tend
la main pour dire là on peut partager
nos ressources intellectuelles,
vous accepteriez ou pas ?
Alors moi personnellement oui,
j'accepterai de parler à tout le monde
euh par principe évidemment. Euh ça veut
pas dire pour autant qu'on va être
d'accord et qu'on va faire quelque
chose. Mais bien sûr. Oui.
D'ailleurs, on l'a emmené chez toi le le
vice-président de la commission
trilatérale il y a des années.
Exact. Je m'en rappelle.
Euh, on arrive à la fin. Tu veux finir
ta phrase ?
Rejoignez l'aventure
du pic pic.
Et ouais.
Donc
pic pic et colégramme tant qu'à faire.
Non, bourré bourré rat. Pic pic
fuse pas, je t'aide.
Il y aura il y aura un conseil de des
ministres, un conseil de petite caille,
un conseil de quoi ? Ah non, il y aura
rien de tout ça. Il y aura des des des
votations citoyennes. Il y aura l'idée
de de faire en sorte que les enfin
d'abord euh les grandes décisions
stratégiques, moi je suis pour le retour
d'un grand commissariat au plan mais un
vrai, pas le truc de François Baou. Euh
non mais regardez le le euh la magie des
30 glorieuses, c'est quand même le plan
calcul. C'est le fait d'avoir à l'époque
une industrie qui permettait d'avoir
Alstom de faire du TGV, du Concorde et
cetera. Aujourd'hui, on a plus tout ça.
Donc déjà, on va on repart de zéro
quasiment. C'est un truc assez grave.
Euh donc on va pas se voiler la face,
hein. Euh c'est c'est de toute façon, on
a deux choix. Soit on va dans le mur et
c'est le FMI qui s'occupe de nous et ce
sera un traitement à la grec XXL parce
que c'est la France et qu'il faudra
aller plus vite. Soit on passe une
période de vache maigre difficile mais
qu'on a choisi et on essaie de faire
autre chose, c'est tout.
Et on pourrait s'avérer bien plus
puissant que tout ce qu'on avait pu
anticiper.
Frédéric, trois livres à conseiller à la
communauté.
Tu peux passer un dernier message
néanmoins sur le pic ?
Vas-y.
Le pic, c'est le ric en toute matière.
Donc ça, il faut le dire pour ceux qui
attendent ça. D'accord ?
C'est une chansons.
Le pixel Ric en toute matière. Et le le
le point fondamental de cette démarche,
c'est que là, on n plus le temps de de
développer, mais on arrive à concilier
tous les courants de pensée démocratique
dans une méthode syncrétique. Voilà,
désolé pour les grands mots mais c'est
très important que les gens qui
s'intéressent à cette cause là le
comprennent. Ensuite, il disait "Certes,
c'est compliqué branlête intellectuel,
tu peux dire tout ce que tu veux, mais
tu sais quoi ? On le sait depuis le
départ parce qu'on ne cherche pas la
communication de masse. On veut d'abord
les éclaireurs qui peuvent rejoindre
justement cette équipe commando." OK.
dans laquelle il y a d'autres personnes
comme Alexis qui ont beaucoup de
visibilité qui disent et qui m'écrivent
en privé même des politiques anciens qui
vont sortir du bois qui sont là depuis
longtemps et qui disent "Mais en fait
ton idée c'est la meilleure" et certains
me l'ont écrit par texto. Donc ils
disent "On a plus d'autre choix, on doit
changer de système ou le système va nous
détruire." H
voilà
trois livres. Alors, trois livres, je
commencerai par
bon référence à tout le plateau là,
Grégory Bon, l'écologie de l'esprit,
vous allez comprendre la construction
d'une pensée manipulatoire avec la
justification d'un génie. Le mec est un
génie, c'est passionnant à lire et il
explique en fait comment notre esprit
fonctionne en osmose avec
l'environnement. Tu changes
l'environnement, tu manipules les
esprits, c'est ce qu'ils font. Donc ça
permet de comprendre beaucoup de choses
pour conclure les plateaux. Après, j'ai
deux autres livres à conseiller qui me
tiennent très très à cœur. Euh le
premier, c'est l'être à un jeune poète
de Renard Maria Rilk. Ce livre m'a m'a
m'a sauvé la vie à un moment où j'étais
vraiment très très bas. J'étais je
sortais de l'adolescence mais euh ça a
été une révélation. Et il est
l'année dernière hein.
C'était l'année dernière.
Oui, merci. Je suis transagiste et enfin
quelqu'un a compris que j'avais besoin
d'être rajuni de quelques décennies.
Merci. Tu me sauves. Ouf ! C'est bon.
Euh
il est très euh
puissant ce livre pour tous ceux qui qui
vont mal en ce moment et qui se posent
des questions sur leur propre identité.
Euh puisque le concept du livre c'est 10
lettres incroyablement spontané,
magnifique, c'est de la très grande
littérature pour ceux qui aiment.
Connaî pas du tout.
Et c'est voilà et donc c'est un c'est un
c'est un aspirant poète qui existe qui
hésite entre deux carrières et qui écrit
un poète très installé qui met un temps
foi à lui répondre. D'ailleurs, les 10
lettes sont étalées sur des mois et des
mois. Et en fait, le poète installé
l'aide à réfléchir euh à la bonne
manière de ne pas sacrifier son âme sur
l'hôtel de la simple réussite sociale,
du statut social.
Il fait du mentoring.
Il fait un mentoring avant l'heure, mais
d'une puissance et d'une beauté. Voilà.
Et puis euh le 3è, alors j'incite tout
le monde à lire euh
passionnant et pas trop compliqué, un
spécialiste de Spinoza mais qui a fait
un petit livre super simple qui est qui
est court qui s'appelle je crois Loin de
moi. C'est un essai sur l'identité
inspiré euh donc euh de toutes les
réflexions de de Spinoza puisqu'on
parlait des patients tristes, ça m'y a
fait penser.
Et c'est d'autant plus extraordinaire
comme livre
qu'il comment dire que tu reçois un
électrochoc dès les premières pages
quand il t'explique avec Brio Clément
Rossé ce spécialiste de Spinoza dès les
premières pages il t'explique que ce que
tu croyais être ce qu'il appelle
d'ailleurs la préidentité c'estàd que ce
que tu croyais être euh ta personne ton
statut et cetera euh en te construisant
tout ça n'existe pas tant que tu n'es
pas euh en interaction avec le reste du
monde. Il dit à vrai dire le mythe
roussoauiste de l'identité du bon
sauvage qui sort de l'œuf et qui a le
cœur pur et est est une absurdité. Il le
démontre avec briot. Après, on sera
d'accord, pas d'accord. Mais je
conseille à tout le monde de le lire.
Attends, je dis juste pourquoi. Parce
que en ce moment la première des choses
dont nous sommes dépossédés, c'est de
notre identité. On a besoin en quelque
sorte d'être, comme disent les psy,
renarcissisé à l'hône de cette
gouvernance perverse. Tu as fait une
psychothérapie
quand j'étais ados. Oui, parce que parce
que je suis j'ai été élevé par une maman
solo et que j'ai eu une bonne
prédisposition à être là ce soir. Tout
tout ce que j'ai vécu avant m'a amené
ici. Pourquoi ? Parce que quand tu quand
tu n'as pas eu de père, que le père a
été démissionnaire, tu as deux
possibilités. Soit tu t'enfermes dans
l'utérus artificiel de la la tendresse
maternelle, soit tu deviens toi-même un
un petit père, si j'ose dire,
c'est-à-dire responsable. Moi, j'ai
grandi dans un HLM, donc j'ai pas eu
d'autre choix que de me faire tout seul.
J'ai fini par faire, voilà, des grandes
écoles, des diplômes et cetera. J'en ai
chié. super boî
mais et j'ai fait des super boîtes. J'ai
vécu 10 ans aux États-Unis après avoir
revendu ma première entreprise. Après,
j'ai eu des échecs évidemment très
nombreux et quelques petites réussite
espoir que les échecs furent
flamboyants.
Mais pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce que Non,
mais pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce que il y
en a plein peut-être qui vont vouloir
m'écrire, qui vont dire "J'ai vécu la
même chose que toi." En fait, on se
construit évidemment en fonction de ça.
Quand il y a pas le père, soit on le
crée, soit on ne l'a jamais. D'accord ?
Et en fait, c'est la parfaite
transposition de ce qu'on vit à
l'échelle collective. Nous avons un état
papa tantôt démissionnaire, tantôt
violent, mais qui ne se trouve pas et
qui et qui n'est jamais crédible. Et ça
nous amène à questionner finalement
notre identité par voie de conséquence
logique.
Président, trois livres,
euh journal d'un prisonnier. Non, je
déconne. Euh,
c'est de Nicolas Sarkozy,
il semble, il me semble. Ouais. de de
Victo
euh l'homme sans qualité de Robert Musil
parce que ça montre toutes ces ces
usines à gaz de euh de single tank,
d'aéropage de gens qui savent de comité
olympiques et cetera, mais qui ça
remonte à loin en fait cette histoire
euh sous le soleil de sa tente Bernanos
parce que voilà, c'est la France qu'on
aime, c'est un livre très fort euh sur
la foi, sur plein de choses. Et puis en
trois trois livres, ça réduit beaucoup
le champ des possibles.
Si tu si tu arrives pas à m'en trouver
un troisème, tu me récites un poème. Non
non, j'ai le troisème mais c'est par
défaut c'est nous autres de de Yévgen
Zamiatin
qui est en fait la première
œuvre de dystopie de science-fiction
avant 84, avant le meilleur des mondes
et cetera, écrit par un russe dans les
années 20 et qui montre une société
totalitaire.
C'est encore ton tropisme popovien. Mais
encore les popofs euh et tout est là en
fait, tout est écrit euh et ça finit
avec une opération offerte par l'État
nounou et cetera. C'est très fort aussi
comme livre.
Alexis Poulin, un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable.
Euh pour les jeunes générations,
ben le même conseil qu'avait fait un
pape, c'est n'ayez pas peur. Faut pas
avoir peur.
C'est prés pap.
Non, c'est vraiment un message fort
parce que la peur peut être mauvaise
conseillère, elle est aussi un moteur.
Mais globalement, on joue trop sur les
peurs à l'heure actuelle. Donc je trouve
que il y a il y a beaucoup trop de
jeunes qui s'enferment dans le
l'écoanxiété, plein de conneries comme
ça. Enfin de dire "Mon dieu,
nostalgie,
enfin tu peux trouver plein. L'idée
c'est que les jeunes vont mal, ils ont
peur, ils font pas d'enfant et cetera.
Ils peuvent pas en même temps on leur
dit votre avenir c'est pas grand-chose.
Le
prix du mètre carré, on
le prix du mètre carré, le fait qu'ils
ont fait des études pour rien. Tu as pas
de tout bib à la fin on va te proposer
d'aller sur le front de l'Est. Enfin
bref, il y a pas grand-chose qui fait
que tu as envie de d'aller vo donc ne
pas avoir peur, c'est quand même super
important dans ce cadre là. Et puis
surtout d'utiliser son cerveau, ça ça
aide aussi. Ça permet de débloquer des
choses.
Fred
pratiquer
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Alors conseil pour les jeunes
générations, apprenez que poser de
bonnes questions est toujours beaucoup
plus puissant que de chercher des
réponses toutes faites. Et en ce sens,
nous avons
comme limon puissant culturel
extrêmement fertile donc dans notre
civilisation, quelque chose qui a
commencé il y a des siècles de ça. On va
à minima remonter à 2500 ans. Euh c'est
la dialectique quoi. L'art de poser les
bonnes questions. la maillotique de
Socrate. Et moi mon pseudonyme sur X
c'est parisiaste. Le parisiaste fait une
référence à ce que les Grecs appelaient
la parésia. C'est le soin qu'on apporte
à tout dire sans filtre. Mais point clé,
il y a de l'humilité derrière. Ça veut
pas dire je dis tout et j'ai raison. Il
y a aucune prétention à dire la vérité,
mais c'est accepter d'être dans une
sorte de candur transparente et de dire
les choses. Ça permet de dire les
problèmes, de travailler son esprit
critique et de dialectiser avec ceux qui
voudront débattre avec nous quand on a
le courage de mettre les pieds dans le
plat et de nommer les problèmes au lieu
de s'enfermer dans cette fameuse matrice
qui nous aveugle.
Messieurs, merci.
Merci.
Merci cher ami.